ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM. THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER BRING THE ABSENT
MEMBERS AND THE CLERK WILL CALL
THE ROLL AGUIAR-CURRY. ARAMBULA
BAUER-KAHAN BERMAN. HELLO BLOOM
BURNER **** BATH. BONTA BRO
BURKE CALDERON CARRILLO
CERVANTES CHAU CHEN DAVID CHIU
CHOI. KANSEN CHU COOLEY COOPER.
CUNNINGHAM DALY DEEP. EGGMAN
FLORA FONG FRAZIER READ MEN
GABRIEL. GALLAGHER CRISTINA
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON
LAURIA GONZALEZ IS GRAY GRAYSON
HOLDEN IRWIN JONES SAWYER.
KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE KILEY
LACKEY LEVINE LIMON LOW
MAIENSCHEIN. MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
SU CHI THIS AARON. OBERNOLTE
O'DONNELL. PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA
RAMOS. YES THREE OF US. RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO. SALAS SANTIAGO
SMITH STONE. TEEN VOEPEL
WALDRON WEBER WICKS WOOD MISTER
SPEAKER
. MEMBERS PLEASE REPORT
TO THE FLOOR. SO WE MAY
ESTABLISH QUORUM AND MOVED THE
BUSINESS OF THE HOUSE MEMBERS
PLEASE REPORT TO THE FLOOR
.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT THE
ASSEMBLY. WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER. BE OFFERED BY
OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN THE
REVEREND PATTY OSHA OVERDOSED.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION. I'LL BE BRIEF
REFLECTION ON LOVE. FORTUNATE
IS IT TO BE BORN INTO A LIFE
EVEN MORE FORTUNATE IS IT TO BE
BORN INTO A LOVING ENVIRONMENT
AND EVEN MORE FORTUNATE THAN
THIS IS TO LEARN TO LIVE A
LOVING LIFE. WHEN ASKED WHAT IS
YOUR RELIGION THE DALAI LAMA
RESPONDED. MY RELIGION IS
KINDNESS. LEARNING TO LOVE
BEGINS WITH OUR KINDNESS AND
CARING FOR OTHERS. REALIZING
THAT ALL LIFE IS INTERCONNECTED
IN ONE IS THE SEED OF KINDNESS
AND COMPASSION. IS THE SEED
THAT GROWS INTO A LOVING LIFE.
NOW MONNING THEM WITH KINDNESS
AND GRATITUDE BEYOND WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON AS HE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE MISTER
GIBSON. THANK YOU PLEASE JOIN
ME PUTS RIGHT HERE OF YOUR
HEART READY AGAIN. AND THE SAN.
NATION UNDER GOD INDIVISIBLE.
THIS CALL. THANK YOU MAY BE
SEATED. READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO THURSDAY AUGUST
TWENTY NINTH TWENTY NINETEEN
THESE ONLY MET AT SEVEN AM
AUDIBLE WILLIAM P. BRO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SEVENTY THIRD DISTRICT
PRESIDING TO COOKIE DOTSON
WILSON AT THE DESK NGUYEN QUICK
KATHLEEN AND LOUIS READING. THE
BONTA PLACE ONE MISTER CALDERON
MOVES AND MR MAYES SECONDS THAT
THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS EMITATIONS THERE
ARE NONE INTRODUCTION REFERENCE
TO BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED. MESSAGES FROM
THE GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE. THERE
ARE NONE. MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THERE ARE NO
ABSENCES TODAY
. MOVING TO
PROCEDURAL MOTIONS. MEMBERS
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE
SEVENTY SEVEN POINT TWO. I AM
RE REFER IN THE FOLLOWING BILLS
TO COMMITTEE. ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY SIX A. B. FOURTEEN FIFTY
FOUR JONES SAWYER TO THE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE. ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY SEVEN A. B. FIFTEEN
TWENTY TWO LOW TO THE BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE. ITEM
THIRTY THREE AB EIGHTEEN
SIXTEEN DAILY TO THE INSURANCE
COMMITTEE. ITEM NUMBER SIXTY A.
B. TWO FIVE THREE. MARK STONE
TO THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
ITEM NUMBER SIXTY ONE AB TWO
FIVE SIX AGUIAR-CURRY TO THE
WATER PARKS AND WILDLIFE
COMMITTEE. ITEM NUMBER SIXTY
SEVEN AB FOUR ONE FOUR BONTA TO
THE HEALTH COMMITTEE. ITEM
NUMBER SEVENTY SIX AB SEVEN
FIFTEEN THIS AREA INTO THE
HEALTH COMMITTEE. I DON'T KNOW
NUMBER EIGHTY AB SEVEN FIVE
NINE BIGELOW TO THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE. AND
FINALLY ITEM NINETY TWO AB
ELEVEN NINETY ONE BONTA TO THE
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE
.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE
.
SECOND READING CLERK READ
SENATE BILL TWO EIGHTY SIX. ALL
BILLS HAVE BEEN DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MORNING
. MEMBERS WE AREN'T
CONCURRENCE WE ARE TAKEN
CONCURRENCE ITEMS. WE'RE GOING
TO PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE
ITEMS TWO AND THREE PASS A
RETAIN A FILE ITEM FOR. WE WILL
BEGIN A FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE
THAT'S AB SIX NINE FIVE BY
MISTER MEDINA. ASSEMBLY BILL
SIX NINETY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MEDINA AND
ACTUALLY THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
MR MEDINA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY I PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX NINETY FIVE
THIS BILL EXTENDS THE CURRENT
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
THE SIGN BILLS STATUTE UNTIL
TWENTY THIRTY SENATE AMENDMENTS
OUR TECHNICAL AND CLARIFYING IN
NATURE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
MEDINA SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CALL THE ROLL ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THOSE. ALL
MEMBERS LOW WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSER ALL TIED
ABOUT ICE FORTY ONE NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. WE'RE GOING TO PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM SIX.
WE ARE GOING TO PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM SEVEN.
PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEM EIGHT
FILE ITEM NINE. IS AB THIRTEEN
FORTY FOR A CORPORATE ASSEMBLY
WILL THIRTEEN FORTY FOUR BY
SOME THE MEMBER OF OUR QUE HAN
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO
PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION
WAS BARRICADED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES
AB THIRTEEN FORTY FOUR IS BACK
BEFORE YOU ONE CONCURRENCE
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE ENATE
REMOVED ALL OPPOSITION BY
ADDING CLARIFYING LANGUAGE THE
BILL HAS RECEIVED OVERWHELMING
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
WELL OF THE ROLE. ALL MEMBER
SERVICE AT ABOUT. ALL MEMBERS
OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE. CLARK
WELL. ZERO TADARISE FORTY EIGHT
NO ZERO SEVEN AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN PASS TEMPORARILY
ON FILE ITEM TEN. WE WILL TAKE
A FILE ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN A. B.
NINE TWENTY SEVEN. OPERATE
ASSEMBLY WILL NINE TWENTY SEVEN
BY SOME REMEMBER JONES SAWYER
AND ACTUALLY TO CRIMES MISTER
JONES SAWYER AB NINE TWO SEVEN
HIS BACK WAS SENATE AMENDMENTS
WHICH WERE NEGOTIATED WITH
JUDICIAL COUNCIL TO EASE
IMPLEMENTATION AND CUT DOWN ON
COURT WORKLOAD. MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. TECHNICIAN SOURCING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. RESERVE AT ALL
MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF
. TAKES
FORTY ONE MEMBERS. ALL MEMBERS
OF THE DESIRED ABOUT. GEN
.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT ICE FORTY ONE KNOWS TO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO GO
BACK TO THE TOP OF THE
CONCURRENCE FILE. FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO AB SIX NINE CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE SIXTY NINE BY
SELLING MEMBER LACKEY AND
ACTUALLY THE GUIDE SIGNAL AND
SERVICE DOGS. MR LACKEY. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AB
ONE SIXTY NINE IS BACK ON THE
SENATE WITH THEIR CHANGES. AND
THE BILL PROVIDES FOR GUIDE
SIGNAL SERVICE DOGS THAT ARE ON
AN OFF DUTY. AND AT SAID SOLD
SUPPORT WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
OF BARK THANK YOU. A RICH
LACKEY SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE
CLERICAL OF THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS OTHERS ARE THE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE A ROLL
TIDE ABOUT EYES FIFTY TWO NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE. THIS IS DOCTOR EGGMAN
FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE AB THREE
THREE THREE CORPORATION
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE THIRTY
THREE BY SOME REMEMBER EGGMAN
AND OTHERS AND EXPLAIN THE
COUNTY PATIENTS RIGHTS
ADVOCATES DOCTOR EGGMAN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AS A SPEAKER AB
THREE THREE THREE IS BACK FROM
CONCURRENCE AND SENATE
AMENDMENTS WHICH WERE MINOR
HOUSING HAVING TO DO WITH WHAT
PROTECTING. WHISTLE BLOWERS I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE GLOBAL OF THE
ROLL. OUT OF VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE. WHO DESIRED ABOUT. CLARK
WELL. CLOSER ALL TIED ABOUT
EYES FORTY ONE KNOWS TEN SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
FILE ITEM SEVEN. IS AB FIVE
EIGHTY EIGHT. COREY ASSEMBLY
BILL FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT I
SOMETHING MEMBER CHEN AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO ANIMAL
SHELTERS DOCTOR CHEN. THANK YOU
SPEAKER AB FIVE EIGHTIES BACK
INSTEAD ON CONCURRENCE WITH
MINOR CLARIFY ADJUSTMENTS THIS
BILL HAS HAD NO VOTES IN EITHER
HOUSE. AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. SEEING THE
RECESSION OF A LOCAL OF THE
ROLE. IT IS OUT OF IT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE AND DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF A
NICE FIFTY ONE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS WE ARE JUMPING TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER TEN. AB THIRTEEN
NINETY ONE COVERAGE ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTEEN NINETY ONE BY
SOMETHING MEMBER BONTA AND
ACTUALLY TO ELECTIONS MR BONTA
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES A. B. THIRTEEN
NINETY ONE IS BACK ON
CONCURRENT A MINOR AMENDMENT
WAS TAKEN IN THE SENATE TO
REDUCE COSTS THAT HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT RESPECTFULLY ASK DR OUT.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK
LIBERAL. THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT
EYES FIFTY SIX NOW ZERO SENATOR
MEMBERS HER CONCURRED IN
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO TAKE A
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWELVE. AB
FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN BY DR
CHANDLER RATE. ASSEMBLY BILL
FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN BY
SELLING NUMBER TEN AND ACTUALLY
LOCAL GOVERNMENT. DOCTOR CHEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
FORTY THIRTY SEVEN IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE IT IS A DISTRICT
BILL THAT WILL HELP TO SEE A
BRAND REFER TAX DOLLARS BACK TO
THE PARAMEDIC PROGRAM. AB FORTY
THREE SUMMERS OR HOW 2% OF THE
PARAMEDIC TAX TO FUND THE
PARAMEDIC PROGRAM AND THEREBY
FULLY IMPLEMENT THE RITUAL
PURPOSE OF THE TAX AS APPROVED
BY THE VOTERS. THIS BILL HAS
HUGE BYE PORES SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK DR VOTE. THEY
ARE CHEN C. NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE CORPORAL. RESERVE OF ALL
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS ARE DESIRABLE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT
I FIFTY SIX AS FIFTY SEVEN NO
ZERO SEVEN MEMBERS ARE
CONCURRED IN THIS IS FILE ITEM
THIRTEEN AB EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BY THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY AND
ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC RECORDS MR
STONE YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I MEMBERS THIS
BILL IS BACK FROM THE SENATE
THIS IS A BILL THAT ALLOWS US
TO USE CELL PHONES AND OTHER
PERSONAL DEVICES WHEN MAKING
RECORDS IN ORDER TO MAKE COPIES
OF RECORDS THROUGH THE P. R. A-
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE MINOR
ENSURE THAT WE'RE PROTECTING
THE DOCUMENTS THAT ARE. BEING
COPIED SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR CONCURRENCE INSIDE AND
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU MISTER
JOHN SAYING NO DISCUSSION OF A.
CLARK LIBERAL MEMBERS DESIRE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE. DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE
THE- CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL
TIDE OF AN ICE FIFTY NINE NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. THIS IS FILE ITEM
FOURTEEN AB FIVE FIVE ONE CORY.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE FIVE ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BRO AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY IN A FATAL THE
HECK YOU ACCIDENTS MISTER ROWE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
FIVE FIVE ONE IS BACK ON
CONCURRENT FROM THE SENATE THIS
IS AN EFFORT BY TOXICOLOGISTS
AND MY LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
IMPROVE THE FORENSIC TESTING
AND DATA COLLECTED IN FATAL
VEHICLE ACCIDENTS. AB FIVE FIVE
ON WILL UPDATE CURRENT LAW
REQUIRED DRUG TESTING AFTER
FATAL COLLISIONS IN ADDITION TO
ALCOHOL TESTING COLLECTING MORE
ACCURATE DATA IN ESTABLISHING
STATEWIDE PRACTICES WILL HELP
CREATE BETTER POLICIES. TO
PROTECT OUR COMMUNITIES IN THE
FUTURE THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE THE.
THINGS ROASTING NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE CORPS CORPORAL. ALL
MEMBERS PHONES ARE THE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ADAMO CLERK WELL
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT EYES FOR
THE NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM
FIFTEEN AB TEN SEVENTY SIX
CORPORATE ASSEMBLY BILL TEN
SEVENTY SIX BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TING AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
THE CRIMINAL RECORDS MISTER
KING. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
A. B. TEN SEVENTY SIX IS BACK
ON CONCURRENT THE BILL REQUIRES
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO
AUTOMATE ARREST AND CONVICTION
RELIEF FOR ELIGIBLE INDIVIDUALS
AMENDMENTS IN THE SENATE MADE
THE BILL PRO SPECTER OF A
CONTINGENT UPON FUNDING THE
AMENDMENTS REMOVED OPPOSITION
FROM THE CALIFORNIA POLICE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION. WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE. SHE
NOTICED CHESHIRE DEBATE CLERK
LIBERAL. IS ADAMANT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS FOR RESERVE A
. CLICK
WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT ICE
FORTY ONE NO SEVENTEEN SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
FILE ITEM SIXTEEN AB ELEVEN
NINETY FIVE O'DONNELL. ASSEMBLY
BILL ELEVEN NINETY FIVE BY SOME
REMEMBER O'DONNELL AND ACTUALLY
TO GREENHOUSE GASES MR
O'DONNELL THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB ELEVEN ANY FIVE
DIRECTS THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD
TO CONSIDER EXPANDING LC OF
PASSED CREDITS TO OIL AND GAS
PRODUCERS WHO REDUCE METHANE
EMISSIONS HERE IN CALIFORNIA BY
SWITCHING TO RENEWABLE NATURAL
GAS IN THEIR OPERATIONS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR NOVEL.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM CLERK WILL OF THE ROLE.
THESE ARE ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS
OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE WORK
WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I
FIFTY THREE KNOWS FIVE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN AB THIRTEEN
SIXTY TWO QUICK READ ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTEEN SIXTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER O'DONNELL AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO
ELECTRICITY MISTER DONNELLY
MEGAN OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE RESENT AB
THIRTEEN SIXTY TWO ON
CONCURRENCE WHICH READ WHICH
WOULD REQUIRE THE P. UC TO
COLLECT TO MAKE AVAILABLEON
THEIR WEBSITE INFORMATION ON
THE RATES AND PROGRAMS OFFERED.
BY LOAD SERVING ENTITIES. AB
THIRTEEN SIXTY TWO WILL PROVIDE
THIS INFORMATION BY REQUIRING
THE PC TO POSTED ON THEIR
WEBSITE ACCURATE. NON BIASED
INFORMATION CONCERNING A LOAD
CERTAIN THE LOAD SERVING
ENTITIES ELECTRICITY RATES AND
ENERGY PORTFOLIO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK WHEN I VOTE. FAMOUS AROUND
SAYING NO DISCUSSION OF A CLERK
LIBERAL. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ALBUM. ALL MEMBERS OF. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLICK WELL
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT EYES SIXTY
ONE NO ZERO SENTIMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN.
AB AT NINE FORTY FOUR
CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL NINE
FORTY FOUR BUY SOMETHING MEMBER
QUIRK IN OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
THE PUBLIC SOCIAL SERVICES
DOCTOR QUIRK. THANK YOU SPEAKER
IN MEMBERS AB NINE FORTY FOUR
WILL ALIGN CAL WORKS. EXCEPTION
PROVISIONS SIMILARLY WITH THOSE
FOR CAL FOR ASH. AMENDMENTS
TAKEN IN THE SENATE THE
REQUESTED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES TO FACILITATE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE BELL. AB
NINE FORTY FOUR IS CO SPONSORED
BY THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY IN ALAMEDA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND HAS NO
ACT OPPOSITION. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. I THINK IT
AT WORK SENIOR DISCUSSION OF A-
CLERK WILL OF. MEMBERS FROM.
ZERO ALL MEMBERS OF OUR DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLARK WELL
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT ICE FORTY
NINE KNOWS ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
WHERE IS THIS IS FILE ITEM
NINETEEN AB FIFTEEN EIGHTY FOUR
COVERAGE AS I'M ABLE FIFTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR BY FAMILY MEMBER
QUIRK AND ACTUALLY TO
ELECTRICITY. DOCTOR QUIRK THANK
YOU AB FIFTEEN EIGHTY FOUR WILL
REQUIRE LOAD SERVING AND
EIGHTIES TO PAY FOR ALL THE
COSTS THAT THEIR PORTFOLIOS
IMPOSE ON THE ELECTRIC SYSTEM
MA'AM IS TAKING IN THE SENATE
ADD DEFINITIONS IN OUR
CLARIFYING. AB FIFTEEN EIGHTY
FOUR HIS RICHIE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN BOTH HOUSES AND IS
SUPPORTED BY TURN THE UTILITY
REFORM NETWORK AND THE CALL AND
Q. THE COALITION OF CALIFORNIA
UTILITY EMPLOYEES AND CAL CCA
IS NEUTRAL I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTES. SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK
LIBERAL. MEMBERS DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS FOR THE START OF A.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF WHAT I
SIXTY NO ZERO SENATE MEMBERS
ARE CONCURRED IN FILE I'M
TWENTY. A. B. FIFTEEN AT NINETY
SIX CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL
FIFTEEN NINETY SIX BY THE
COMMITTEE ON ENVIRONMENTAL
SAFETY AND TOXIC MATERIALS AND
ACTUALLY TO HAZARDOUS
SUBSTANCES. DR QUIRKY MEGAN
OPEN YOU KNOW IT'S NICE NOT TO
GET HAVE TO GET UP AND DOWN
MORE THAN ONCE FOR THREE BELLS.
THANK YOU I AB FIFTY NINETY SIX
ADDS FACTIONAL TO THE
METHAMPHETAMINE CONTAMINATED
PROPERTY ACT OF TWO THOUSAND
FIVE. IN ORDER SAID INTERIM
CLEANUP STANDARDS FOR FAT AND
ALL. ARE CONTAMINATED PROPERTY
AND PROVIDES. A DIRECTION TO
LOCAL HEALTH OFFICERS FOR THE
OVERSIGHT AND CLEAN UP OF
FENNEL CONTAMINATED PROPERTIES.
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS TO MAN
THE DEFINITION OF FEDERAL TO
INCLUDE AN ANALOG OF FAT NO
LEADS THE REQUIREMENTS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC SUBSTANCE
CONTROL DEVELOP A HEALTH BASED
REMEDIATION STANDARD FOR FAT
AND ALL AND MAKES TECHNICAL
CHANGES. THERE'S NO OPPOSITION
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
CONCURRENCE AND SEND AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU DOCTOR FOR SEEING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE. OR CALL THE
ROLL. CEREMONY. ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS ARE ABOUT. ALL MEMBERS
ARE DESIRABLE. CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I FIFTY
NINE OH ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. ALMOST FROM
HERE. MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
AT THIS TIME MOVE. TO
RECONSIDERATION ITEMS ONE OH
ONE ONE OH TWO AND ONE OF THREE
WILL BE CONTINUED. WE ARE GOING
TO MOVE TO THE ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING FILE. TO TAKE UP. FILE
ITEM ONE OH NINE. AJ ARE.
SEVENTEEN CORPORATION ASSEMBLY
JOINT RESOLUTION SEVENTEEN BY
SOME MEMBER RAMOS AND OTHERS
RELATIVE TO MISSING AND
MURDERED NATIVE AMERICAN WOMEN
AND GIRLS THE STRUGGLES THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER TODAY I RISE
AS A CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY
SELECT COMMITTEE ON NATIVE
AMERICAN AFFAIRS AND THE FATHER
BROTHER UNCLE AND COUSIN AND
FRIEND OF NATIVE AMERICAN WOMEN
THROUGHOUT THE NATION. AND THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THIS
CONTINUES TO GO MISSING AND
MURDERED AND ACCOUNTED FOR. AJ
ARE SEVENTEEN IS A RESOLUTION
THAT REQUEST THE TOURNEY
GENERAL OF CALIFORNIA TO
INVESTIGATE DATA AS IT RELATES
TO MISSING AND MURDERED NATIVE
AMERICAN WOMEN AND GIRLS. AMONG
INDIAN WOMEN HOMICIDE IS THE
THIRD LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH
AMONG THOSE BETWEEN THE AGES OF
TEN AND TWENTY FOUR YEARS OF
AGE AND IS THE FIFTH LEADING
CAUSE OF DEATH FOR TRIBAL WOMEN
BETWEEN TWENTY FIVE AND THIRTY
FOUR YEARS OF AGE. IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN THE
NATIONAL CRIME INFORMATION
CENTER FOUND THAT THERE WERE
NEARLY SIX THOUSAND REPORTS OF
MISSING NATIVE AMERICAN AND
ALASKA NATIVE WOMEN AND GIRLS
IN THE UNITED STATES BUT THE
NATIONAL MISSING AN INDEMNIFIED
UNIDENTIFIED PERSON SYSTEMS
WITHIN THE UNITED STATES
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE. REPORT
IT JUST ONLY SIXTEEN CASES. SO
WE SEE THE DID THE DEEP
DISPARITY THAT'S THERE BUT
ALONG OUR RESEARCH WE FOUND
THAT CALIFORNIA IS NUMBER SIX
IN THE TOP TEN STATES WITH THE
HIGHEST NUMBER OF MISSING AND
MURDER NATIVE AMERICAN WOMEN
AND GIRLS WITH CASES. WITH SAN
FRANCISCO AS ONE OF THE TOP TEN
CITIES WITH THE HIGHEST NUMBER
OF MISSING AND MURDER NATIVE
AMERICAN WOMEN AND GIRLS IN THE
UNITED STATES GIVEN THE
UNCERTAINTY INTENSITY WITH
THESE TYPES OF CASES IT IS OF
UTMOST IMPORTANT THAT THIS BODY
AND THE ATTORNEY GENERAL OF
CALIFORNIA IDENTIFY A MEDIA
COMPREHENSIVE SOLUTIONS TO
ACCURATELY INVESTIGATING AND
DOCUMENTING AND TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE HAVING TO SHARE
BETWEEN FEDERAL STATE COUNTY
AND TRIBAL COMMUNITIES. NATIVE
AMERICAN WOMEN DESERVE TO BE
COUNTED FOR TOO LONG THEY HAVE
GONE MISSING AND MURDERED WITH
NO REPERCUSSIONS I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS RAMOS
SAYING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
WOULD YOU LIKE CO AUTHORS ON
THE RESOLUTION SIR. YES WE'D
LIKE TO REFER CO AUTHORS. FOR
SURE WILL BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS ON H. A R. SEVENTEEN
CORPS CORPORAL. THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS. KIRK WELL CLOSE RATHER
SIXTY TWO CO AUTHORS ADDED THIS
IS AN AGE A ARE WE WILL TAKE A
ROLE ALL MEMBERS OF THE
CEREMONY. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE CLERK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TELL YOU THAT I A
SIXTY ONE. KNOWS ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEMS ONE
OH FOUR. THROUGH ONE OH EIGHT
AND ONE TEN AND ONE ELEVEN PASS
AND RETAIN. WE ARE AT THE
SENATE THIRD READING FILE. PASS
AND RETAIN A FILE ITEM ONE
TWELVE THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE
THIRTEEN. SB THIRTY SIX THE
CLERK WILL READ SENATE BILL
THIRTY SIX BY SENATOR HERTZBERG
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY IN A
PRE TRIAL RELEASE. DOCTOR WEBER
EMAIL YES MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT TO
YOU SB THIRTY SIX BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG WHICH IS A BILL THAT
IS INSPIRED BY NATIONAL
MOVEMENT FOCUSING ON REFORMING
OUR PRE TRIAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
ACROSS THE COUNTRY POLICY
INNOVATORS IN SYSTEM ACTORS ARE
RETHINKING HOW WE ACHIEVE
EQUITY FOR THE ACCUSED IN THE
PERIOD BETWEEN WHEN THEY ARE
CHARGED WITH A CRIME AND WHEN
THEY ARE BROUGHT TO TRIAL. IN
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES OF ALREADY
IMPLEMENTED SIGNIFICANT CHANGES
CURRENTLY FORTY NINE OF THE
FIFTY EIGHT CALIFORNIA COUNTIES
HAVE ADOPTED A PRE TRIAL REST
ASSESSMENT TOOL AIMED AT
IMPROVING JUDICIAL DECISION
MAKING AND PRE TRIAL SO
PROVISION PRACTICES. THE
PROBLEM IS AS THESE TOOLS ARE
PRODUCED BY ALL MANNERS OF
ORGANIZATIONS FROM NONPROFIT
AND FOR PROFIT COMPANIES TO
CHARITABLE FOUNDATIONS AND THEY
VERYDRAMATICALLY IN THAT
METHODOLOGY THEY USE TO ASSESS
RISK. MORE CONCERNING IS THE
FACT THAT UNDER CURRENT
CALIFORNIA LAW THERE ARE NO
MINIMAL STANDARDS GOVERNING THE
EFFECTIVE USE OF RISK
ASSESSMENT TOOLS AND NO
SAFEGUARDS IN PLACE TO ENSURE
THAT THEY ARE BEING USED IN A
WAY. THAT ACTUALLY IS ESTIMATES
WRIST WHILE MINIMIZING BIAS
THAT DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. WITH SB
THIRTY SIX WE'RE CREATING THREE
MINIMAL STANDARDS REGARDING THE
USE OF RISK ASSESSMENT TOOLS
ONE ANY COUNTY THAT USES A TOOL
MUST VALIDATE THE STATISTICAL
ACCURACY OF THAT TOOL ON A
REGULAR BASIS. TO IN A TOOL
USED IN CALIFORNIA MUST BE
TRANSPARENT THAT MEANS OF
COUNTY NEED TO TELL THE PUBLIC
EXACTLY HOW THIS SCORES ARE
CALCULATED. AND THREE DATA
COLLECTION THROUGH THE USE OF
THESE TOOLS MUST BE REGULAR
COLLECTED AND PUBLISHED SO THAT
THE SYSTEM ACTORS CAN BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE TO THE COMMUNITIES
THEY SERVE. RECENT AMENDMENTS
REFLECT ABERRATION WITH THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL TO HARMONIZE
SB THIRTY SIX WOULD PRE TRIAL
PILOT PROGRAMS ESTABLISHED BY
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET. MEMBERS THE
REALITY IS A CALIFORNIA WHEN IT
COMES TO THE WAY WE HANDLE THE
ACCUSED BEFORE TRIAL WE'RE
FAILING. IN A TWO TWENTY
SEVENTEEN REPORT BY THE PRE
TRIAL JUSTICE INSTITUTE THAT
LOOK AT PRE TRIAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM. IN ALL FIFTY STATES IT
GET CALIFORNIA DE. A. LEAVE
THAT WE MUST DO BETTER. SB
THIRTY SIX PRESENTS A
SIGNIFICANT STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
BACK TO WEBER. SENIOR
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. CAR CLUB
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS FROM.
THESE ARE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL. ALL
MEMBERS ARE DESIRABLE. CLARK
WELL. CLOSE ROLL TALBOT EYES
FIFTY SIX NOW ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES. THERE IS WE'RE GOING TO
GO BACK TO THE CONCURRENCE FILE.
AND TAKE UP. FILE ITEM. NINETY
FOUR. AC ARE ONE THIRTY FIVE
GREGORY ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE THIRTY FIVE BY
SOME THE AMERICAL DROUGHT AND
OTHERS RELATIVE TO ENERGY
EFFICIENCY DAY. MISTER
CALDERON. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER A C. R. ONE THIRTY FIVE
IS BACK TO THE ASSEMBLY FROM
THE SENATE ON CONCURRENCE
SENATE AMENDMENTS JUST FIXED A
DRAFTING I RESPECTFULLY ASK
WHEN I BOUGHT. THERE WAS
CALDERON SENIOR DISCUSSION OF
EIGHT O'CLOCK OR ALL.
SACRAMENTO MEMBER SERVICE OUT
OF A. ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE
TO VOTE. QUIRK WELL CLOSE ROLE
TALLY THE VOTE EYES FIFTY NINE
NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. BACK IN FILE
ORDER ON THE SENATE THIRD
READING FILE FILE ITEM ONE
FOURTEEN PASS AND RETAIN. FILE
ITEM ONE OF FIFTEEN IS SB FOUR
FIFTY SEVEN THE CORPORATION
SENATE BILL FOUR FIFTY SEVEN
SEVEN BY SENATOR HUESO ACTUALLY
TO ENERGY. MR GARCIA THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES
I'M- PROUD TO PRESENT SB FOUR
FIFTY SEVEN ON BEHALF OF THE
SINGING SENATOR FROM SAN DIEGO
THIS BILL WILL SUPPORT THE
STATE'S INNOVATIONS WITH BIO
METHANE AND- A STRATEGY OF
SEVERAL STATES STRATEGIES TO
REDUCE CARBON EMISSIONS.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I WILL.
THANK MISTER SALE SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLICK LIBERAL.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF
DESIRE TO VOTE. WELL CLOSER ALL
TALIBAN EYES FORTY FOUR KNOWS
THREE THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTION THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FOR
SEVENTY SEVEN TWO EXCUSE ME THE
ONE DAY WAITING PERIOD FOR
CONCURRENCE IS ON ITEMS TWENTY
ONE THREE NINETY THREE TO ALLOW
AUTHORS TO TAKE UP THEIR BILLS
TODAY. WITHOUT OBJECTION THAT
REQUEST IS GRANTED. MEMBERS
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE
SEVENTY SEVEN POINT TWO I RE
REFERRING SB SEVEN FORTY NINE
DRAWS OF TO THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE
. MEMBERS WE ARE ON
THE SENATE THIRD EADING FILE
FILE ITEMS ONE SIXTEEN THROUGH
ONE TWENTY THREE. PASS A RETAIN.
WE ARE AT FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY
FOUR SB ONE FIFTY SIX.
CORPORATE SENATE BILL ONE FIFTY
SIX BY SENATOR NIELSEN AND
ACTUALLY TO HEALTH FACILITIES.
MR GALLAGHER. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS ARE RISING
PRESENT AB ONE FIFTY SIX ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR NIELSEN. THE
LOSS OF THE FEATHER RIVER
HOSPITAL IN PARADISE HAS BEEN
CATASTROPHIC NOT JUST FOR THE
PEOPLE WHO LIVED IN THAT
COMMUNITY BUT THE ENTIRE
REGION. THE HUNDRED BED
FACILITY SERVE AS ONE OF THE
FEW ACUTE CARE RESOURCES WITHIN
BUTTE COUNTY AND WAS INTEGRAL
AND PROVIDING RESIDENTS WITH
TREATMENT. AB ONE FIFTY SIX
HOURS REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUE A
SPECIAL PERMIT. ADD TO ALLOW
GENERAL ACUTE CARE HOSPITAL TO
OFFER EMERGENCY STABILIZATION
SERVICES AT A LOCATION OUTSIDE
OF THE HOSPITAL IF THE HOSPITAL
PROVIDE STATUS FOR SATISFACTORY
EVIDENCE TO DPH THAT IT MEETS
CERTAIN CRITERIA. AB SORRY SB
ONE FIFTY SIX HAS RECEIVED NARY
A NO VOTE IN THE SENATE OR
ASSEMBLY. THE NOT AND VOTE I ON
THIS BILL THANK YOU. SAME AREA
MEMBER SEEKING RECOGNITION.
CLICK LIBERAL. PHONE NUMBERS
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
AND RESERVE A- ALL MEMBERS OF.
DESIRE TO VOTE CLICK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TELL YOU ABOUT AYE
AYES FIFTY EIGHT NO ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM ONE
TWENTY FIVE IS SB ONE SIXTY
FIVE COVERAGE. I HAVE A ONE
SIXTY FIVE BY SENATOR ATKINS
AND OTHERS AND EXPLAIN TO MEDI
CAL. BONTA THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES I RISE
TO PRESENT SB ONE SIXTY FIVE ON
BEHALF OF CENTER PRO TEM ATKINS
THE BILL IS ANOTHER STEP IN THE
EFFORT TO DEVELOP A SYSTEM TO
ENSURE THAT LIMITED ENGLISH
PROFICIENT MEDI CAL ENROLLEES
HAVE IN PERSON LANGUAGE
INTERPRETER SERVICES WHEN THEY
VISIT THEIR MEDICAL PROVIDERS.
SPECIFICALLY THE BILL ALLOWS
PILOT PROJECTS SITES TO GO
FORWARD IN ORDER TO EVALUATE
THE EFFECTIVENESS OF PROVIDING
IN PERSON MEDICAL
INTERPRETATION THE BILL HAS HAD
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IT WAS ON
CONSENT IN THE HEALTH AND
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEES IN
THIS HOUSE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER BONTA SEEING THEIR
DISCRETION TO BAKER CLUB IN THE
ROLE. SARAH VOTE ALL MEMBERS
WERE DESIGNED OF A. ALL MEMBERS
OF A RESERVE A. CLARK WELL
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE SIXTY.
KNOWS ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WHERE FILE ITEM ONE
TWENTY SIX SB ONE EIGHTY FIVE
COOKERY SENATE BILL ONE EIGHTY
FIVE BY SENATOR MCGUIRE AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO CANNABIS
DOCTOR WOULD. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS SB ONE
EIGHTY FIVE BY SENATOR MCGUIRE
IS A TRUTH IN LABELING AND
TRANSPARENCY BILL THE CLOSES
LOOPHOLE IN CURRENT LAW ALLOWS
COMPANIES TO USE THE NAMES OF
APPELLATIONS AND PRODUCTS IN
ADVERTISING AND FURTHER
CLARIFIES THE ORGANIC
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM FOR
CANNABIS AND CANNABIS PRODUCTS
THE BILL EXPANDS THE
PROHIBITIONS ALREADY IN
STATUTES WHICH PROHIBIT
IMPROPERLY USING COUNTY NAMES
FOR CANNABIS PRODUCTS TO
INCLUDE ANY NAME THAT IS LIKELY
TO MISREPRESENT THE ORIGIN OF
THE PRODUCT. SIMILAR LABELING
LAWS IN PLACE FOR BOTH WINE FOR
WORK FOR WINE BOTH HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
HAVE PROMOTED CORPORATE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND CLARITY FOR
CONSUMERS THIS BILL SIMPLY PUT
THE SAME PROTECTIONS IN PLACE
FOR CANNABIS SB ONE EIGHTY FIVE
IS ENJOYED STRONG PART PARTISAN.
SUPPORT THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE. HEY THAT WOULD. SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS ARE TO VOTE. CLARK WELL
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I FIFTY
NINE OH ZERO. THAT MEASURE
PASSES. FILE ITEMS ONE TWENTY
SEVEN. THROUGH ONE THIRTY THREE
PASS AND RETAIN. FILE ITEM ONE
THIRTY FOUR. SB SEVEN EIGHTY
SIX CORKERY SENATE BILL SEVEN
EIGHTY SIX BY THE COMMITTEE ON
BUSINESS PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND
ACTUALLY THE HEALING ARTS MR
LOW EMAIL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS THIS IS
A COMMITTEE BILL NO
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANKS
LO SI NO DISCUSSION DEBATE
CLARK WELL OVER THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS OF DESIRE TO VOTE.ALL
MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE
ABOUT AYE SIXTY TWO NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM
ON THIRTY FIVE IS SB SEVENTY
CORKERY. SENATE BILL SEVENTY BY
SENATOR NIELSEN AND ACTUALLY TO
LECTURE CITY. MR BELOW ME THEY
OPEN THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE TO ASK YOUR
SUPPORT OF SB SEVENTY UP BY
SENATOR NIELSEN THIS BILL
REQUIRES ELECTRICAL
CORPORATIONS TO INCLUDE. IN
THERE WHILE FIRE MITIGATION
PLANS A DESCRIPTION OF WHERE
AND HOW THEY CONSIDERED UNDER
GROUNDING ELECTRICAL
DISTRIBUTION LINES IN AREAS
THAT HAVE THE HIGHEST WILDFIRE
RISK AND- AS YOU ALL KNOW IN%
RECENT YEARS CALIFORNIA'S
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES. HAVE
CAUSE GRAVE DAMAGE TO ABOVE
GROUND ELECTRICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE BUT SOME OF THE
MOST DEVASTATING FIRES HAVE
ACTUALLY BEEN IGNITED BY THE-
ABOVE GROUND INFRASTRUCTURE AS
IN THE CASE OF THE CAMP FIRE.
SO IT MAKES SENSE THAT WE WOULD
ASK ELECTRICAL UTILITIES TO
HARDEN THEIR INFRASTRUCTURE IN
ORDER TO LIVE WITH THE REALITY
OF WILDFIRES AND REDUCE THE
RISK OF FUTURE CATASTROPHIC
FIRES. UNDER GROUNDING IS NOT
JUST AN INVESTMENT IN RELIABLE
INFRASTRUCTURE BUT AN
INVESTMENT IN LIVES AND AVOIDED
COSTS TO RATEPAYERS. BY
INCLUDING THE POTENTIAL OF
UNDERGROUND AGAIN WHILE FOR
MITIGATION PLANS SB SEVENTIES
INTENTION IS TO ENCOURAGE
UTILITIES TO TAKE ACTIONS THAT
ARE NECESSARY FOR THE WELL. FOR
THE PUBLIC AND THEREFORE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE THE.
THANK WAS BLOOM SAY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE. THE CLUB IN
ALL. MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
ON MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF THE. WE
ARE AT FILE ITEM. ONE THIRTY
SEVEN. THIS IS SB FIVE FIFTY.
JACKIE Và MISTER HOLDING
CORPORATION SENATE BILL FIVE
FIFTY BY SENATOR HILL AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES MR HOLDEN YOUR
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
HILL I'M PROUD TO PRESENT SB
FIVE FIFTY WHICH PROVIDES
ADDITIONAL CRITERIA FOR THE CPU
CD CONSIDERING REVIEWING A
PROPOSED CORPORATE
RESTRUCTURING TO ENSURE SAFE
SERVICE OF THE SUCCESSOR
ENTITY. ADDITIONALLY RECENT
AMENDMENTS TO SB FIVE FIFTY
CLARIFY THE CPUC REVIEW PROCESS
BETWEEN I'LL USE AND PUBLIC
ENTITIES AS RELATED TO WORK
FORCE AND RATE THEIR IMPACTS
IMPORTANT NEGOTIATED
CLARIFICATIONS AFTER THE
PASSAGE OF ASSEMBLY BILL TEN
FIFTY FOUR EARLIER THIS YEAR
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THERE WAS
HOLDEN SINGER DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CAR CLUB RURAL. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE ABOUT. ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS ARE TO VOTE. QUIRK WELL
CLOSER ALL. TALLY THE- I SIXTY
THREE KNOWS ONE THE MEASURE
PASSES THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE
THIRTY EIGHT SB SIX SIXTEEN.
GREGORY SENATE BILL SIX SIXTEEN
BY SENATOR WHITE HOUSE SKI AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY CIVIL
ACTIONS. MS RIVAS THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
TODAY I'M PRESENTING AS A CO
AUTHOR ON THIS IMPORTANT PIECE
OF LEGISLATION WHICH WILL
PROTECT THE MINIMAL BALANCE IN
A PERSON'S BANK ACCOUNT WHEN IT
IS LEVY BY DEBT COLLECTORS
UNDER CURRENT LAW EVERY DOLLAR
OF A PERSON'S BANK ACCOUNT
INCLUDING THEIR LAST PAYCHECK
YEAH I. T. C. PAYMENT OR FEMA
DISASTER PAYMENT CAN BE WIPED
OUT WITH A SINGLE DEBT
COLLECTOR LEVY. SB SIX ONE SIX
WOULD PROTECT THE LAST
SEVENTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS IN A
PERSON'S BANK ACCOUNT FROM
BEING SEIZED BY DEBT COLLECTORS.
WE KNOW THAT MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS ARE LIVING ON THE
EDGE PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK WITH
BARELY ENOUGH TO COVER THEIR
NEEDS WE ALL HAVE THESE
CONSTITUENTS IN OUR DISTRICTS.
FOR EXAMPLE I REPRESENT A
DISTRICT THAT IS MAJORITY
LATINO WHERE STUDIES SHOW THAT
ARE MORE LIKELY TO BE IMPACTED
BY THE CURRENT COLLECTION
PROCESS. SOME IMPORTANT PIECES
I'M TO NOTE ABOUT SB SIX ONE
SIX IT DOES NOT A RACE THAT. IT
DOES NOT PROTECT ANYTHING MORE
THAN SEVENTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS
DOLLARS REGARDLESS OF HOW MANY
BANK ACCOUNTS SOMEONE HAS. IT
ESTABLISHES A FLOOR EQUAL TO
THE MINIMUM BASIC STANDARD OF
ADEQUATE CARE WHICH HAS BEEN
CALCULATED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES SINCE NINETEEN
SEVENTY ONE. TO DETERMINE WHAT
A LOW INCOME FAMILY NEEDS TO
SURVIVE. IT PROTECTS YOUR
CONSTITUENTS FEMA DISASTER
FUNDS. AND IT DOES NOT PREVENT
DEBT COLLECTORS FROM LIVING
ANYTHING ABOVE SEVENTEEN
HUNDRED DOLLARS ACROSS BANK
ACCOUNTS GARNISHING THE WAGES
OF WORKERS LIVING PROPERTY OR
SEIZING PROPERTY. FLOOR
AMENDMENTS TAKEN LAST WEEK
REINFORCED THAT SB SIX ONE SIX
PROTECTIONS CANNOT BE STACKED
ON TOP OF OTHER PROTECTIONS.
THIS BILL ENJOYS THE SUPPORT OF
THE CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC PARTY
THE SUPPORT OF DOZENS OF LEGAL
SERVICES ORGANIZATIONS LABOR
AND COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS. IT
IS NEXT TO IMPOSSIBLE TO LIVE
IN POVERTY AND NOT GOING TODAY
SB SIX ONE SIX DOES NOT ERASE
ANY DEBT IT'S SIMPLY ALLOWS
PEOPLE TO PAY TWO DAYS BILLS
WHILE THEY WORK THEIR WAY OUT
OF YESTERDAY'S DAT. COLLEAGUES
IF WE ARE SERIOUS ABOUT OUR
COMMITMENT TO END POVERTY IN
OUR STATE. WE WILL PASS THIS
BILL TODAY I URGE YOUR AYE VOTE.
THERE WAS RIVAS MISS WICKS YOUR
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIX ONE SIX. THIS
BILL ADD SOME BASELINE SECURITY
FOR LOW INCOME FAMILIES WHO
WOULD LIKE TO USE THE BANK
ACCOUNT BUT HAVE FALLEN BEHIND
ON AN OLD DEBT. OFTEN DUE TO
STRETCHES OF UNEMPLOYMENT AND
MEDICAL COSTS AND THEY CANNOT
AFFORD TO HAVE ALL THEIR MONEY
SEIZED IN A BANK LEVY. ACTIVELY
NO ONE ESCAPES POVERTY WITHOUT
DEBT. POOR PEOPLE ARE OFTEN
OVERWHELMED BY HIGH INTEREST
RATES THAT MAKE IT NEARLY
IMPOSSIBLE TO PAY DOWN THEIR
DEBTS. IF WE ARE SERIOUS ABOUT
TACKLING POVERTY IN OUR STATE
WE NEED TO BE REALISTIC ABOUT
THE FACT THAT POOR PEOPLE
STRUGGLING. TO PAY DEBT AND
NEED AS MUCH HELP AS THEY CAN
GET. I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE ON SB SIX ONE
SIX. THANK YOU MS WICKS. THE
SHOW BONTA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX ONE SIX.
THIS BILL HELPS WORKING PEOPLE
AND FAMILIES WHO ARE TRYING TO
PAY OFF THEIR DEBTS AND HELP
KEEP THEM FROM RISKY.
SITUATIONS IN WHICH THEY COULD
LOSE THEIR HOUSING OR FACE
OTHER HARM TOTAL BANK ACCOUNTS
USERS MAKE IT EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT FOR CAN FAMILIES TO
PROVIDE THE BASIC NECESSITIES
OF LIFE PEOPLE OUGHT NOT FACE
THE PROSPECT OF HUNGER.
JOBLESSNESS OR EVICTIONS WALL
PAYING OFF DEBTS SB SIX ONE SIX
WILL GIVE WORKING PEOPLE THE
CHANCE TO LIFT THEMSELVES OUT
OF POVERTY. WHILE PAYING BACK
THEIR DEBTS AT A RATE THEY CAN
MANAGE I TO RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER BONTA. SEEING NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON THE
ITEM. CARP GLOBAL ROLE. OUR
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTED ASIDE
ABOUT. ALL MEMBERS OF. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE
. ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS ARE THOUGH. MS RESIST
MISS RIVAS MOVES A CALL. PASS
AND RETAIN OF ALARM ONE THIRTY
NINE. FILE ITEM ONE FORTY. SB
SIX NINETY CORKERY CYNICAL SIX
NINETY BY CENTER HUESO AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE COASTAL
RESOURCES MR GLORIA. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER OF FOR MORE THAN
THIRTY YEARS THE TIJUANA RIVER
VALLEYS EXPERIENCE INCREASED
DISCHARGE OF TRASH SENATE AND
WASTEWATER GENERATED BECAUSE
THE SEWAGE INFRASTRUCTURE IN
THE AREA IS INADEQUATE. THIS
CHARGE OF RAW SEWAGE ON OTHER
WERE IN OTHER WAYS TO THE
TIJUANA RIVER VALLEY POSE A
SERIOUS PUBLIC HEALTH RISK FROM
UNTREATED AND PARTIALLY TREAT A
HUMAN INDUSTRIAL WASTE THE
CONTAINS TOXINS AND BACTERIA
AND VIRAL PATHOGENS SUCH AS E.
COLI AND SALMONELLA. THERE'S
BEEN SUCH A PERVASIVE PROBLEM
THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO HAS COME
TO HAS DECLARED A CONTINUED
STATE OF EMERGENCY SINCE THE
YEAR NINETEEN NINETY THREE.
THIS POLLUTION IMPAIRS THE
QUALITY OF THE WHAT WAS STATE
WATERS THREATENS LIFE AND
PROPERTY DESTROYED HABITATS
EFFECTS RECREATIONAL AND
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES FOR SAN
DIEGO RESIDENTS AS WELL AS
VISITORS DESPITE DECADES OF
WORKING WITH FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
TOWARD A SOLUTION THEY HAVE
REPEATEDLY FAILED TO STOP THIS
MASSIVE POLLUTION DISCHARGE AND
TO PROTECT OUR COMMUNITIES. AS
A RESULT THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
OF OUR GREAT STATE AS WELL THE
SAN DIEGO WATER BOARD ANNOUNCED
THAT THEY WOULD BE SUING THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FOR
VIOLATIONS OF THE CLEAN WATER
ACT AND THE CONTINUED POLLUTION
OF OUR STATE WATERS.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS PROCESS IS
TOO LENGTHY THE LIVES THE
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA CANNOT
WAIT. A TO BE. THEY WOULD TELL
OF RELIEF CAN BE PROVIDED OUR
ECONOMY CANNOT CONTINUE TO BE
STUNTED BY CONSTANT BEACH
CLOSURES THAT DRIVE DOWN THE
VALUE OF HOMES. AND HARM LOCAL
SMALL BUSINESSES AS WELL AS
PREVENT ACCESS TO COASTAL
RESOURCES. AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN
I JOIN SENATOR HUESO CO AUTHOR
IN SB FIVE OH SEVEN WHICH
FUNDED A NEEDS ASSESSMENT. TO
BE CONDUCTED BY THE COUNTY OF
SAN DIEGO. OF THE PROJECTS
IDENTIFIED IN A NEEDS
ASSESSMENT THE CYNICAL REGIONAL
WATER QUALITY CONTROL BOARD HAS
OUTLINED PROJECTS WITH IN THE
STUDY AS A PRIORITY PROJECTS
FOR ADDRESSING CROSS BORDER
POLLUTION. THIS BILL SB SIX
NINETY ENCOURAGES THE CALL
CALIFORNIA COASTAL CONSERVANCY
TO PRIORITIZE PROJECTS
IDENTIFIED FROM THE SB FIVE OH
SEVEN ASSESSMENT. IN ORDER TO
MITIGATE THE DAMAGE DONE TO OUR
COAST I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR HUESO. THERE WAS GLORIA
SENIOR DISCUSSION BATES. GLOBAL
ROLE. DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF. DESIRABLE. WORK
WELL. CLOSER ALL TELL YOU WHAT
I SIXTY TWO KNOWS ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES. WE'RE GOING TO
PASS. TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM
ONE FORTY ONE. THIS IS FILE
ITEM ONE FORTY TWO SB FIVE
SIXTY CORPORATION SENATE BILL
FIVE SIXTY BY SENATOR MCGUIRE
AND ACTUALLY COMMUNICATIONS
DOCTOR WAY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBER SB FIVE SIXTY
CLARIFIES THAT UTILITIES MUST
REPORT DE ENERGIZING OF
ELECTRICAL LINE OUTAGES WITHIN
THE OUTAGE FOR PRINT TO FIRST
RESPONDERS HEALTHCARE
FACILITIES AND
TELECOMMUNICATION PROVIDERS
AHEAD OF OUTAGES THIS THIS
GREATER LEVEL OF DETAIL ENSURE
BETTER COORDINATION BETWEEN
UTILITIES EMERGENCY RESPONDERS
TELECOMMUNICATION PROVIDERS AND
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS DURING THESE
DE ENERGIZING EVENTS.
AMENDMENTS BEING TAKEN ON THE
FLOOR TODAY CLARIFY WHEN AND TO
WHOM PART WIRELESS PROVIDERS
NEED TO REPORT OUTAGE
INFORMATION AND TO ALSO ADDRESS
CHAPTER IN OUT ISSUES. THIS IS
THIRD READING. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK DRIVE UP. EXCELLENT CLOSE.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CAR CLUB ALL. THESE ARE ABOUT
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF A.
KIRK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT EYES FIFTY NINE NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEM
ONE FORTY THREE IS SB SIX FIFTY
SIX CORPORATION SENATE BILL SIX
FIFTY SIX BY SENATOR HUESO AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE SAN
DIEGO CORONADO BRIDGE TO
CLEARING THE URGENCY THERE UP
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. MR
GLORIA. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER A SENATE BILL SIX FIFTY
SIX REQUIRES CALTRANS TO
ESTABLISH AN ADVISORY COMMITTEE
COMPRISED OF LOCAL
REPRESENTATIVES TO PROVIDE
INPUT ON THE SELECTION OF A
PROPER SUICIDE DETERRENT SYSTEM
FOR THE CORONADO CITY CORONADO
BRIDGE SB SIX FIFTY SIX WILL
ENSURE TO STAKEHOLDERS WILL
INFORM THE SELECTION PROCESS
AND LEAD TO A DECISION THAT
BEST MEETS THE NEEDS OF THIS
COMMUNITY AS WELL AS TO REDUCE
THE UNNECESSARY DEATHS ON THIS
ICONIC STRUCTURE IN SAN DIEGO
ABOUT THE SENATOR AT. HUESO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANKS GLORIA SEEING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
COR CLUB IN THE ROLE. ZARA VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF
WHAT I SIXTY TWO NO ZERO ON THE
URGENCY I SIXTY TWO NO ZERO ON
THE MEASURE. THE BILL PASSES.
FILE ITEMS ONE FORTY FOUR AND
ONE FORTY FIVE PASSED RETAIN
FILE ITEM ONE FORTY SIX. SB
FIVE FIVE TO COLLABORATE.
SENATE BILL FIVE FIVE TWO BY
SENATOR ARCHULETA AND ACTUALLY
TO HAZARDOUS WASTE. THREE OF US
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF SENATOR ARCHULETA TO PRESENT
SENATE BILL FIVE FIVE TWO WHICH
WILL DELETE THE SUNSET DATE ON
A SUCCESSFUL CURBSIDE HOUSEHOLD
HAZARDOUS WASTE COLLECTION
PROGRAM AND ENCOURAGE THE USE
OF DOOR TO DOOR HOUSEHOLD
HAZARDOUS WASTE COLLECTION. THE
PROGRAM WAS CREATED IN TWENTY
ELEVEN AND HAS SINCE STOPPED
WHICH SUCCESSFUL CURBSIDE
HAZARDOUS WASTE COLLECTION
PROGRAMS AND MANY CITIES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA SB FIVE
FIVE TWO WILL ENSURE THAT THESE
PROGRAMS CONTINUE WELL INTO THE
FUTURE. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MS RIVAS SEEING
THEIR DISCUSSION BATES CLARK
LIBERAL. DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE ABOUT CLARK
WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I
SIXTY THREE NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE
ITEM ONE FORTY SEVEN. FILE ITEM
ONE FORTY EIGHT. SB SIX.
CALGARY SENATE BILL SIX BY
SENATOR BELL AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO RESIDENTIAL
DEVELOPMENTS MISTER TECH. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER TODAY I AM
PROUD TO PRESENT SB SIX A BILL
WHICH WILL CREATE A CENTRALIZED
DATABASE OF STATE AND LOCALLY
OWNED SURPLUS LAND AND LOCAL
PROPERTY IDENTIFIED FOR
CONSTRUCTION AS WE HAVE AN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CRISIS UP
AND DOWN THE STATE THIS
DATABASE COULD BE VERY USEFUL.
TO IDENTIFY POSSIBLE LAND FOR
DEVELOPMENT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR I BOUGHT ON SB SIX. AMOS
TANKS SAYING NO DISCUSSION OF A
CORPS CORPORAL. WHO'S OUT OF
THAT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
A. ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE
TO VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSER ALL
TIE BUT I SIXTY TWO NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM
ONE FORTY NINE. IS SB EIGHT
CORKERY ANIBAL EIGHT BY SENATOR
GLAZER AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
TO PARKS MR LEVINE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS THIS BILL IS ON THIRD
READING I HEAR THAT'S A
COMPELLING ARGUMENT. BUT
SERIOUSLY THIS IS NOT THE FIRST
TIME YOU FOR THIS BILL AND ALSO
IT'S NOT THE LAST TIME SB A IS
THE COMPANION. TO MY
LEGISLATION TO BAN SMOKING ON
OUR STATE BEACHES IN OUR STATE
PARKS AND RECREATION I'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS A LONG TIME
WITH THIS IS THE TIME TO HELP
MAKE SURE WE'RE PROTECTING
PUBLIC HEALTH. AND THE
ENVIRONMENT FROM THE DANGERS OF
SMOKING IN OUR STATE BEACHES
AND PARKS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
LIVING SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. QUIRK LIBERAL. ALL
MEMBERS OF DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS UNDESIRABLE. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
YEAH. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE T<c.cyan> ABOUT AYE AYES FORTY</c>
THREE KNOWS THIRTEEN. THAT
MEASURE PASSES
. MEMBERS THIS IS
FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY SB TWENTY
TWO CLICK READ SENATE BILL
TWENTY TWO BY SENATOR LEYVA AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO
EVIDENCE. MISTER DAVID CHIU YOU
MAY OPEN. OKAY MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES THIS IS A BILL TO
ENSURE OUR COLLECTIVE
COMMITMENT TO FIGHTING FOR
JUSTICE FOR RAPE SURVIVORS HERE
IN CALIFORNIA. SB TWENTY TWO
SIMPLY CHANGES ONE WORD IN
EXISTING LAW BY SAYING THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES IN
FORENSIC LABORATORIES SHALL
FOLLOW INSTEAD OF SHOULD FOLLOW
AS IT CURRENTLY STATES LISTED
TIME FRAMES FOR SUBMITTING IN
ANALYZING RAPE KIT EVIDENCE. IF
ENACTED THIS BILL WILL HAVE AN
ENORMOUS IMPACT ON THE LIVES OF
VICTIMS AND HELP TO PUT RAPISTS
BEHIND BARS ALL RAPE SURVIVORS
DESERVE TO HAVE THE RAPE KITS
TESTED PROBABLY. WHICH IN TURN
CAN HELP TO ENSURE JUSTICE FOR
THOSE VICTIMS IDENTIFIED ZERO
PERPETRATORS AND EVEN EXONERATE
THOSE WRONGFULLY CONVICTED THIS
BILLS EARNED STRONG BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN BOTH HOUSES AND WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE
. AMOS JUNE SEEING
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK
LIBERAL. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF. DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT
OF CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE
BUT I SIXTY THREE NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASS
. MEMBERS BACK IN
FILE ORDER FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY
ONE PASS AND RETAIN WE'RE GOING
TO PASS TEMPORARILY ON ONE
FIFTY TWO. PAST RETAIN ABOUT A
ONE FIFTY THREE. THIS IS FILE
ITEM ONE FIFTY FOUR. SB ONE
FIFTY THREE. CLOCK RATE SENATE
BILL ONE FIFTY THREE BY SENATOR
WILK AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO
INDUSTRIAL HEMP MAKING A
PREPARATION THEREFORE MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT SENATOR WILKES BILL SB
ONE FIFTY THREE AS A PROUD CO
AUTHOR. THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN FEDERAL FARM BILL
REMOVED HIM FROM THE CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCES ACT AND AUTHORIZED
STATES TO REGULATE THE
INDUSTRY. THIS BILL SETS FORTH
THE PROVISIONS FOR CALIFORNIA
TO ESTABLISH A STATE PLAN FOR
THE CULTIVATION OF INDUSTRIAL
HIM. IN ORDER TO REMAIN
CONSISTENT WITH THE NEW FEDERAL
STANDARDS. THIS WILL ALLOW
CALIFORNIA FARMERS TO FULLY
INVESTED INDUSTRIAL HEMP
PRODUCTION AND THERE'S
DIVERSIFY THEIR OPERATIONS.
THIS BILL IS SPONSORED BY THE
CALIFORNIA HIM COUNSEL AND
SUPPORTED BY THE FARM BUREAU
THE STATE GRANGE VOTE HIM AND
OTHERS I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU WAS AGUIAR-CURRY
SAYING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE
CLICK LIBERAL. SORRY ABOUT ALL
MEMBER SERVICE OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS A DESIRE TO VOTE. WELL
CLOSER ROLE. TELL YOU VOTE I
SIXTY NO ZERO. THAT MEASURE
PASSES. THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE
FIFTY FIVE SB TWO OH TWO
COVERAGE SENATE BILL TWO OH TWO
BY SENATOR WELKIN OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO ANIMALS THIS SHOULD
LOW THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
RISE ON BEHALF OF SENATOR WILK
TO PRESENT SENATE BILL TWO OH
TWO. UNBEKNOWNST TO MANY
CALIFORNIA IS FACING A SEVERE
SHORTAGE OF ANIMAL BUT BLOOD
PRODUCTS AND THIS MEANS THAT IF
ONE OF OUR PETS NEEDS A BLOOD
TRANSFUSION IN AN EMERGENCY
THERE'S A GOOD CHANCE THAT
VETERINARIANS WON'T HAVE THE
SUPPLY TO COMPLETE IT FOR
ANIMALS THIS IS A TRUE MATTER
OF LIFE AND DEATH AND SB TWO OH
TWO IS THE STATE'S FIRST STEP
TOWARDS FIXING THIS PROBLEM.
THIS BILL ALLOWS PRIVATELY
OWNED THE ANIMALS TO BE
VOLUNTEERED TO DONATE BLOOD AND
THEN GO HOME THE SAME DAY A
JUST LIKE COVER MUCH OF THE WAY
YOU AND I DONATE BLOOD WHICH
REMINDS ME I NEED TO GET IN
LINE AND DONATE BLOOD ONCE
AGAIN BUT- THIS TYPE OF BLOOD
DONATION FOR PETS IS ALLOWED IN
EVERY STATE EXCEPT YOU GUESSED
IT CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY DOG TO
DONATE BLOOD MUST BE HELD IN
CAGES FOR SEVERAL YEARS IN
ORDER FOR THE DONATION TO
COMPLY WITH REGULATIONS. AND
BECAUSE OF THIS RESTRICTION
CALIFORNIA HAS ONLY TWO
LICENSED COMMERCIAL BLOOD BANKS
IN OPERATION AND WE CONTINUE TO
SUFFER FROM A SHORTAGE OF
AVAILABLE BLOOD SB TO EXPAND
THE SUPPLY OF BLOOD AND HELPS
TO ENSURE THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
OF PETS ACROSS THE STATE AND
THEREFORE I. RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. ENGLISH BLOW SEE
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE. SEVERAL
MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A- ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARABLE. CLERK
WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I'D
FIFTY SEVEN NO ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM ONE
FIFTY SIX IS SB TWO SIXTY
COVERAGE SENATE BILL TWO SIXTY
BY SENATOR TADO AN ACT AND
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE. MR BONTA
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE TO PRESENT SB
TWO SIXTY ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
COURT BATTLE. SB TWO SIXTY WILL
HELP EVERYDAY CALIFORNIANS
AVOID GAPS IN HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE WHEN THEY UNDERGO LIFE
CHANGES THAT TRIGGER LOSSES IN
COVERAGE THE BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT HAS NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. NAME IS
BONTA SAY NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE THE CLUB THE ROLE.
MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF THEM ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. THIS OUT OF A.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ADAMO. CLARK
WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT EYES
FIFTY SIX NOW ZERO. TAT
MEASURE PASSES PASSED RETAIN
FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY SEVEN. THIS
IS FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY EIGHT SB
TWO EIGHTY NINE QUICKLY SENATE
BILL TWO EIGHTY NINE BY SENATOR
ARCHULETA AND OTHERS ACTUALLY
MEDI CAL. MR WENT. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE PRESENT
TO SB TWO EIGHT NINE WHICH
WOULD ALLOW ACTIVE DUTY
SERVICEMEMBERS TO MAINTAIN
THEIR PLACE ON THE MEDICAID.
HOME AND COMMUNITY BASED
SERVICE WAITING LIST IF THEY
MAINTAIN RESIDENCY IN
CALIFORNIA WHILE ON DEPLOYMENT
EXISTING LAW ESTABLISHES
VARIOUS VARIOUS SERVICES UNDER
THE MEDICAL PROGRAM THAT ENABLE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WOULD OTHERWISE
BE PLACED. IN A TO LIVE IN A
FACILITY TO LIVE AT HOME AND IN
THEIR COMMUNITY AS A FAMILY
HOWEVER ONE FAMILIES GET
DEPLOYED THEY LOSE THEIR PLACE
ON THE WAITING LIST SB. TWO
EIGHT NINE KEEPS FAMILIES
TOGETHER WHILE PROVIDING CARE
FOR THOSE WITH SPECIAL NEEDS.
ASK FOR YOUR AYE ABOUT. THANK
YOU MISTER ONE SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. THESE ARE NOT
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE THE. THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT
I SIXTY NO ZERO. MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEMS ONE FIFTY NINE
THROUGH ONE SIXTY ONE PASS AND
RETAIN. PASS TEMPORARILY. ON
FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY TWO. WE ARE
FIVE OH ONE SIXTY THREE. SB
THREE FORTY NINE SENATE BILL
THREE FORTY NINE BY SENATOR
PORTANTINO AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TAXATION TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY
MYSTERON LOSS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS SB THREE
FORTY NINE BY SENATOR
PORTANTINO I WOULD REDUCE THE
MINIMUM FRANCHISE TAX ON SMALL
BUSINESSES AND CALIFORNIA SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE THE BACKBONE OF
CALIFORNIA'S GROWING ECONOMY
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT OVER THREE
MILLION OF CALIFORNIA SMALL
BUSINESSES ACCOUNT FOR OVER 99%
OF OUR STATES EMPLOYERS AND 45%
OF CALIFORNIA'S EXPORTS. UNDER
CURRENT LAW THERE IS AN ANNUAL
MINIMUM FRANCHISE TAX OF EIGHT
HUNDRED DOLLARS ON EVERY
CORPORATION THIS TAX IS A ONE
SIZE FITS ALL STRUCTURE THAT
MANY SMALL BUSINESSES STRUGGLE
TO AFFORD AND STIFLES JOB
GROWTH AND OPPORTUNITY SB THREE
FOUR NINE CREATES A FEE
STRUCTURE BASED ON A
CORPORATION'S ANNUAL GROSS
RECEIPTS THIS WILL HELP FOSTER
GROWTH OF SMALL BUSINESSES AND
ENCOURAGES ENTERPRENEURS SHIP.
AS A PROUD PRINCIPLE CO AUTHOR
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. DENNIS ROSS SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLICK LIBERAL.
ZERO ALL MEMBERS OF. BIZARRE
ABOUT. ALL MEMBERS OF. THE
SERVER. YEAH. CLICK WELL CLOSE
ROLL TYPE BUT I SIXTY NINE
KNOWS ONE. THE MEASURE PASSES.
THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY
FOUR SB THREE FIFTY FOUR CLERK
READ SENATE BILL THREE FIFTY
FOUR BY SENATOR DROPS ON OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY TO POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION. MR MEDINA. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS FACE
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES IN
OBTAINING THE PROPER FINANCIAL
SUPPORT. THAT IS NEEDED TO
ENROLL IN A GRADUATE OR
PROFESSIONAL DEGREE PROGRAM. AT
PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES. SB THREE
FIFTY FOUR WILL EXTEND THE
CURRENT CALIFORNIA DREAM LOAN
PROGRAM. TO INCLUDE UC AND CSU
GRADUATE STUDENTS THAT MEET AB
FIVE FORTY REQUIREMENTS.
PASSAGE OF SB THREE FIFTY FOUR
WILL MOVE OUR STATE CLOSER
TOWARDS ENSURING THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE THE SAME
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ACADEMIC
SUCCESS RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. AMOS REGINA.
SENIOR DISCUSSION OF A CAR CALL
THE ROLL. SORRY ABOUT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS HAD ABOUT. ALL
MEMBERS OF. DECIDE ABOUT. KIRK
WELL CLOSER ALL. TELL YOUR EYES
FIFTY KNOWS NINE THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY FIVE
IS SB THREE SIXTY THREE.
CORKERY SENATE BILL THREE SIXTY
THREE BY SENATOR PAN AND
ACTUALLY THE WORKPLACE SAFETY.
MS AGUIAR-CURRY. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE
TO PRESENT SB THREE SIXTY THREE
A BELLE A BILL THAT WILL
REQUIRE DATA REPORTING FOR
ASSAULTED BY INMATES ARE
PATIENTS ON STAFF A FACILITIES
RUN BY THE DEPARTMENT OF STATE
HOSPITALS THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES THIS DATA WOULD
INCLUDE THE NUMBER OF
OCCURRENCES FOR EACH FACILITY.
JOB CLASSIFICATION OF EMPLOYEES
ASSAULTED BY A PATIENT OR
INMATE. AND THE DATE OF THE
ASSAULT. DOCUMENTED INCIDENTS
OF VIOLENCE PROVIDE THE
FOUNDATION FOR A WORKPLACE
VIOLENCE PREVENTION. HOWEVER
AGGREGATE DATA REGARDING
ASSAULTS OF STATE EMPLOYEES IN
OUR MOST CHALLENGING
ENVIRONMENT STATE WORK SITES IS
NOT READILY AVAILABLE. SB THREE
SIXTY THREE IT WILL HELP THE
STATE LEGISLATURE AND THE
BARGAINING UNITS OF STATE
EMPLOYEES RECOGNIZE
DEFICIENCIES IN PATTERNS EARLY
AND AID IN IDENTIFYING
NECESSARY STEPS TO REDUCE
FUTURE VIOLENCE AT THOSE WORK
SITES. I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MS
AGUIAR-CURRY SENIOR DISCUSSION
OF A CLUB LEVEL ROSE. PHONE. IS
THERE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF A
RESERVE OF. ALL MEMBERS OTHERS
ARE VOTE. KIRK WELL CLOSER ALL
TIME BUT I SIXTY NINE NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS WE
ARE GOING TO GO BACK TO FILE
ITEM ONE FIFTY SEVEN APPARENTLY.
THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY
SEVEN. THIS IS MISS FRIEDMAN.
THIS IS MISS FRIEDMAN THIS IS
FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY SEVEN. SB
TWO EIGHTY. CLOCK RATE SENATE
BILL TWO EIGHTY BY SENATOR
JACKSON AND ACTUALLY BUILDING
STANDARDS. WE MAY PASS
TEMPORARILY. WE'LL GET CLARITY
ON THAT ITEM THANK YOU
. EVER IS
THIS IS ONE FIFTY SEVEN FILE
ITEM ONE FIFTY SEVEN SB TWO
EIGHTY. CORPORATION SENATE BILL
TWO EIGHTY BY SENATOR JACKSON
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
BUILDING STANDARDS. MS FREEMAN
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE 2% SB TWO EIGHTY
ON BEHALF OF SENATOR JACKSON SB
TWO EIGHTY SIX TO ALLOW MORE
SENIORS AND DISABLED
INDIVIDUALS TO AGE IN PLACE AND
STAY IN THEIR OWN HOMES TO THE
USE OF HOME MODIFICATIONS THAT
REDUCE THE RISK OF FALLING. ONE
THOUSAND PEOPLE EVERY DAY IN
CALIFORNIA TURN SIXTY FIVE
YEARS OLD FALLS ARE THE LEADING
CAUSE OF BOTH FATAL AND
NONFATAL INJURIES FOR
CALIFORNIANS IN THAT AGE GROUP
MOST ARE OLDER ADULTS PREFER TO
REMAIN IN THEIR OWN HOMES AS
LONG AS POSSIBLE BUT MANY ARE
FORCED INTO SKILLED NURSING
ASSISTED LIVING OR OTHER
CONGREGATE LIVING OPTIONS.
BECAUSE THEIR HOMES ARE NO
LONGER PHYSICALLY SAFE FOR THEM
TO LIVE IN. SB TWO EIGHTY ASSN
APARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT DURING
ITS NEXT TRY ANNUAL RULE MAKING
CYCLE TO CONSIDER SOME BUILDING
THE STANDARDS CHANGES INCLUDING
ADDING A WHITE INDOOR WAY IN
ONE BEDROOM TWO BATHROOM ON THE
GROUND FLOOR. RELOCATING
DOORBELLS LIGHT SWITCHES AND
HEATING VENTILATION AND AIR
CONDITIONING CONTROLS TO BE
REACHABLE BY THOSE WITH
MOBILITY IMPAIRMENTS I'M
REQUIRING SUPPORT BACKING IN
ALL BATHROOMS TO EASE THE
FUTURE INSULATION OF GRAB BARS
THIS BILL IS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
IN OPPOSITION AND AS SOMEONE
WHO'S GREAT UNCLE WHO IS NINETY
FIVE IS TRYING TO STAY IN HIS
OWN HOME. I JUST GOT HIT WITH A
THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLAR BILL TO
MAKE IT SAFE FOR HIM TO LIVE I.
REQUEST FULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MS FRIEDMAN SAY
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. SARAH VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE ABOUT. ALL
MEMBERS A DESIRE TO VOTE. CLARK
WELL CLOSER ROLE TELL AYE BUT I
SIXTY SIX NO ZERO. THAT MEASURE
PASSES. THIS IS FILE ITEM. ONE
SIXTY SIX. SB THREE SIXTY SEVEN
CORPORATION SENATE BILL THREE
SIXTY SEVEN BY SENATOR HUESO
AND ACTUALLY THE COASTAL
RESOURCES MR LAURIA THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TO
PRESENT SENATE BILL THREE SIXTY
SEVEN ON BAFFIN SENATOR HUESO
THIS BILL WILL BUILD ON THE-
STATE COASTAL CONSERVANCY'S
EFFORTS TO INCREASE COASTAL
AXIS BY ALLOWING GRANTS FOR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND FOR
THE CONSTRUCTION OF
IMPROVEMENTS ONS OF ON SITE AND
DISTANCE LEARNING FACILITIES
THIS BILL IS ENJOYED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN THE SENATE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
TODAY. DAVIS GLORIA SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CORPS
CORPORAL. ALL MEMBERS VOTE. IT
IS OUT OF A- ALL MEMBERS OF THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TELL YOU ABOUT I
SIXTY TWO NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE
SIXTY SEVEN SB THREE SEVENTY
FIVE CORPORATE SENATE BILL
THREE SEVENTY FIVE BY SENATOR
DRESS SO AND OTHERS IN ACTING
TO VICTIMS OF CRIME MAKING A
PROBATION THEREFORE. MISS SMITH.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER SB
THREE SEVENTY FIVE EXTENDS A
TIME LIMIT FOR CRIME SURVIVORS
TO APPLY FOR HELP FROM THE
CALIFORNIA VICTIMS COMPENSATION
BOARD. IN PAYING FOR BILLS AND
EXPENSES THAT RESULT FROM
VIOLENT CRIME FROM THREE YEARS
TO SEVEN YEARS. UNDER CURRENT
LAW SURVIVORS WHO ARE UNAWARE
OF THE PROGRAM WHO ARE NOT
READY TO APPLY OR WHO ARE
ADDRESSING THEIR TRAUMA YEARS
AFTER THEIR VICTIMIZATION MAY
BE LEFT WITH NO FINANCIAL
SUPPORT FOR ACCESS TO THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED. PASSING SB
THREE SEVENTY FIVE IS THE FIRST
OF MANY STEPS WE CAN TAKE TO
ENSURE THAT SURVIVORS ARE
SUPPORTED AND HAVE ACCESS TO
THE SERVICES THEY NEED TO HEAL.
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED NO NO
VOTES AND NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS SMITH
SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK
LIBERAL. SORRY ABOUT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE TO DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSER WRONGS
TELEVOTE AYE SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES THIS IS
FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY EIGHT. SB
THREE SEVENTY SIX COVERAGE
SENATE BILL THREE SEVENTY SIX
BY SENATOR PORTANTINO AND
ACTUALLY THE FIREARMS DESPAIR
QUE THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS SB THREE SEVENTY
SIX WOULD REDEFINE INFREQUENT
TO MEAN LESS THAN SIX FIREARMS
TRANSACTIONS PER CALENDAR YEAR
REGARDLESS OF THE TYPE OF
FIREARM FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO
SELL. LEASE OR TRANSFER
FIREARMS WITHOUT LEGALLY BEING
REQUIRED TO OBTAIN A LICENSE
THERE'S A DISPARITY IN THE
PENAL CODES DEFINITION OF THE
TERM INFREQUENT WHICH RESULTS
IN A DISPARITY IN THE WAY IN
WHICH UNLICENSED SELLERS OF
FIREARMS ARE TREATED UNDER THE
LAW. INDIVIDUALS MAY OR MAY NOT
BE REQUIRED TO OBTAIN A LICENSE
TO SELL FIREARMS DEPENDING ON
THE TYPE OF FIREARM BEING
TRANSACTED IN SOME INSTANCES
THIS MAY EXEMPT FOR EXAMPLE
NONPROFITS ROOM HAVING TO GO
THROUGH A LICENSED DEALER WHEN
RAFFLE LINGER AUCTIONING OFF A
FIRE ARM. THE DISPARATE
TREATMENT CAUSES CONFUSION AND
MAKES UNCLEAR IF AND WHEN
SELLERS ARE REQUIRED TO AND
SHOULD OBTAIN A LICENSE TO
ENGAGE IN THE BUSINESS OF
TRANSACTING FIREARMS. THIS IS A
PROBLEM BOTH FOR THE PUBLIC AS
WELL AS FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT.
BECAUSE THERE IS A LACK OF
CLARITY. THE PURPOSE OF THE
BILL IS TO STANDARDIZE THE
DEFINITION OF THE TRIP TERM
INFREQUENT. IT IS ALSO INTENDED
TO REDUCE THE FREQUENCY AND
NUMBER OFFIREARMS IN IN IN THE
VISUAL IS ALLOWED TO SELL OR
MANUFACTURER ANNUALLY WITHOUT A
LICENSE. THE BILL WOULD CREATE
A SINGLE LIMIT FOR THE NUMBER
OF TRANSACTIONS AND I'M LICENSE
INDIVIDUAL IS AFFORDED IN A
YEAR REGARDLESS OF THE TYPE OF
FIREARM BEING TRANSACTED. THIS
IS IMPORTANCE. WHERE
TRANSACTIONS MAY HAVE A MIXTURE
OF FIREARMS. THE BILL WOULD
ALSO LIMIT THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
FIREARMS INDIVIDUALS ARE ABLE
TO SELL LEASE OR TRANSFERRED TO
NO MORE THAN FIFTY PER YEAR
WITHOUT HAVING TO OBTAIN A
LICENSE. AND WITH ONLY UP TO
FIVE SEPARATE TRANSACTIONS.
INDIVIDUALS WILL BE REQUIRED TO
OBTAIN A LICENSE IF THEY'RE
SELLING LEASING TRANSFERRING OR
MANUFACTURING MORE THAN FIFTY
FIREARMS A YEAR. CALIFORNIA
WOULD NOT BE THE FIRST STATE TO
INSTITUTE LICENSING
REQUIREMENTS SUCH AS THESE
CONNECTICUT REQUIRES INDIVIDUAL
SELLING MORE THAN TEN HANDGUNS
TO GET A LICENSE. MASSACHUSETTS
GENERALLY REQUIRES ANY
INDIVIDUAL SELLING OR LEASING A
FIREARM TO OBTAIN A LICENSE.
THERE DOES PROVIDE SOME
EXCEPTIONS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. DAVIS BACK A
HAND SEEN NO DISCUSSION DEBATE
CAR CLUB THE ROLE. IS OUR VOTE
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE OF A-
ALL MEMBERS OF. MISERABLE. THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
TELLING ABOUT EYES FORTY NINE
IS FIFTEEN. THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTION THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR
PLEASE REMOVE ITEM TO SEVENTEEN
SB THREE NINETY TWO ALLEN. TO
THE NECK TO FILE. ONE OF.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
BACK TO THE CAN CURRENTS FILE.
TO TAKE UP. TWO ITEMS STARTING
WITH FILE ITEM. THIRTY SEVEN.
THIS IS FILE ITEM THIRTY SEVEN
AB. TWO NINETY FIVE DOCTOR
WOULD CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL
TO NINETY BY SOMETHING MEMBER
WHAT IN OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE DOCTOR
WOULD THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT
AB TWO NINETY FOR CONCURRENCE
AB TWO NINETY IS A BILL
INTENDED TO CURB THE PRACTICE
OF SPECIALTY CARE PROVIDERS
LIKE DIALYSIS AND SUBSTANCE
ABUSE FROM STEERING PATIENTS ON
THE CONSUMER TO ONTO COMMERCIAL
INSURANCE PLANS TO REAP
SIGNIFICANT PROFITS FROM HIGHER
REIMBURSEMENT PAYMENTS. AB TWO
NINETY WAS EXTENSIVELY AMENDED
IN THE SENATOR BY GREATER
PATIENT PROTECTIONS AND
STRENGTHENING OUR GOAL OF THE
OF THE HEARING PATIENTS
CURRENTLY RECEIVING CARE THAT
THEY WILL NOT HAVE THAT CARE
DISRUPTED THE BILL HAS BEEN
AMENDED TO GRANDFATHER IN
EXISTING PATIENCE DELAY
IMPLEMENTATION TO ALLOW THE
AMERICAN KIDNEY FOUNDATION TIME
TO SEEK A NEW I. G. OPINION
REGARDING NEW PARAMETERS FOR
OPERATING CALIFORNIA LASTLY THE
BILL WAS AMENDED IN THE SENATE
HEALTH TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF
PRICE FIXING BY PROVIDING AN
ALTERNATE PAVEMENT PAYMENT
OPTION IN PROCESS FOR PROVIDERS
TO OBTAIN A RATE OTHER THAN
MEDICARE. I WORK VERY HARD MY
COLLEAGUES IN THE SENATE TO
IMPROVE THIS BILL WITH ADDED
PATIENT PROTECTIONS AND TO
ENSURE THE TO ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS. OF THE OPPONENTS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU NETWORK SEEING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE. CAR CLUB
THERE ALL. MEMBERS VOTE IS ARE
NOT. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF. TO DESIRE
TO VOTE. THIS IS FORTY ONE
. ALL
MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF A
. CLARK
WELL CLOSER ALL. TALBOT EYES
FORTY TWO NO SIXTEEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES
. MEMBERS WE HAVE
ONE ITEM ON CALL WE ARE
PREPARED TO LIFT THE CALL. ON
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY EIGHT SB
SIX SIXTEEN THE CARD OPPOSED.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF A.
WELL CLOSER ALL. TELL VOTE EYES
FORTY THREE KNOWS NINETEEN.
THAT MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS WE
ARE. BACK TO THE CAN CARDS FILE
TO TAKE A FILE ITEM NUMBER
FORTY TWO. THIS IS AB NINE
SIXTY FIVE CORPORATION AS A
LEGAL NINE SIXTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARK STONE AND
ACTUALLY TO PEARL. MR STONE
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS THIS IS THE BILL THAT
ALIGNS. CREDIT SYSTEMS WITH THE
AND THE- CDC ARE PROP FIFTY
SEVEN AND YOUTH OFFENDER PAROLE
ARE NOT REALLY ALIVE THIS IS
WHAT BRINGS THOSE TOGETHER
SENATE AMENDMENTS WE HAVE
DROPPED THE ELDERLY PAROLE PEAS
AND WE'VE MADE IT VERY CLEAR
THAT THE SECRETARY OF CDC ARE.
HAS AT HIS DISCRETION THE
ABILITY TO IMPLEMENT THIS
PROGRAM THE PROBABLY STARTING
WITH THE EDUCATION CREDITS WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON CONCURRENCE.
THANK YOU MISTER STONE SAY NO
DISCUSSION OF A CLERK LIBERAL.
THIS ITEM OF ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE ABOUT. ALL MEMBERS A DESIRE
TO VOTE. AND THEN I COULD GO
BACK
. THE CLERK WILL. CLOSE
ROLL TIDE BUT ICE FORTY ONE
KNOWS TWENTY SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. MEMBERS WE
ARE MOVING BACK TO FILE ITEM
TWENTY ONE. THAT IS ON THE
CONCURRENCE FILE. THIS IS FILE
ITEM TWENTY ONE. WE'RE GOING TO
PASS TEMPORARILY
. AND WE'RE
GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY ON
FILE ITEM TWENTY TWO. THIS IS
FILE ITEM TWENTY THREE. WE ARE
GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY ON
FILE ITEM TWENTY THREE. THIS IS
FILE ITEM TWENTY FOUR. AB
THIRTEEN OH SEVEN CORPORATION
AS A LEGAL THIRTEEN OH SEVEN BY
SOME MEMBER BLANCA RUBIO AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO STUDENT
FINANCIAL AID MS RUBIO THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
AB THIRTEEN OH SEVEN IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ADDRESS CHAPTER IN ISSUES THIS
BILL WILL BRING STABILITY TO
THE CAL GRANT A WORD BY
IMPLEMENTING A NEW FUNDING
FORMULA FOR STUDENTS ATTENDING
PRIVATE NONPROFIT UNIVERSITIES.
THIS BILL HAS ENJOYED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST DRIVE OUT
.
THANK YOU MS RUBIO SEE NO
DISCUSSION OF A- COUPLE OF THE
ROLE. THE SERVER ALL MEMBER
SERVICE OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS
OF. DESERVE A. QUIRK WELL CLOSE
ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY THREE NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS. OUR CAN
CURTAIN FILE ITEM TWENTY FIVE.
AB THIRTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN.
OPERATE ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN BY THE ONLY
MEMBER WICKS AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO CAL FOR US MISS
WICKS THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB THIRTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN DIRECT DEPARTMENTS TO
CONSULT WITH STAKEHOLDERS
HOLDERS IN ORDER TO DEVELOP A
STATEWIDE PROCESS FOR THE
PURPOSE OF INCREASING THE
ENROLLMENT OF FAMILIES INTO CAL
FRESH SENATE AMENDMENTS ADDED
LANGUAGE TO INCLUDE THE REP
REPRESENTATIVES OF COUNTY
ELIGIBILITY WORKERS AS PART OF
THE STAKEHOLDER GROUP. THIS
BILL HAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
NO OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. NAME IS
WICKS SAY NO DISCUSSION DEBATE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. THESE
ARE VOTE ALL MEMBERS OF THE
SIDE OF A- ALL MEMBERS OF THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE TELL YOU WHAT I
SIXTY ONE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
THIS IS FILE ITEM. TWENTY
SEVEN. AB FIFTEEN TWENTY TWO.
THAT MEASURE GOT RE REFER I
BELIEVE. PREVIOUSLY. BUT WE
WILL TAKE UP FILE ITEM TWENTY
EIGHT. AB. FIFTEEN TWENTY THREE
CORRECT ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN
TWENTY THREE BY SOMETHING
MEMBER LOW AND ACTUALLY TO
BUSINESS MR LOW THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISS RIGOR MEMBERS IS BACK
FOR CONCURRENT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK PRIVATE. THING WHICH LO SI
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE CLERK
<c.magenta>IBERAL. ALL MEMBERS OF A</c>
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS ARE
DESIRABLE. KIRK WELL CLOSE ROLL
TIDE BUT I SIXTY TWO KNOWS ZERO
SEVEN AMENDMENTS. OUR
CONCURRENT. THIS IS FILE ITEM
TWENTY NINE AB SIXTEEN NINETY
NINE CORPORATION AS A LEGAL
SIXTEEN NINETY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE AND
ACTUALLY THE TELECOMMUNICATIONS
MITCHELL OF IN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
DURING WHAT WAS THE LARGEST
WILDFIRE IN STATE HISTORY THE
MENDOCINO COMPLEX FIRE OUR
FIRST RESPONDERS HAD THEIR DATA
THROTTLED THEY WERE TRYING TO
FIGHT THE FIRE THEY THEIR DATA
SLOWED TO A CRAWL TO GET THEM
THE INFORMATION THAT THEY
DESPERATELY NEEDED. THEY HAD TO
CALL A CUSTOMER SERVICE REP WHO
THEN TRY TO UP SELL THEM TO A
MORE EXPENSIVE PLAN WHEN WE
SEND THIS BILL TO THE GOVERNOR
WE WILL SEND A MESSAGE THAT IN
A STATE OF EMERGENCY KNOW FIRST
RESPONDERS WILL EVER HAVE THEIR
DATA THROTTLED AGAIN I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. ON THIS CONCURRENCE IN
SENATE AMENDMENTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER LIVING. SEE NO
DISCUSSION OF A CAR CLUB IN THE
ROLE. DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF. HER DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLICK WELL CLOSER ALL TIE
BUT I SIXTY ONE NO ZERO SENATE.
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
THIS IS FILE ITEM THIRTY. AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY SIX BY MR DALY
CORPORATION AS A LEGAL
SEVENTEEN THIRTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALY AND
ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC CONTRACTS
MR DAILY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS THIS BILL
REQUIRES LOCAL AGENCIES TO
ADOPT AND MAINTAIN A POLICY FOR
NOTIFYING BIDDERS. ON AWARDED
PUBLIC CONTRACT NOTIFYING ALL
BIDDERS IT HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT HAS NO NO
VOTES. I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS DALY
CITY NO DISCUSSION DEBATE CORP
LIBERAL. IS OUT OF IT ALL
MEMBERS OF. THE DESIGN OF A-
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLICK WELL. CLOSE ROLL
TIDE BUT I SIXTY THREE NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT AND FILE ITEM THIRTY
ONE IS AB SEVENTEEN FORTY
EIGHT. CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN FORTY
EIGHT BY SOME REMEMBER BONTA
ACTUALLY TO EMPLOYMENT MR BONTA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES AB SEVENTEEN FORTY
EIGHT IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE A
TECHNICAL AMENDMENT WAS TAKEN
IN THE SENATE. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE ABOUT. SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CARPOOL OPEN
THE ROLE. MEMBERS OF. DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF. IT IS OUT
OF A. CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL
TIDE LOVE I SIXTY THREE NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. WE WILL PASS TEMPORARILY ON
FILE ITEM. THIRTY TWO. WE.
REFERRED FILE ITEM THIRTY THREE
THIS IS FILE ITEM
. THIRTY FOUR.
WE WILL PASS TEMPORARILY ON
FILE ITEM THIRTY FOUR. THIS IS
FILE ITEM THIRTY FIVE AB THIRTY
FIVE COVERAGE ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY FIVE BY SOMETHING MEMBER
KALRA AND OTHERS AND EXPLAIN TO
EMPLOYMENT MISTER KALRA. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER SENTIMENTS
AB THIRTY FIVE ATTACKED ON
NATURE RESPECTFULLY ASK FROM
AYE VOTE ON THE AMENDMENTS. SAY
NO DISCUSSION OF A CLERK WILL
OPEN. DESERT ABOUT ALL MEMBER
SERVICE OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS
THE DESIRE TO VOTE. CLICK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TELEVOTE EYES FORTY
TWO KNOWS EIGHTEEN SENATE A
MEMBER CERTAIN CURTIN FILE ITEM.
THIRTY SIX. IS AB FORTY NINE.
SEVERAL PASS TEMPORARILY. FILE
ITEM THIRTY SEVEN AB TWO NINETY.
WHAT WE DISPENSED WITH THAT
ITEM ALREADY. THIS IS FILE ITEM
THIRTY EIGHT. AB FIVE NINETY
SIX. BY MISTER GRACE
INCORPORATE AS LEGAL FIVE
NINETY SIX BY SOMETHING MEMBER
GRAYSON AND ACTUALLY MOTOR
VEHICLES MISS RACING THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB
FIVE NINE SIX IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN
THE SENATE WERE MINOR AND
CLARIFYING IN NATURE AND
REMOVED ALL OPPOSITION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I VOTE.
THING WAS GRAYSON SAYING NO
DISCUSSION OF A CORE GLOBAL
ROLE. THESE ARE VOTE ALL
MEMBERS WILL RESERVE A. ALL
MEMBERS OF. DESIRABLE. CLICK
WELL CLOSE ROLE TELL ABOUT AYE
SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
FILE ITEM THIRTY NINE. IS AB
EIGHT OH THREE. SEPARATE
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT OH THREE BY
SOMETHING MEMBER GIPSON
ANOTHER'S AND ACTUALLY THE
PUBLIC SAFETY MISTER GIBSON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT AB EIGHT
OH THREE WHICH IS BACK ON
CONCURRENT SENATE AMENDMENTS
NARROWS THE PROGRAM TO ONLY
INCLUDE PEACE OFFICERS
EMPLOYEES EMPLOYEES. AT CDC ARE
AT ALSO ADDS UP TWENTY CO
AUTHORS ARE RESPECTFULLY ASK
BUT I BONUS BIPARTISAN PIECE OF
LEGISLATION. THANKS GIPSON
SEEING THEIR DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE CARPOOL OVERALL. THESE
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBER
SERVICE ARE BOTH. CLARK WELL.
ZERO TELL YOU THAT I SEVENTY NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT. THIS IS FILE ITEM
FORTY AB EIGHT FORTY NINE
QUICKLY ASSEMBLY WILL EIGHT
FORTY NINE BY SOME REMEMBER
BONTA AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
TO ELECTIONS MR BONTA. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES A. B. FORTY AB EIGHT
FORTY NINE IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE AMENDMENTS IN THE
SENATE STREAMLINED HEARING
PROCESS SEES REDUCE
REQUIREMENTS AND SET HIGHER
THRESHOLDS FOR WHEN TRANSLATION
MUST BE PROVIDED WITH THESE
AMENDMENTS LOCAL GOVERNMENT
ASSOCIATIONS ARE NOW NEUTRAL. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. FAMOUS BONTA SENIOR
DISCUSSION OF A CAR CLUB IN THE
WRONG. IS OUT OF A ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS OF.
ESERVER. WELL. CLOSER ALL
TELEVOTE EYES FIFTY ONE NO
SIXTEEN. SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. THIS IS FILE ITEM
FORTY ONE. AB NINE FORTY FIVE
BY MISTER MCCARTY. CARPOOL RATE
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE FORTY FIVE
BY SOMETHING MEMBER MCCARTY AND
OTHERS AND ACT ON THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. MR MCCARTY. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER THIS MEASURE
IS BACK ON CONCURRENT TO ALLOW
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
PARTICIPATE WITH RECIPROCAL
BANKING DEPOSITS. HELPING THEM
WORK MORE WITH OUR COMMUNITY
BANKS AND OFFERING MORE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR SMALL
BUSINESS ASK YOUR RIVAL THANK
NO DISCUSSION OF A LOCAL GIRL.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
OF. DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE OF A- THE- CLERK
WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I
SIXTY NINE OH ZERO SENATE.
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO BE
BREAKING THE DEMOCRATS WILL
HAVE A CAUCUS IN THE MEMBERS
LOUNGE REPUBLICANS WILL BE IN
THE RULES COMMITTEE ROOM WE
WILL BREAK FOR EXACTLY ONE HOUR
AND RESUME TAKING UP ITEMS
PROMPTLY AT ONE PM
. MEMBERS
THIS IS RECESS UNDER CALL.
RECESS UNDER CALL. THIS IS
RECESS CENTER CALL UNTIL ONE PM
.
MEMBERS WE ARE BACK ON THE
DAILY FILE. WE'RE BACK IN
SESSION. PLEASE JOIN US ON THE
FLOOR WE WILL PICK BACK UP IT
FILE ITEM TWENTY TWO AB TWELVE
THIRTY THREE THE CLERK WILL
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE
THIRTY THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
SMITH ACT LATER PEOPLE
INSTRUCTION MISS SMITH YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AB TWELVE THIRTY
THREE WHICH WOULD MAKE A P.
EXAMS FREE FOR LOW INCOME
STUDENTS AND FOSTER YOUTH IS
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE THIS BILL
HAS RECEIVED NO NO VOTES AND NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE ON CONCURRENT.
THANK YOU MISS SMITH SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. WHERE WELL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THAT ICE FIFTY FIVE NO
ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES. FILE
ITEM TWENTY THREE A. B. TWELVE
FIFTY FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE FIFTY FIVE
BY SOME REMEMBER ROBERT RIVAS
AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT MYSTERY OF US YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED MADAM SPEAKER
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE
FIFTY FIVE BUILT UPON BUILDS
UPON THE GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE
ORDER. TO CREATE A DIGITIZED
INVENTORY OF SURPLUS STATE
PROPERTY THAT COULD BE USED FOR
FORMAL HOUSING SENATE
AMENDMENTS ADDRESSED CHAPTER
THREE ISSUES AND ALSO A
COMBINED EFFORTS WITH OUR
COLLEAGUE. FROM SAN FRANCISCO
THIS BILL ONE ABLE A SEARCHABLE
INVENTORY OF SURPLUS CITY AND
COUNTY PROPERTY TO COMPLEMENT
THE INVENTORY OF SURPLUS STATE
PROPERTY RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR EYE BELOW. THANK YOU
MINISTRY. THANK YOU MISTER
REAVIS SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE. THE CHIME DID
NOT HAPPEN BUT WE ARE VOTING
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED TWO
THIRDS VOTE. MEMBERS WE ARE
VOTING ALL MEMBERS VOTE YOU
JUST HEARD THE HOSTS. I KNOW
THAT YOU RESPOND SO BEAUTIFULLY
THE BELL DOESN'T ALWAYS HAPPEN
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE ICE FIFTY EIGHT
NEWS ZEROS MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO TEST
THE BELL SO NOW IT IS GOING TO
RING AND I ASK YOU NOT VOTE. WE
ARE NOT VOTING WE'RE TESTING
THE CHIME THANK YOU MEMBERS.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM THIRTY TWO
A. B. SEVENTEEN FIFTY FOR THE
CLERK WILL READ SOME BILLS
SEVENTEEN FIFTY FOUR BY SOME
REMEMBER JONES SAWYER NOT
RELATE TO EMERGENCY SERVICES
MISTER JONES SAWYER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED HI THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY FOUR
THE AMENDMENTS WERE TAKING IT'S
AN A. G. O. WERE TO INCLUDE A
SUNSET DATE. IN THE BILL OF
JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY NINE
AT THE REQUEST OF THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS HIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER JONES
SAWYER SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS. OF THEIR TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE
TO VOTE. CLAIRE WELL CLOSE THE
ROLEIN TALLY THAT I SIXTY NEWS
HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM THIRTY FOUR
AB EIGHTEEN TWENTY FOUR THE
CLERK WILL READ. SOME PEOPLE
EIGHTEEN TWENTY FOUR BY THE
COMMITTEE ON NATURAL RESOURCES
AN ACRYLATE VIRAL QUALITY IS
FRIEDMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB EIGHTEEN TWENTY FOUR IS THE
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE
BILL MAKING SEVERAL NON
CONTROVERSIAL MOMENTS TO SEE
CA AND RELATED STATUES AND
YES THAT IS POSSIBLE. IN
ADDITION TO TECHNICAL CLEAN UP
THE BILL RE ENACTS A PRIOR
EXEMPTION FOR THE CLOSURE OF A
REAL REAL GRADE CROSSING
ORDERED BY THE P. YOU SEE
ALLOWING THEM TO QUICKLY CLOSE
UNSAFE CROSSINGS THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS REMOVED TO
PROVISIONS OF THAT CHAPTER IN
LANGUAGE THE BILL IS NO
OPPOSITION AND IS RECEIVE NO NO
VOTES I ASK FOR CONCURRENCE IN
SENATE AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS FRIEDMAN SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ON THEM. VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ON MEMBERS OF
THOSE WHO DESERVE IT. ALL
MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. WHERE TWELVE CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE ICE
FIFTY NINE NEWS HERE THIS
MEASURE PASSES. ME TO FILE ITEM
FORTY THREE AB ELEVEN TEN THE
CLERK WILL READ. SOME ABRIL
LEVINSON BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN ACCOLADE EVER
INCREASES MISREAD MENU ARGAN
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AMENDMENTS MADE TO AB
ELEVEN TEN AND THE SENATE
REMOVED A SEPARATE CATEGORY OF
NOTICING FOR RENT INCREASES A
15% OR MORE. AB ELEVEN TEN
WOULD EXTEND THE NOTICE PERIOD
REQUIRED FOR A LANDLORD TO
IMPOSE A RENT INCREASE OF MORE
THAN 10% ON A TENANT FROM SIXTY
DAYS TO NINETY DAYS THE BILL
HAS NO KNOWN OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON CONCURRENCE THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISS FRIEDMAN SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. WORK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTE ICE FORTY TWO
NEWS TWELVE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM FORTY FOUR AB ELEVEN
EIGHTY FOR THE CLERK WILL READ
SOME THE BILL LIMóN EIGHTY
FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GLORIA
ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC RECORDS. MR
GLORIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR IS BACK
FROM THE SENATE FOR CONCURRENCE
THE TO MINUTES OUR TECHNICAL
AND CLARA FIND IN NATURE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER GLORIA
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE THERE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OF THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED AS ART OF THE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES FORTY
SIX KNOWS NINE THIS MEASURE
PASSES. FILE ITEM FORTY FIVE AB
TWELVE FIFTY FOR THE CLERK WILL
READ SOME BILL TWELVE FIFTY
FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
KAMLAGER-DOVE AND OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE ABOUT CATS COME LONGER
DAD YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU PERMISSION TO USE PROP
MADAM SPEAKER. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. I AM HERE TODAY ON
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE FIFTY FOUR
WHICH IS BACK FROM THE SENATE
ON CONCURRENCE. THE AMENDMENT
ALLOWS FOR THE TAKE OF A BOBCAT
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE FOR THE PROTECTION OF
A SPECIES. LISTED AS ENDANGERED
OR THREATENED UNDER THE FEDERAL
ENDANGERED SPECIES ACT THE
MEASURE RECEIVED OVERWHELMING
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN THE
SENATE. AND LITTLE BOBBY AND I.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU HAS COME LONGER
DOES SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE. THERE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. QUIRK WELL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE EYES FORTY FOUR
KNOWS FOURTEEN BODIES MEASURE
PASSES. MOVING IF I LINE FORTY
SIX A. B. THIRTEEN OH ONE THE
CLERK WILL READ SOME PEOPLE
THIRTEEN OH ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY AN
ACCOLADE SHOT WERE FOR SERVICES
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED CALLING SIM
PLEASE RETURN A. B. THIRTEEN A
ONE TO THIS HOUSE RELATES TO
THE FUNDING SYSTEM FOR PRIVATE
ADOPTION FUNDING. OF THIS IS A
PROGRAM THAT REALLY INCENTIVIZE
OF PRIVATE ADOPTIONS IN LIGHT
OF RECENT FINANCIAL EVENTS WE
RE EXAMINE HOW THAT FUNDING
WORKS AND THIS JUST
RESTRUCTURES IT. GOOD BILL
KNOWN OPPOSITION IRISH AND I
WILL. THANK YOU MISTER COOLEY
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. WHERE WELL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY THREE
KNOWS HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM FORTY SEVEN AB
FIFTEEN TWENTY ONE THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY RULE FIFTEEN
TWENTY ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LOW AN ACCOLADE TO PROFESSIONS
OF LOCATIONS MR LOW YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MINISTER CAN MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE. THANK
YOU MISTER LOS SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OF THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
WHERE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY VOTE ICE FIFTY SIX NO
ZERO. SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. FILE ITEM FORTY
EIGHT AB FIFTEEN FORTY EIGHT
THE CLERK WILL READ SOME AGO
FIFTEEN FORTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GAVE ANOTHER SNACK LATER
STATE GOVERNMENT DECLARING THE
YEARS HE THEIR OF STICK BACK
IMMEDIATELY MR GABRIEL YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS A. B. FIFTEEN
FORTY EIGHT WHICH WOULD CODIFY
THE CALIFORNIA STATE NONPROFIT
SECURITY GRANT PROGRAM. AND
PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED ASSISTANCE
TO NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS AT
RISK OF HATE MOTIVATED VIOLENCE
IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE THE BILL
WAS AMENDED IN THE SENATE TO
ADDED URGENCY AND A SUNSET DATE
THIS WILL BE A GIANT STEP
FORWARD IN PROTECTING OUR MOST
AFFORDABLE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
TARGETED BY HATE GROUPS
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MR GABRIEL
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ON MEMBERS
THE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY VOTE I SIXTY FIVE NEWS
HERE ON THE URGENCY I SIXTY
FIVE NO ZERO ON THE BILL SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM FORTY NINE AB SIXTEEN
SIXTY NINE THE CLERK WILL RANGE
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN SIXTY
NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA
AN ACCOLADE OF FIREARMS MR
BONTA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES A. B. SIXTEEN SIXTY
NINE IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE
AMENDMENTS IN THE SENATE WERE
TECHNICAL IN CLARIFYING IN
NATURE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
BONTA SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER TO GO MR GALLAGHER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS THE ISSUE WITH
THIS BILL IS WERE IN ONCE AGAIN
INCREASING THE DROSE FEE. THAT
DRAWS FEE SHOULD BE. GOING INTO
THE DOJ AND BEING GOING TOWARDS
GETTING. FIREARMS OUT OF THE
HANDS OF PROHIBITED PERSONS
FELONS. THOSE WITH A MENTAL.
ILLNESS THAT PROHIBITS THEM
FROM HAVING A FIREARM. WE STILL
HAVE A HUGE BACKLOG TWENTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE ON THAT
PROHIBITED LIST WHO HAVE NOT
BEEN. ADDRESS BY THE DOJ SO A
LOT OF TIMES WE TALK ABOUT IN
THIS BODY WELL LET'S BAND THIS
GUN THAT LOOKS SCARY OR LETS.
YOU HAVE ONE GUN A MONTH. BUT
WE DON'T DO ANYTHING ABOUT THE
PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY SHOULDN'T
HAVE GUNS AT ALL. AND MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE WE'RE DOING
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO KEEP.
WEAPONS OUT OF THEIR HANDS. I
INSTEAD WE CONTINUE TO DO MORE
MORE LEGISLATION THAT
INTERFERES WITH LAW ABIDING
CITIZENS RIGHT TO OWN AND
POSSESS FIREARMS AS THEIR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO DO. WHY
ARE WE TAKING CARE OF THE
ACTUAL PROBLEM MEMBERS ONCE
AGAIN WE'RE JUST GONNA RAISE
THE FEEL LITTLE BIT MORE BUT
THE FEE IS NOT GOING TO DO WHAT
IT NEEDS TO DO. AND NOBODY'S
HOLDING THIS. ATTORNEY GENERAL
TO ACCOUNT FOR THE FACT THAT
YES HE STILL HAS TWENTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE ON BACKLOG.
WHAT ARE WE GOING TO ADDRESS
THE REAL ISSUE WHEN IT COMES TO
GUN VIOLENCE. HOPEFULLY ONE DAY.
THANK YOU MISTER GALLAGHER
SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER MISTER
MONTE MAKE CLOSE. THANK YOU FOR
THE DEBATE RESPECTFULLY ASK
DRIVER CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE
A- ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
NOTED IS THERE TO VOTE. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE AYE AYES FORTY TWO
NEWS EIGHTEEN SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. FILE ITEM
FIFTY AB SIXTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT
THE CLERK WILL READ SOME LEGAL
SIXTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON
ANOTHER'S AN ACCOLADE TO
RECIDIVISM MISTER CALDERON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER A. B. SIXTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT REQUIRES A DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
TO CONTRACT WITH AN EXTERNAL
RESEARCHER TO ANALYZE THE
EFFECTIVENESS. OF ITS
REHABILITATION PROGRAMS INTO
SUBMIT A REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON THIS AND ALICE
THIS. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE
VOTE IN SENATE CONCURRENCE
THANK YOU MISTER CALDERON
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE A- CLERK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TELLING VOTE ICE
FIFTY NINE NEW ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONFERRED IN.
FILE ITEM FIFTY ONE ONE AB SIX
EIGHTY SIX THE CLERK WILL READ
SO MIDDLE SIX EIGHTY SIX BY
SOME REMEMBER WALDRON AND
OTHERS AN ACCOLADE TO INDIAN
CHILDREN. MISS WALDRON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER SB SIX EIGHTY SIX
IMPROVES CALIFORNIA'S
COMPLIANCE WITH THE FEDERAL
INDIAN CHILD WELFARE ACT. WHICH
WAS ENACT ENACTED IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT TO PROVIDE
IMPORTANT RIGHTS AND
PROTECTIONS TO INDIAN FAMILIES.
WHILE IN THE SENATE WE TOOK
AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS
IMPLEMENTATION CONCERNS RAISED
BY THE ADMINISTRATION THE BILL
HAS NO OPPOSITION AND ENJOYS
BROAD BI PARTISAN SUPPORT I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISS WALDRON SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ON MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE VOTE. CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALENT VOTE I
SIXTY ONE NEWS ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
FILE ITEM FIFTY TWO AB EIGHT
NINETEEN THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT NINETEEN BY
SOME REMEMBER MARK STONE AND I
BELIEVE THE FOSTER CARE MR
STONE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THIS BILL IS A CONTINUATION OF
IMPLEMENTATION BILLS FOR
CONTINUE OF CARE REFORM
CALIFORNIANS DONE QUITE A BIT
OVER THE LAST NUMBER OF YEARS.
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
HONORING OUTCOMES AND WORKING
FOR KIDS RATHER THAN WORKING
FOR THE SYSTEM IN OUR CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM SENATE
AMENDMENTS OR FURTHER TECHNICAL
SUPPORT FROM THE ADMINISTRATION
WE'RE MAKING SURE THAT THAT
WE'RE CLEANING UP SOME THE
IMPLEMENTATION CHALLENGES OF C.
C. R. AS WE SHOULD BE DOING AND
I ASK FOR YOUR- AYE VOTE. ON
SENATE AMENDMENT. THANK YOU
MISTER STAND SEEN HEARING FOR
THE DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLICK WELL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY VOTE I SIXTY FOUR NO
ZERO SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN FILE ITEM FIFTY THREE AB
FIFTEEN OH FIVE THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN OH
FIVE BY SOME REMEMBER O'DONNELL
WHEN OTHERS NECK LATER CHARTER
SCHOOLS. MR O'DONNELL PAT WE'RE
PASSED HIM FOR PASSING
TEMPORARILY ON VIOLATING FIFTY
THREE. AN FIFTY FOUR WE'LL GO
TO FILE ITEM FIFTY FIVE. AB
TWELVE. THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE BY SIMPLY
MIRROR ONE ANOTHER'S MACLAINE
FIREARMS. THE MIST WHEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON AB TWELVE. AB.
TWELVE HIGHLIGHTED FIFTY FIVE
YEAH I WANNA PASS TEMPORARILY
AND THEN GO TO FILE ITEM TWENTY
ONE OF TWENTY ONE OKAY WE WILL
GO TO FILE ITEM TWENTY ONE AB
FOURTEEN SIXTY SIX THE CLERK
WILL READ. SOME PEOPLE FOURTEEN
SIXTY SIX BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ONE ACCOLADE TO IMPLEMENT. WHEN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AB FOURTEEN SIXTY
SIX AS AMENDED IN THE SENATE
CLARIFIES THE AMBIGUITY IN
CURRENT LAW RELATING TO PART
TIME. ADJUNCT FACULTY AT ALL AT
TO NONPROFIT INDEPENDENT
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES.
RECENTLY SEVERAL SCHOOLS HAVE
BEEN FORCED TO TREAT ADD JUG
FACULTY MEMBERS AS TIME CARD
EMPLOYEES WHO HAVE TO TRACK
HOURS WORKED AND NEIL AND REST
BREAKS. THIS BILL WILL ENABLE
ADJUNCT FACULTY IN THE SCHOOLS
TO BE CONTINUED TO. TO CONTINUE
TO BE TREATED AS PROFESSIONALS
THE BILL SETS A MINIMUM
COMPENSATION FLOOR BASED ON A
FORMULA FOR TOTAL HOURS OF
SERVICE. NOT JUST CLASSROOM
TIME TO ACCOUNT FOR TIME
PREPARING LESSONS GRADING
ASSIGNMENTS AND RESPONDING TO
STUDENTS. SUPPORTED BY A ICC
YOU ADD THE SEIU CALIFORNIA
THIS BILL WILL ENSURE THAT
ADJUNCT FACULTY MEMBERS ENJOY
FLEXIBILITY. AND INDEPENDENCE
WHILE BENEFITING STUDENTS WITH.
THEIR PROFESSIONAL EXPERIENCE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER WHEN
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE I SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO
SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MANY FILE ITEM FIFTY FIVE AB
TWELVE THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE TWELVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ONE ANOTHER'S AN
ACCOLADE OF FIREARMS WHEN YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED ALRIGHT THANK
YOU A. B. TWELVE IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE THIS BILL PROVIDES
JUDICIAL DISCRETION TO SET THE
TIME PERIOD FOR A G. B. R. O.
AFTER NOTICING HEARING BETWEEN
ONE TO FIVE YEARS. THE BILL
ALSO MAKES THREE CLARIFICATIONS
THAT MAKE TV ARE OWES MORE
EFFICIENT AND EFFECTIVE BY
ALLOWING AGENCIES TO FILE IN
LIEU OF NAMING INDIVIDUAL
OFFICERS THAT ARE REQUESTING
OFFICER MAY SERVE THE ORDER AND%
THAT ALLOWANCES FOR CEILING
TRANSFER DO NOT APPLY IN
EMERGENCY CONTACTS. WHILE THESE
CHANGES WOULD NOT OF STOP THE
EVENTS OF THE BORDERLINE
SHOOTING IN MY DISTRICT IT IS
MY BELIEF THAT BY STRENGTHENING
AND REFINING OUR EXISTING GUN
LAWS WE CAN HOPE TO PREVENT
ANOTHER COMMUNITY FROM
EXPERIENCE THE HORROR FROM
EXPERIENCING THE HORROR. OF A
MASS SHOOTING I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MISS IRWIN SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO MOVE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE.
WHERE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES FORTY
SEVEN KNOWS THIRTEEN SENTIMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. WILL MOVE
BACK UP TO FILE ITEM FIFTY FOUR
AB TO THE CLERK WILL READ. SOME
PEOPLE TO BUY SOME REMEMBER
SANTIAGO WHEN OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE TO POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION MR SANTIAGO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED I THINK AMEND
SPEAKER AB TWO IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE MAKING SURE THAT
THAT WE GET TWO YEARS OF FREE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. WE'RE VERY PROUD
OF THAT IN THIS BILL HASN'T
CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS THAT THAT
CHANGES SOME OF THE CONDITIONS
FOR STUDENTS I TO RECEIVE THIS
DEBT FREE EDUCATION THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE. THANKYOU MISTER
SANTIAGO MISTER OBERNOLTE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED AND MATTER.
THANK YOU MINISTRY HER
COLLEAGUES TWO YEARS OF FREE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE IS A VERY
LAUDABLE GOAL HOWEVER. I HAVE
TO POINT OUT AS I POINTED OUT
BEFORE THAT NONE OF THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN MY
DISTRICT ARE ELIGIBLE FOR THIS
FUNDING. I THINK IF WE'RE GOING
TO PASS THIS FUNDING FOR ALL OF
CALIFORNIA SHOULD APPLY TO
EVERYONE. IN EVERY DISTRICT NOT
JUST SOME. THANK YOU MISTER
OWNER TASTE SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
MR CENTER YOU MAY CLOSE. I
THANK YOU MA'AM SPEAKER THE I
WOULD ARGUE BACK TO THE
COLLEGES ARE ELIGIBLE THEY JUST
HAVE TO SIGN UP FOR THE PROGRAM
TO BE ELIGIBLE. AND MEET WITH
THE REQUIREMENTS THINK EVENTS.
BURKE WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLAIRE WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY VOTE I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. FILE ITEM FIFTY SIX AB
TWENTY EIGHT THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER OBERNOLTE
ANOTHER WAS AN ACCOLADE HIGH
SCHOOL DIPLOMAS MR OBERNOLTE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
STATISTICS SHOW THAT MANY OF
THE JOBS WILL BE CREATED IN
CALIFORNIA OVER THE NEXT TWENTY
YEARS. WILL REQUIRE EXPERTISE
IN THE STEM FIELDS SCIENCE
TECHNOLOGY ENGINEERING AND
MATHEMATICS HOWEVER STATISTICS
ALSO SHOW THE ARK HIGH SCHOOLS
ARE NOT GRADUATING ANOTHER
STUDENTS WITH THAT EXPERIENCE
THIS BILL AB TWENTY EIGHT WILL
CREATE A STEM SEAL A STATE SEAL
OF STEM. THAT STUDENTS MAY
QUALIFY TO HAVE ON THEIR HIGH
SCHOOL DIPLOMAS TO ENCOURAGE
STUDY IN THESE FIELDS SENATE
AMENDMENTS EXTEND ELIGIBILITY
FOR THE SEAL TO CHARTER SCHOOLS
AND COUNTY BOARD OF EDUCATION
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
CONCURRENCE. IN SENATE
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU MISTER
OBERNOLTE SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE I SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO
SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN BY
LINE FIFTY SEVEN AB FIFTY NINE
THE CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL FIFTY NINE BY SOME
REMEMBER KALRA OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE TO ELECTIONS MISTER
KALRA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER SYMBOL FIFTY
NINE IS BACK IN THE SENATE WITH
AMENDMENTS BASED ON FEEDBACK
FROM SECTORS STATUS LIKE WE ASK
YOUR I'VE A- THANK YOU MISTER
KALRA SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
GO. ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE AS FIFTY FOUR KNOWS NINE
SEVEN AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. FILE ITEM. FIFTY EIGHT AB
ONE THIRTY THREE OF THEIR
KOREAN ASSEMBLY BILL ONE THIRTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBERQUIRK
SILVA ANOTHER SNACK LATER
TAXATION OF MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE IT'S
PARKS LA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER FELLOW
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY AB ONE
THIRTY THREE IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE THE BILL IS. IN A
PRIVATE PROPERTY TAX
POSTPONEMENT PRO MY PROGRAM IN
KEEPING WITH ANALYSIS OF
PARTICIPATION BY THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYSIS OFFICE IN
SHORT THIS BILL WILL HELP
SENIORS STAY IN THEIR HOMES I
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
MISS QUIRK SILVA SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE HE DESIRED. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. BURKE WELL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TELEVOTE I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO
SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN BY
LINE FIFTY NINE EIGHTY TWO OH
FOR THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TO FOR BY SOME
REMEMBER WOULD NATURALLY THE
HOSPITAL'S SIR WOULD YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. MADAM MADAM CHAIR.
AB TWO FORCED BACK AFTER MINOR
AND THEN IS THE SENATE HAS FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. AS DRIVE UP.
THANK YOU MISTER WOULD SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
MEMBERS NO DESIRE TO GO. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THAT I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO
SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
PASS TEMPORARILY IN FILE ITEM
SIXTY AND SIXTY ONE MOVING FILE
I'M SIXTY TWO AB THREE THIRTY
NINE THE CLERK WILL READ. SOME
PEOPLE THREE THIRTY NINE BY
SOME REMEMBER WHEN OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE TO GUN VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDERS MR WHEN YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AB THREE THREE NINE IS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE THIS BILL
WOULD REQUIRE LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES. HAVE
POLICIES AND STANDARDS RELATING
TO GUN VIOLENCE RESTRAINING
ORDERS THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
REDUCE COSTS BY ENCOURAGING
TRAINING ON THE NEW POLICIES TO
BE INCLUDED IN EXISTING
EDUCATION PROGRAMS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR DRIVE A-
THANK YOU MISS IRWIN SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. WORK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY VOTE I
FIFTY SEVEN NO ZERO SENTIMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. BY LETTING
SIXTY THREE AB THREE FORTY THE
CLERK WILL READ SOMETHING BILL
THREE FORTY BY SOME REMEMBER
ONE ANOTHER'S AN ACCOLADE OF
FIREARMS WHEN YOU ARE AGAIN
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AB THREE FORTY IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE AFTER RECEIVING
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT IN THE SENATE
AND THIS BILL SPECIFICALLY
ADDRESSES THE ISSUES OF MY
COLLEAGUE FROM NICHOLAS SO I
CERTAINLY HOPE TO SEE A- GREEN
LIGHT OVER THERE. IN THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET THE LEGISLATURE
APPROPRIATE THREE MILLION
DOLLARS TO FIND ENFORCEMENT
EFFORTS AGAINST THE PROHIBITED
FIREARM POSSESSORS AT THE LOCAL
LEVELS IN THE COUNTIES OF
ALAMEDA SAN DIEGO SANTA CRUZ
AND VENTURA. THIS BILL REQUIRES
ROBUST DATA COLLECTION AND A
REPORT TO BE SUBMITTED TO THE
LEGISLATURE SO WE CAN LEARN
WHAT WORKS WHAT CAN BE IMPROVED
AND HOW TO BETTER FOSTER
COLLABORATION. BETWEEN
JURISDICTIONS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR DR OF. THANK YOU MISS
IRWIN MISTER GALLAGHER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. YES MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS I THINK MY COLLEAGUE
THIS IS IMPORTANT THE PROBLEM
IS THAT THE DOJ AND THEM NOT
ALLOCATING THE RESOURCES WE'VE
GIVEN THE MONEY SEVERAL TIMES
NOW ACTUALLY FIFTEEN MILLION I
BELIEVE THREE YEARS AGO TO DO
THIS JOB MAYBE ONE DAY THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL ACTUALLY DO IT
AND PUT SOME SOME TEETH IN
ENFORCEMENT INTO RESTRAINING
ORDERS AND OTHER THINGS BECAUSE
YOU CAN YOU CAN PASS
RESTRAINING ORDERS GREATER
PROTECTIONS WE CAN ISSUE A
RESTRAINING ORDERS BUT AS HAS
HAPPENED IN MY DISTRICT WE HAD
A GENTLEMAN WITH A RESTRAINING
ORDER AGAINST HIM. BUT HE WAS
NEVER DISARMED BY THE DOJ OR
THE APPS PROGRAM AND HE WENT ON
A SHOOTING RAMPAGE SO UNTIL
THERE'S ACTUAL ENFORCEMENT
AGAINST PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT
SUPPOSED TO HAVE WEAPONS. AND
IT SHOULD BE THROUGHOUT THE
STATE NOT JUST IN CERTAIN
COUNTIES. THAT SOMEHOW ARE
LUCKY ENOUGH TO GET. THIS
FUNDING ALLOCATED TOWARDS IMAGE
SHOULD BE THROUGHOUT THE STATE
THE DOJ. ARE ATTORNEY GENERAL
REPRESENTS ALL OF CALIFORNIA'S
LAST I CHECKED ANYWAYS. MAYBE
ONE DAY HE'LL DO HIS JOB MAYBE
ONE DAY THIS BODY. WILL PUSH
HIM TO DO HIS JOB INSTEAD OF
SUING THE PRESIDENT EVERY TIME
HE WAKES UP EVERY MORNING.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER IS OR WHEN
YOU MAY CLOSE YES AGAIN THIS IS
SPECIFICALLY ADDRESSING THE
ISSUES OF MY COLLEAGUE FROM
NECKLACES A PILOT PROGRAM TO
SEE WHAT THE BEST PRACTICES ARE
AND THE MONEY IS GOING.
DIRECTLY TO THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AND THAT WE CAN
IMPLEMENT THOSE BEST PRACTICES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AFTER WE
FIGURE OUT WHAT WORKS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK DR OF. THANK YOU MISTER
WHEN. THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY SEVEN
NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. ITEM SIXTY FOUR
EIGHTY THREE FIFTY FOR THE
CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE FIFTY FOUR BY SOME MEMBER
QUIRK SILVA ANOTHER'S AN
ACCOLADE SCHOOL MEALS THIS
QUIRK SILVA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB
THREE FIFTY FOUR IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE THIS BILL REQUIRES
SCHOOLS THAT DO NOT PARTICIPATE
IN THE FEDERAL NATIONAL SCHOOL
LUNCH PROGRAM OR THE BREAKFAST
PROGRAM TO REPORT AN
ALTERNATIVE MAIL PROGRAM. TO
ENSURE THAT STUDENTS ARE
PROVIDED WITH ONE ADEQUATE MAIL
PER DAY ANDI RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU MISS
QUIRK SILVA SEEING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS. ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLAIRE WELL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE I SIXTY KNOWS NINE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN. BY
LETTING SIXTY FIVE EIGHTY THREE
FIFTY SEVEN THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE THREE FIFTY SEVEN
BY SOME REMEMBER THIS AREA NOT
RELATED TAXATION MISTER
NAZARIAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER. IT AB
THREE FIFTY SEVEN IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE THIS BILL CLARIFIES
THAT THE TWENTY YEAR STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS FOR COLLECTIONS BY
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD WOULD
START BASED ON THE DUE AND
PAYABLE DATE. OF A TAX
LIABILITY IF NEW ASSOCIATED
LIABILITIES ARE INCURRED SUCH
AS A LEAN OR FEET THEY WOULD BE
SUBJECT TO THE SAME TWENTY YEAR
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS OF THE
ORIGINAL TAX LIABILITY AND
WOULD NO LONGER WE SET THE
STATUE OF LIMITATIONS.
AMENDMENTS AND SENATE WERE.
TECHNICAL ASPECT. WE ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
NAZARIAN SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS ERICA. ALL
MEMBERS KNOW TO DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY VOTE I SEVENTY THREE NO
ZERO SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN FILE ITEM SIXTY SIX AB FOUR
OH SIX THE CLERK WILL READ SOME
BILL FOUR OH SIX BY SOME
REMEMBER THE BONE ANOTHER'S AN
ACCOLADE A DISABILITY
COMPENSATION. IS THE KNOWN YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB FOUR OH
SIX ESTABLISHES A PROCESS TO.
TRANSLATE PAID FAMILY LEAVE
APPLICATIONS FOR OUR
CONSTITUENTS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THIS BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND HAS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND RESPECT THE ASPIRIN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU MISS THE MON
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK.
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALENT
VOTE I SEVENTY THREE NO ZERO
SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
PASS AND RETAIN ON FILE ITEM
SIXTY SEVEN FILE ITEM SIXTY
EIGHT AB FOR EIGHTY NINE THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
FORTY NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MARK STONE AND OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE WATER MR STONE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB FORTY
NINE ENSURES THAT THE STATE.
CAN SPEND THE SUBVENTION FUNDS
THAT ARE DUE TO THE POWER RIVER
FOR FLOOD CONTROL PROJECTS
WE'RE DOING THIS SO THAT WE CAN
MAKE SURE WE HOLD THE GOV THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S FEET TO
THE FIRE GET THE PROJECT DONE
FINALLY AFTER DECADES OF WORK I
ASK FOR YOUR- CONCURRENCE AND
SENATE AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU
MISTER STAND SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY VOTE I SEVENTY NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. FILE ITEM SIXTY NINE EIGHTY
FIVE TWENTY ONE THE CLERK WILL
READ SOME PEOPLE FIVE TWENTY
ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERMAN
AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE HEALING
ARTS SIR BERMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES FOR MY
COLLEAGUES WHO HAVE SAID THAT
GUN VIOLENCE ISN'T ABOUT TAKING
GUNS OFF THE STREET BUT IS
ABOUT. A DROWNED ADDRESSING
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES I HAVE THE
PERFECT BILL FOR YOU AB FIVE
TWENTY ONE IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE EIGHTY FIVE TWENTY
ONE WOULD ESTABLISH A MEDICAL
AND MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDER
EDUCATION AND TRAINING
PROGRAMME FOR FIRE FOR FIREARM
VIOLENCE PREVENTION THE
AMENDMENTS CORRECT. A HANDFUL
OF GRAMMATICAL ERRORS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER BERMAN
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. QUIRK WELL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALENT VOTE I FIFTY NINE NO
ZERO SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. FILE ITEM SEVENTY AB FIVE
FORTY THREE THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE FORTY THREE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH AND
OTHERS AN ACCOLADE TO EDUCATION
MISS SMITH YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB FIVE
FOUR THREE IS BACK ON CAN
CURRENTS IT WOULD REQUIRE HIGH
SCHOOL SERVING GRADES NINE
THROUGH TWELVE TO POSE SEXUAL
HARASSMENT POLICIES REPORTING
PROCEDURES AND RESOURCES. ON A
POSTER IN SCHOOL BATHROOMS
LOCKER ROOMS AND OTHER
PROMINENT LOCATIONS SO THAT
STUDENTS HAVE READY ACCESS AND
ARE FAMILIARIZED WITH THIS
INFORMATION THIS BILL IS
RECEIVED NO NO VOTES AND NO
OPPOSITION. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON CONCURRENT.
Q. MISS SMITH SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THOSE GUYS
SEVENTY NO ZERO SENTIMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM SEVENTY
ONE EIGHTY FIVE FIFTY THE CLERK
WILL READ. SOME PEOPLE FIVE
FIFTY BY SOME REMEMBER FLOOR
AND OTHERS NOT RELATED VETERANS
MR FLOOR YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB FIVE
FIFTIES BACKER CONCURRENCE IN
AMENDMENTS WHICH ARE CLARIFIED
NATURE ONE TAKE THIS MOMENT TO
SAY THANK YOU TO A MEMBER FROM
PALO ALTO. AS INCREDIBLE STAFF
FOR SUPPORT ON THIS BILL IT'S
BEEN INCREDIBLE. TO WORK WITH
YOUR STAFF TO THANK YOU
APPRECIATE IT RESPECTFULLY ASK
DR OKAY. THANK YOU MISTER FLORA
SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. I MEMBERS
VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS SAID HE DESIRED VOTE.
WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE I SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO
SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
FILE ITEM SEVENTY TWO A. B. SIX
FOURTEEN THE CLERK WILL READ
SOME REAL SIX FOURTEEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER EGGMAN OTHERS
NOT RELATED TAXATION
SIGNIFICANT MEDIALLY TAX LEVY.
EGGMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB SIX FOURTEEN IS BACK
WITH FROM CONCURRENT HAVING TO
DO WITH FOOD BANKS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS EGGMAN SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ON MEMBERS NOTICES
ARE DEVOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TELEVOTE I
SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO SENTIMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM
SEVENTY THREE AB SIX TWENTY
NINE THIRTY WILL READ SOME
PEOPLE SIX TWENTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH AND
OTHERS NOT RELATED CRIME
VICTIMS OF MAKING IT A
PROBATIONER FOR. ITS MAKE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AB SIX TWENTY NINE IS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE AND WITH
CHAPTER RING IT WAS AMENDED TO
ADDRESS CO AUTHORS IN THE
SENATE. I IT IS RECEIVE NO NO
VOTES AND HAS HAD BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT. AND BIPARTISAN CO
AUTHORS I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS SMITH
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO THE- ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRED BOTH.
WHERE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE AYE SIXTY EIGHT
NO ZERO SENTIMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM SEVENTY
FOUR EIGHTY SIX FORTY SEVEN THE
CLERK WILL READ. SOME PEOPLE
SIX FORTY SEVEN BY SOME
REMEMBER KALRA ACTUALLY THE
OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY MISTER
KALRA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER MA'AM IS
TAKEN THE SENATE TO AB SIX
FORTY SEVEN CLEAR BY THE
LANGUAGE ON THE SCOPE OF HAD
HAZARDOUS PRODUCTS ONLY
REQUIRING MANUFACTURES WITH
EXISTING SAFETY DATA SHEETS TO
POST INFORMATION ON THE
WEBSITE. AND TRANSLATE INTO FOR
SPECIFIC LANGUAGES ANNA DELAYED
IMPLEMENTATION OF JULY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY OTHER MEMBERS.
ARE CLARIFYING A TECHNO NATURE
IN NATURE AND RESPECT AS RICK.
THANK YOU MISTER KALRA SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
YOU DESERVE A. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TELEVOTE
I SIXTY THREE NO ZERO
SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
FILE ITEM SEVENTY FIVE EIGHTY
SIX EIGHTY FOR THE CLERK WILL
READ SOME PEOPLE SIX EIGHTY
FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE
ANOTHER SNACK LATER BUILDING
STANDARDS MR LIVING YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB
SIX EIGHTY FOUR REQUIRES THE
BUILDING STANDARDS COMMISSION
TO DEVELOP. STANDARDS FOR
DEVELOPING EVEY PARKING
INFRASTRUCTURE IN EXISTING
HOMES AND MULTI FAMILY
RESIDENCES THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF THIS
CONSTRUCTION CURRENTS. THANK
YOU MISTER SEEING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY VOTE I
SIXTY SIX NO ZERO SENTIMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM
SEVENTY SEVEN AB SEVEN EIGHTEEN
THE CLERK WILL READ. SOME
PEOPLE SEVEN EIGHTEEN BY
REMEMBER EGGMAN ANOTHER'S
NATURALLY THE JUVENILES MISS
EGGMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ABOUT
SPEAKER A. B. SEVEN EIGHTEEN IS
BACK FROM CONCURRENT HAVING TO
DO WITH FOSTER YOUTH AND
GETTING THEIR DOCUMENTATION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS EGGMAN SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE WRONG. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. WHERE WELL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY VOTE I
SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO SENTIMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM
SEVENTY EIGHT AB SEVEN FORTY
EIGHT THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN FORTY EIGHT
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON
ACCOLADE AND ON MINOR
DEPENDENCE FORGET SAYING YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM
SEVENTY EIGHT. FILE ITEM
SEVENTY NINE AB SEVEN FIFTY TO
THE CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVEN FIFTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GAVE ANOTHER
SNACK LATER PUBLIC TRANSIT IS
YOUR GABRIEL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB
SEVEN FIVE TO A BILL THAT WOULD
ENSURE THAT NURSING WOMEN ARE
PROVIDED WITH A SAFE AND
HYGIENIC SPACE TO BREAST FEED
OR PUMP PRESS MEDICAL TRAVELING
IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE. THE
BILL WAS AMENDED IN THE SENATE
TO LIST THE SPECIFIC MULTI
MODAL TRANSIT STATIONS AND
PASSED THE SENATE UNANIMOUSLY
WITH BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MR GABRIEL
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON. THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO
DESERVE IT. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. FOR TWELVE
CLOSE THE ROLE AND HOW THEY
VOTE I SIX SEVEN NO ZERO
SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN. BY
LETTING ME ONE AB FIFTY TWO THE
CLERK WILL READ SOME PEOPLE
EIGHT FIFTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURKE ANOTHER
SNORKELING PEOPLE INSTRUCTION
THIS BURKE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB EIGHT FIFTY TWO ESTABLISHES
A PROCESS FOR THE REGULAR
REVISION OF ACADEMIC CONTEXT
STANDARDS PRIOR TO THE REVISION
OF CURRICULUM FRAMEWORK. SENATE
AMENDMENTS REVISED THE
REQUIREMENT THAT THE STATE
BOARD OF EDUCATION NOTIFY
SPECIFIED PARTY'S WIN IT
INTENDS TO MODIFY OR REJECT
ACADEMIC CONTENT STANDARDS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT WE CAN
KERR AND SENATE AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU MISS BURKE SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ON THEM AS WELL. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THAT I SEVENTY ONE NO
ZERO SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN BY. THE CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND GENERAL
SIXTY TWO IN THE FALL NOTICE
REQUIREMENT TO THE ALLOW THE
FOLLOWING COMMITTEES TO MEET.
HEALTH COMMITTEE TO ME AND TO
HEAR AB FOR FOURTEEN BONTA AND
AB SEVEN FIFTEEN IS THERE AND
ON WEDNESDAY SEPTEMBER ELEVENTH
AT NINE THIRTY AM IN ROOM FOUR
THIRTY SEVEN INSURANCE
COMMITTEE TO ME. AND TO HEAR AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTEEN DAILY ON
WEDNESDAY SEPTEMBER ELEVENTH
UPON CALL THE CHAIR IN THE ROOM
IN A ROOM TO BE DETERMINED. THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE TO ME AND
TO HEAR AB TWO FIFTY THREE MARK
STONE IN AB EIGHTEEN TWENTY.
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE ON
WEDNESDAY SEPTEMBER ELEVENTH AT
NINE THIRTY AM IN ROOM FOUR
FOUR SEVEN THE LABOR EMPLOYMENT
COMMITTEE TO MEET AND TO HEAR
AB THREE SEVEN. THREE SEVEN
EIGHT AMOUNT ON THURSDAY
SEPTEMBER TWELFTH AT NINE
THIRTY AM IN ROOM. FOUR FORTY
SEVEN PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE
TO MEET. AND TO HEAR AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY FOUR JONES
SAWYER ON WEDNESDAY SEPTEMBER
ELEVENTH AT NINE AM IN ROOM ONE
TWENTY SIX. THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE TO MEET AND HEAR A.
B. SEVEN FIFTY NINE BIGELOW IN
AB EIGHT THIRTY THREE LACKEY ON
WEDNESDAY SEPTEMBER ELEVENTH AT
NINE THIRTY AM IN ROOM. FORTY
TWO OH TWO THE COMMITTEE WILL
ALSO HEAR THE FOLLOWING
RESOLUTIONS ACR ONE OF SEVEN
MELENDEZ ACR ONE TWELVE BIGELOW
ACR ONE NINETEEN FLOOR ACR ONE
TWENTY. QUIRK ACR ONE TWENTY
FOURTH ARAMBULA ACR ONE TWENTY
SEVEN FLORA ACR ONE TWENTY A
GRAY S. C. R. FORTY SIX
GALGIANI AN S. C. R. FIFTY SIX
MCGUIRE WATER PARKS AND
WILDLIFE COMMITTEE TO MEET AND
TO HEAR AB TWO FIFTY SIX
AGUIAR-CURRY ON THURSDAY
SEPTEMBER TWELFTH AT NINE
THIRTY AM IN ROOM FOUR FORTY
FOUR. NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE TO MEET AND TO HEAR
AB ELEVEN NINETY ONE BONTA AND
SB FIFTY FOUR ALLEN ON
WEDNESDAY SEPTEMBER ELEVENTH AT
NINE AM IN ROOM FOUR FORTY
FOUR. WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE
MOVE ITEM. ONE FORTY FIVE AT
THE THREE FIFTY SIX WIRED TO
THE INACTIVE FILE. PURSUANT TO
ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY SIX I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RE
REFER SB SIX SIXTY FOUR ALLEN.
FROM THE RULES COMMITTEE FOR
THE PRIVACY AND CONSUMER
PROTECTION COMMITTEE AND THEN.
TO THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. MOVING BACK ON THE
FILE TO FILE ITEM EIGHTY TWO AB
EIGHT SIXTY NINE CLERK WILL
READ. SOME MIDDLE AGE SIXTY
NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CUNNINGHAM ACTUALLY TO SEE
PROPERTY. CUNNINGHAM YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AB STATE SIXTY NINE IS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE IT WAS
AMENDED TO ADDRESS CHAPTER RING
OUT ISSUES AND PASSED THE
SENATE FORTY TO ZERO. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
CUNNINGHAM SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE- ALL
MEMBERS VOTED AS ART OF THE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. BURKE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY VOTE I SEVENTIES NO
ZERO SENTIMENTS ARE COMPARED IN
FILE ITEM EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY
NINE FIFTY FOR THE CLERK WILL
READ SOME PEOPLE NINE FIFTY
FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER WOULDN'T
ACTUALLY THE DENTAL SERVICES
SIR WOULD YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THINK ABOUT A SPEAKER EIGHTY
NINE FIFTY FOUR IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE OF FROM THE SENATE
WITH MINOR AMENDMENTS. IT'S A
LOOK INTO THE COMPLEX WORLD OF
DENTAL PROVIDER AGREEMENTS
FASCINATING STUFF IS AN AWESOME
BILL I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU MISTER WOULD SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK. WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE HE
DESIRED BOAT. WHERE TWELVE
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE I SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO
SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
FILE ITEM EIGHTY FOUR AB NINE
SIXTY SEVEN THE CLERK WILL READ
SOME PEOPLE NINE SIXTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SMITH ACCOLADES
SCHOOL ACCOUNTABILITY ISS
SMITH YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB NINE SIX
SEVEN IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE
THIS BILL INCLUDES ALL LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES IN THE LOCAL
CONTROL ACCOUNTABILITY IN
PLANNING PROCESS. AND SUPPORTS
THE LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR'S
GOAL OF ALIGNING CHARTER SCHOOL
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
WITHOUT OF ALL STATE ELLIE. ETS
IRATE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE ON CONCURRENT. THANK YOU
MISS SMITH SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE THE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
WHERE WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE EYES FORTY SEVEN
NEWS FIFTEEN SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. BYLINE EIGHTY
FIVE EIGHTY NINE NINETY THREE
THE CLERK WILL READ SOME AGO
NINE NINETY THREE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THIS AREA THAT REALLY TO
HEALTHCARE COVERAGE STERN IS
VERY AND YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER A. B.
NINE NINE THREE IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE. THIS BILL REQUIRES
A HEALTH PLAN OR AN INDIVIDUAL
INSURANCE PLAN TO PERMIT AN HIV
SPECIALIST TO BE AN ELIGIBLE
PRIMARY CARE PROVIDER IF THE
SPECIALIST REQUESTS PRIMARY
CARE PROVIDER STATUS AND MEETS
THE HEALTH CARE SERVICE PLANS
ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA THIS BILL
IS DESIGNED TO HELP PATIENTS
SEEKING TO ACCESS. THEIR
COMPREHENSIVE HEALTH CARE
THROUGH THEIR HIV SPECIALISTS
WHEN THEY ARE HAVING DIFFICULTY
DOING SO IN A TIMELY MANNER
AMENDMENTS TAKEN AND SENATE
INSURE THAT INSURANCE PLANS
ONLY HAVE TO PAY HIV SPECIALS
PRIMARY CARE RATES WHEN HIV
SPECIALISTS ARE PROVIDING
PRIMARY CARE SERVICES. THIS
BILL HAS BEEN IN WHAT THE WORKS
FOR AT LEAST THREE YEARS AND
HAS BEAT BEEN VETOED ONCE AND
I'M HOPING THAT THIS IS GONNA
BE THE CHARM. WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO THE- ALL MEMBERS
VOTED DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THIRTY DESIRE TO VOTE.
BURKE WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SEVENTY NO
ZERO SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO BACK
UP IN FILE TO FILE ITEM SEVENTY
EIGHT AB SEVEN FORTY EIGHT THE
CLERK WILL READ SOME PEOPLE
SEVEN FORTY EIGHT BY SOME THE
RIVER GIPSON ACCOLADE A NON
MINOR DEPENDENCE IS TO GET SEND
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL. SEVEN FORTY
EIGHT WHICH IS BACKROOM
CONCURRENCE OF RESPECTFULLY ASK.
FOR THE AYE VOTE THIS BILL IS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER GIVE SAN.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED AS OUR TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
WHERE WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELLING VOTE I SIXTY NINE NO
ZERO SENATE MEMBERS ARE
CONCURRED IN
. FILE ITEM EIGHTY
SIX AB TEN SIXTY ONE THE CLERK
WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL TEN
SIXTY ONE BY SOME REMEMBER
GIPSON ACCOLADE TO FOSTER CARE
MISTER GIBSON YOU ARE AGAIN
RECOGNIZED. MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I'M PRESENTING ASSEMBLY
BILL TEN SIXTY ONE WHICH IS
BACK ON CONCURRENT SENATE
AMENDMENTS AT TECHNICAL IN
CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
RESPECTFULLY ASK BUT I VOTE. ON.
TEN SIXTY ONE. THANK YOU MISTER
GIVE SENTENCING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE A-
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ON MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR
TO VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLAND TALLY THE VOTES I SEVEN
OH ZERO SAN AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN BY LATE EIGHTY
SEVEN AB TEN NINETY SEVEN THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
TEN NINETY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN ACRYLATE.
PEOPLE INSTRUCTION MR HOLDING
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER ASSEMBLY BILL TO
NINETY SEVEN IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION. AB TEN NINETY SEVEN
AS A TRANSPARENCY MEASURE THAT
DIRECTS CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION TO REPORT ON THE
USE OF CREDIT RECOVERY IN
CALIFORNIA AND ALSO DEFINES
CREDIT RECOVERY IN STATUTE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER HOLDEN SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK. WILL
OPEN THE ROLE ALL MEMBERS.
THIRD OF THE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
TO THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. WORK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TELEVOTE I
SIXTEEN I KNOW ZERO SENTIMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. FILE ITEM
EIGHTY EIGHT AB ELEVEN TWENTY
NINE THE CLERK WILL READ SO
MIDDLE LEVEL TWENTY NINE BY
SOME REMEMBER CHAO AND OTHERS
NOT REALLY TO PRIVACY SEARCH
HOW YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM SPEAKER AB
ELEVEN TWENTY NINE IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE TO SENATE AMENDMENT
SIMPLY ADDRESS. CHOP DURING OUT
ISSUES I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
ABOUT. THANK YOU MISTER CHAO'S
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS TO THEIR TO
VOTE. CLERK WILL FLOWS THE ROLE
IN TELEVOTE EYES SIXTY SIX NO
ZERO SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. FILE ITEM EIGHTY NINE AB
ELEVEN THIRTY TO THE CLERK WILL
READ SOME LIBERAL LIVING THIRTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GABRIEL
ANOTHER SPECULATED HELP
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SISTER
GABRIEL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER A. B.
ELEVEN THIRTY TWO IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE THE BILL HELPS
CRACKDOWN ON CALLER ID FRAUD IN
SPAM CALLS RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MR
GABRIEL SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE IT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE. WORK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY VOTE I SIXTY SEVEN NO
ZERO SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN FILE ITEM NINETY AB ELEVEN
SIXTY SIX THE CLERK WILL READ
SOME OF ROLL LEVIN SIXTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE ACCOLADE
UNDERGROUND INFRASTRUCTURE MR
LIVING YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERSI RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE ON CONCURRENCE ON
SENATE. AMENDMENTS THANK YOU
MISTER GREEN SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. WHERE WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE I SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN FILE ITEM NINETY ONE AB
ELEVEN EIGHT HE THE CLERK WILL
READ SOME REAL LEVIN EIGHTY BY
SOME REMEMBER FRIEDMAN AND
ACCOLADE WATER. IS FRIEDMAN YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. MEMBERS AB
ELEVEN EIGHTY IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE AFTER PASSING THIS
HOUSE IN MAY WITH BROAD
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THE MEMONS
IN THE SENATE WERE CLARIFYING
AND TECHNICAL IN NATURE AB
ELEVEN EIGHTY REQUIRES A
CALIFORNIA WATER RESOURCES
BOARD TO UPDATE REGULATIONS FOR
NON POTABLE RECYCLE WATER.
FOUNTAINS TITLE TWENTY TWO BY
TWENTY TWENTY THREE THIS BILL
IS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND NO NO VOTES ND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
FRIEDMAN SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. WELL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY
SEVEN NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN MOVING TO FILE
ITEM NINETY THREE AB TWELVE
FOURTEEN THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE FOURTEEN
BY SIMPLY WERE MELENDEZ AND
ACCOLADES SCHOOL EMPLOYEES.
MELENDEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER THE
TWELVE FOURTEEN IS BACK FROM
THE SENATE ON CONCURRENT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS MELENDEZ SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
VERY VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. BURKE WILL
LOSE THEIR ROLE IN TALLY VOTE I
SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO TAKE UP
THE SPEAKER PRO TEM SPILLS. SO
WE WILL BE MOVING BACK UP IN
FILE ORDER TO FILE ITEMS SIX.
AB SEVEN EIGHTY FOR THE CLERK
WILL REIGN SOME PEOPLE SEVEN
EIGHTY FOUR BY SUMMER ROLE OF
ANOTHER'S AND ACTUALLY TAXATION
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY TAX
LEVY MR MULLIN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB SEVEN EIGHTY
FOUR WHICH WILL EXEMPT ZERO
EMISSION TRANSIT BUSES FROM THE
STATE PORTION OF THE SALES TAX
UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. IS
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE AND SENATE
AMENDMENTS THESE AMENDMENTS
LIMIT THE EXEMPTION TO PUBLIC
AGENCIES AT SENATOR HILLS A CO
AUTHOR INCLUDE VARIOUS
DEFINITIONS AND TECHNICAL FIXES
ARE RESPECTFULLY. ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
MULLIN SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. WHERE WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY VOTE I
SIXTY SIX NO ZERO SENTIMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. NINETY FILE
ITEM ONE FIFTY TWO SB FORTY
NINE THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL FORTY NINE BY
SENATOR SKINNER AN ACCOLADE
ENERGY MR MULLIN YOU ARE AGAIN
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU AGAIN
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS SB FORTY
NINE WILL ALLOW CUSTOMERS TO
CONNECTS MART METERS WITH SMART
APPLIANCES SO THEY CAN BETTER
MANAGE THEIR ENERGY DEMAND A
REDUCE THEIR ENERGY BILLS BY
USING ELECTRICITY OFF PEAK. SB
FORTY NINE ALSO CLARIFIES THAT
THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION CAN CONSIDER GRADE
RELIABILITY BENEFITS WHEN
ESTABLISHING ENERGY EFFICIENCY
BUILDING STANDARDS AND
APPLIANCE SANDERS AND DIRECTS
THE CDC TO SET UP PLANTS
STANDARDS TO FACILITATE LOAD
MANAGEMENT THROUGH DEMAND
RESPONSE THE BILL WILL IMPROVE
CALIFORNIANS ABILITIES TO USE
CLEAN AND EXPENSE OF POWER AND
WILL HELP CALIFORNIA
EFFICIENTLY UTILIZED
ELECTRICITY. FROM RENEWABLE
SOURCES AND ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER MULLIN SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK. MR
HOLDEN. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED I
APOLOGIZE. I'LL MAKE A COMIC A
BRIEF I JUST WANTED TO STAND
AND JOIN IN SUPPORT OF THIS
VERY IMPORTANT MEASURE THIS
BILL DID HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
MAKE IT TO UTILITY AND ENERGY
WERE RECEIVE UNANIMOUS SUPPORT
AND WE- ARE ASKED FOR THIS BODY
TO SUPPORT AS WELL. THANK YOU
MISTER HOLDEN. MR MULLIN YOU
MAY CLOSE. ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS
VOTE IS ARE THE- ALL MEMBERS OF
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ON
MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. BURKE WELL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY ONE
KNOWS TEN MEASURE PASSES
. ONE
THIRTY TWO IN A FILE ITEM TO
TWENTY SB FOUR SIXTY EIGHT THE
CLERK WILL READ. SENATE BILL
FOUR SIXTY EIGHT BY CENTER
JACKSON THAT ACTUALLY TO
TAXATION MR MULLIN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THEY GET MA'AM
SPEAKER CALIFORNIA HAS NEARLY
EIGHTY TAX EXPENDITURES THAT
REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF TAX
COLLECTED FOR THE STATE IN
EXCHANGE FOR AN INTENDED PUBLIC
POLICY OBJECTIVE. MANY TAX
EXPENDITURES WERE CREATED
DECADES AGO TO ACHIEVE CERTAIN
GOALS AND ECONOMIC BENEFITS
SUCH AS IMPROVING INDUSTRY
COMPETITIVENESS INFLUENCING
TAXPAYER BEHAVIOR SPURRING
ECONOMIC GROWTH ALL WORTHY
GOALS. THE FACT IS HOWEVER THAT
WE HAVE NO IDEA. IF THESE
EXPENDITURES ARE WORTH THE
SHOULD NEVER CAN COST
CALIFORNIA BEARS TO KEEP THEM
ALIVE THIS YEAR ALONE TAX
EXPENDITURES WILL REDUCE
GENERAL FUND REVENUE BY SOME
SIXTY SIX BILLION DOLLARS. TO
HELP THE CITY ADDRESSES ISSUE
SB FOUR SIX A WILL REQUIRE THE
UNIVERSITYOF CALIFORNIA
ANALYZE HE'S TAX EXPENDITURES
TO DETERMINE IF THEY ARE
ACHIEVING THE GOALS THE
LEGISLATURE INTENDED. ONCE THE
UC COMPLETES THE ANALYSIS ITS
FINDINGS WILL BE PRESENTED TO A
NON PARTISAN BOARD COMPRISED OF
THE STATE COMPTROLLER THE LA L.
THE STATE AUDITOR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE FOR THEIR DESIGNEES AND
AN EXPERT IN TAX ADMINISTRATION
DESIGNATED BY THE SECRETARY OF
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS. AFTER
CONSIDERING INFORMATION FROM
STAKEHOLDERS IN THE PUBLIC THE
BOARD SHALL MAKE A
RECOMMENDATION TO THE
LEGISLATURE AS TO WHETHER THE
TAX EXPENDITURE AT ISSUE IS
MAYBE THE PURPOSE FOR WHICH IT
WAS ESTABLISHED AND SHOULD BE
CONTINUED OR WHETHER. IT SHOULD
BE ALTERED TO REPEAL. THE BILL
THAT REQUIRES OUR OWN REVENUE
AND TAXATION COMMITTEE IN
CONCERT WITH THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE TO HOLD THE JOINT
PUBLIC HEARING. TO CONSIDER THE
UC'S REPORT AND THE BOARD'S
RECOMMENDATIONS. THIS BILL WILL
BEGIN OVERSIGHT PROCESS FOR TAX
EXPENDITURES THAT WE HAVE NEVER
BEFORE HAD IN OUR STATE'S
HISTORY AND IS LONG OVERDUE.
AND ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MISTER MULLIN MISTER MEDINA
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. I
STAND IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
SIXTY EIGHT. THIS BILL BEGINS
THE PROCESS OF REVIEWING TAX
EXPENDITURES UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA WILL PERFORM THE
NONPARTISAN RESEARCH ON THE
LARGEST NON PERSONAL INCOME TAX
EXPENDITURES PUBLIC ENTITIES
WILL HOLD PUBLIC HEARINGS TO
PRESENT THE RESEARCH DONE BY UC
MAKING RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
LEGISLATURE WHETHER OR NOT TO
MAINTAIN REDUCE OR INCREASE OR
REPEAL. TAX EXPENDITURES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER MEDINA
MISTER TING YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I ALSO
WANT TO RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB FOUR SIX EIGHT I HEARD
THIS MEASURE REVAN TAX. HE WILL
BE OF OVER EIGHTY TAX
EXPENDITURES WHICH SPEND SIXTY
BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR WITH
VERY LITTLE REVIEW ANNUALLY
THIS BILL IS SORELY NEEDED TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE SPENDING
THAT MONEY WISELY AND WE'RE
GETTING. THE BANG FOR OUR BUCK
THAT WE SORELY NEEDED EVERY
ASPECT OF OUR STATE BUDGET
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AYE VOTE ON SB FOUR SIX EIGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER KING SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER MISTER MULLIN YOU
MAY CLOSE. AS FERNANDO. CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
OF THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED AS
OUR DEVOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY VOTE AYE AYES
FORTY FIVE NO SEVENTEEN THIS
MEASURE PASSES MOVING BACK UP
IN FILE ORDER TO FILE ITEM ONE
FORTY SEVEN SB FIVE THE CLERK
WILL READ. SENATE BILL FIVE BY
CENTER BELL AN ACCOLADE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT FINANCE MR MULLIN
YOU ARE GOING RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU AND FINALLY MADAM SPEAKER
IT'S NO SECRET WE'RE IN THE
MIDST OF A HISTORIC HOMELESS
AND HOUSING CRISIS CURRENTLY
THERE ARE TWO POINT TWO MILLION
EXTREMELY LOW AND VERY LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS COMPETING FOR
ONLY. SIX HUNDRED AND SIXTY
FOUR THOUSAND AFFORDABLE HOMES
THIS LEAVES MORE THAN ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION OF CALIFORNIA'S
LOW SUCCUMB HOUSEHOLDS WITHOUT
ACCESS TO HOUSING AND AT RISK
OF BECOMING HOMELESS SB FIVE.
MAKES THE STATE A LONG TERM
FINANCIAL PARTNER TO
IMMEDIATELY CONSTRUCT
DESPERATELY NEEDED AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR HARD WORKING
CALIFORNIANS IT ALSO HELPS
ALLEVIATE POVERTY CREATE JOBS
TO MEET OUR STATEWIDE
ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS WITHOUT
AFFECTING SCHOOL FUNDING. IT IS
ESTIMATED THAT SB FIVE WILL
CREATE UP TO EIGHTY SIX
THOUSAND NEW AND REHABILITATED
HOUSING UNITS THREE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY NINE THOUSAND JOBS AND
SPUR MORE THAN SIXTY BILLION
DOLLARS IN ECONOMIC ACTIVITY.
OVER A TEN YEAR PERIOD SB FIVE
REQUIRES AT LEAST 50% OF ALL
FUNDING BE USED TO BUILD
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND REQUIRES
GEOGRAPHIC EQUITY. IN ADDITION
SB FIVE CONTAINS STRONG
ACCOUNTABILITY PROVISIONS TO
ENSURE FUNDS ARE ONLY SPENT ON
DESIGNATED PROJECTS TO PROTECT
SCHOOL FUNDING. THE STATE
COMMITTEE HOUSE UNDER EACH CD
HOUSING COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
TO REVIEW AND APPROVE PROPOSED
PLANS PROVIDING STRONG STATE
OVERSIGHT. THE COMMITTEE IS
ALSO A POWER TO TAKE CORRECTIVE
ACTION WHEN LOCALS DO NOT MEET
THEIR PLANS OBJECTIVES. SB FIVE
CONSENT PAINS STRONG
PROTECTIONS FOR STATE BUDGET.
THE BILL ONLY SETS OF THE
STRUCTURE OF THE PROGRAM IT HAS
KNOWS IT AS ZERO FISCAL IMPACT
UNTIL THE GOVERNOR AND
LEGISLATURE ALLOCATE FISCAL
AUTHORITY. FUTURE PROJECT
APPROVALS DURING ECONOMIC
DOWNTURNS THE LA I WAS
CONFIRMED THERE WOULD BE NO
NEGATIVE FISCAL IMPACT TO
SCHOOLS. THE STATE IS REQUIRED
TO BACK FILL SCHOOLS UNDER PROP
NINETY EIGHT AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER MULLIN SEE MR KILEY YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I UNDERSTAND VERY MUCH
THE NEED THAT A LOT OF
MUNICIPALITIES HAVE FOR THIS
SORT OF FUNDING BUT I JUST
FOUND A WORD OF CAUTION ASIDE
FROM SIR THE MIXED EVIDENCE ON
TAX INCREMENT FINANCING AS WELL
AS THE DANGER I THINK THE
LEGISLATION PROS POSES TO
PROPERTY RIGHTS I THINK THERE
SHOULD ALSO BE SOME HESITATION
FOR THE LONG TERM FUNDING
STREAMS THAT WE'RE GONNA BE
CREATING HERE THIS AUTHORIZES
THE CREATION OF UP TO NINE
FUNDING STREAMS AND AMOUNTS
FROM **** TWO HUNDRED MILLION
TO TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION.
EVERY YEAR AND ONCE THOSE ARE
APPROVED THEY'RE LOCKED IN
PLACE FOR A PERIOD OF THIRTY
YEARS WHICH MEANS THAT WHEN WE
FACE AN ECONOMIC DOWNTURN AND
WERE FORCED TO MAKE BUDGET CUTS
EVERY DOLLAR THAT GOES TO GET
THIS IS A DOLLAR IT'S GONNA BE
TAKEN AWAY FROM PARTS OF OUR
BUDGET THAT ARE NOT
CONSTITUTIONALLY PROTECTED LIKE
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA OR
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY OR
SOME CORRECTIONS PROGRAMS OR
OUR COURTS AND SO I WOULD JUST.
ADD THAT WORD OF CAUTION BEFORE
WE PASS LEGISLATION THAT COULD
WALK US IN TO THOSE SORT OF.
UNTOUCHABLE LONG TERM FINANCIAL
COMMITMENTS. THANK YOU MISTER
KILEY. IS AGUIAR-CURRY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. I RISE TODAY IS A
PROUD CO AUTHOR OF SB FIVE WE
NEED CREATIVE SOLUTIONS LIKE
THIS TO ONE ONE TO SUCCESSFULLY
COMBAT THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
CRISIS IN PARTICULAR SB FIVE
INSURERS ARE SMALL CITIES AND
TOWNS HAVE A FAIR SHOT THE
RECEIVING SOME OF THE FUNDING
IN THIS BILL. A RURAL
COMMUNITIES ARE OFTEN FORCED TO
COMPETE WITH LARGER URBAN
AGENCIES WHICH HAVE ACTUAL
DEPARTMENTS TO APPLY FOR THESE
PROGRAMS. WE HAVE MAYBE A
PERSON. OUR STATE'S HOUSING
CRISIS IS AFFECTING ALL
COMMUNITIES LARGE AND SMALL SO
I APPRECIATE THAT SB FIVE
DEDICATES A PORTION OF THE
FUNDING FOR OUR RURAL AREAS I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS MEASURE FORD AND
I ARE. ARE I URGE AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
MISTER MULLIN YOU MAY CLOSE.
SPEAKER THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS THERE'S A HOUSING
CRISIS SB FIVE AS PART OF THE
SOLUTION IT MAXIMIZES STATE
INVESTMENTS PROVIDE STRONG
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY SB
FIVE WILL INCREASE OUR FOR
HOUSING STOCK. GET MORE PEOPLE
OFF THE STREETS AND KEEP
FAMILIES IN THEIR HOMES AS FOR
I HAVE A- CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE DEVOTED. BURKE WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THOSE
GUYS FORTY SEVEN KNOWS THIRTEEN
THIS MEASURE PASSES. MOVING
BACK. IN A FILE ITEM FOR AB SIX
TWENTY THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE SIX TWENTY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY
IMMACULATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT
MR COOLEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
COLLEAGUES THIS BILL SETS IN
STATUTE OF RULES GOVERNING
SUDDEN. UNEXPLAINED DEATH IN
CHILDHOOD SOME OF THE STATE'S
STATUTE THE SENATE MEMBERS WHO
JUST TERRIFYING OR CHEN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU MISTER COOLEY SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
THERE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED DESIRED VOTE.
WORK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES FIFTY
NINE NO ZERO SENTIMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. MOVING TO FILE
ITEM THIRTY SIX AB. FORTY NINE
THE CLERK WILL READ SOME AGO
FORTY NINE BY SOME REMEMBER
CERVANTES AN ACRYLATE TO
ELECTIONS CERVANTES YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS TODAY I'M
PRESENTING ASSEMBLY BILL FORTY
NINE THE CALIFORNIA VOTER
PROTECTION ACT OF TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN FOR CONCURRENT AND
SENATE AMENDMENTS SENATE
AMENDMENTS DELETED A
REQUIREMENT GOTTA VOTE CENTER
MUST BE PRESENT IN EACH
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT IN THE COUNTY
COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
THREE AYE VOTE ON TODAY'S BUILT
ON CONCURRENCE AND SENATE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU. THE
RESTAURANT IS SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS BOTH THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
WHERE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY VOTE AYE AYES SIXTY EIGHT
NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. MOVING TO FILE
ITEM FIFTY THREE. FIFTY THREE
AB FIFTEEN OH FIVE THE CLERK
WILL READ SOME PEOPLE FIFTEEN
OH FIVE BY SOME LIBERAL DONALD
ACTIVATED CHARTER SCHOOLS
MISTER I DON'T KNOW YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER RISERS AND EIGHTY
FIFTEEN OH FIVE COOL FOR
CONCURRENCE THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS REPRESENT AN
AGREEMENT BETWEEN A VARIETY OF
STAKEHOLDERS AND IMPACT THE
FOLLOWING. COMMUNITY IMPACT
THIS BILL GIVES DISTRICTS
GREATER FLEXIBILITY TO CONSIDER
HOW CHARTER SCHOOL WILL IMPACT
THEIR COMMUNITY. BILLS IT
ALLOWS A FULL UPHILL TO THE
COUNTY BOARD OF EDUCATION THAT
WAS THE DUE PROCESS WE SPOKE SO
MUCH ABOUT LAST TIME THIS BILLS
UP. IN THIS BODY CREDENTIALS IT
ENSURES THAT CHARTER TEACHERS
ARE FOR LOOP QUALIFIED FOR
THEIR ASSIGNMENT AND HAVE A
STATE LEVEL BACKGROUND CHECKS.
PARITY IT REQUIRES CHARTER
AUTHORIZES TO USE A STATE
ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM FOR THE
BASIS A CHARTER RENEWAL. AND
ALLOWS A FAST TRACK RENEWAL
PROCESS FOR HIGH PERFORMING
CHARTER SCHOOLS. THANK YOU
MISTER O'DONNELL. CREO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I'M GLAD
THAT THE AUTHOR THE SPONSORS
AND THE OPPOSITION WERE ABLE TO
COME TOGETHER TO WHAT CAN ONLY
BE SEEN AS A HISTORIC AGREEMENT
ON WHAT IS POSSIBLE WHEN PUBLIC
EDUCATION LEADERS PUT THEIR
POLITICAL DIFFERENCES ASIDE AND
PRIORITIZE THE CHILDREN OF OUR
STATE AND THERE FOR THE FUTURE
OF CALIFORNIA. AS NEGOTIATED AB
FIFTEEN OH FIVE AFFIRMS THAT
HIGH QUALITY PUBLIC CHARTER
SCHOOLS IN CALIFORNIA ARE PART
OF OUR STATE EDUCATION SYSTEM
WITH FIFTEEN OH FIVE AND
VARIOUS OTHER PIECES OF
LEGISLATION THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS NOW PASSED AND
WILL PASS SOME OF THE MOST
RIGOROUS CHARTER SCHOOL
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
LEGISLATION ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
AS A PROUD GRADUATE OF LOCAL
PUBLIC SCHOOLS IN THE DISTRICT
THAT I NOW HAVE THE PRIVILEGE
TO REPRESENT I AM HOPEFUL THAT
WE CAN NOW MOVE PAST THE
POLITICS AND REALLY WORK
TOWARDS ADDRESSING WHAT IS
TRULY IMPORTANT AND THAT IS
CLOSING THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP
ESPECIALLY FOR CHILDREN OF
COLOR IT IS MY HOPE THAT MOVING
FORWARD WE CAN ADDRESS THE
SUCCESS OF ALL PUBLIC SCHOOLS
IN CALIFORNIA AND ADDRESS THE
ISSUE OF FULLY FUNDING. PUBLIC
EDUCATION VERSUS CONTINUING TO
FUND A PRISON SYSTEM THAT
DISPROPORTIONATELY INCARCERATE
PEOPLE OF COLOR WHO NEVER HAD A
CHANCE TO BEGIN WITH I WILL BE
VOTING FOR THIS BILL TODAY AND
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR COLLEAGUES ON ISSUES
RELATING TO EDUCATION EQUITY
IMPROVING THE LCF A FORMULA
ADDRESSING THE NEEDS OF OUR
TEACHERS TO BE SUCCESSFUL IN
THE CLASSROOM AND ENSURE THAT
EVERY CHILD ACROSS CALIFORNIA
HAS THE OPPORTUNITY TO THRIVE.
SUCCEED AND REACH THEIR FULL
POTENTIAL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER CAREER MISTER BONTA YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN OH
FIVE AS A PROUD JOINT OFF THERE
I WANT TO THANK. MY FELLOW
AUTHORS FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
BILL FOR TO ALL OF OUR
STAKEHOLDERS HAVE BEEN AT THE
TABLE HAMMERING OUT. OF THE
BEST IDEAS AND HOW WE CAN MOVE
FORWARD WITH APPROPRIATE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND OVERSIGHT OF
OUR- CHARTER SCHOOLS I JUST
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR THAT
WORK. AB FIFTY NO FIVE ONE SURE
THAT CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE
AUTHORIZED IN OVERSEEN BY
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION THAT BEST
UNDERSTAND EDUCATIONAL NEEDS OF
OUR LOCAL STUDENTS. AND WILL
CREATE MORE ACCOUNTABILITY IN A
STRONGER EMPHASIS. ON
EMPOWERING LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND COUNTY BOARDS.
FISCAL IMPACT WHICH IS
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL. FOR ANY
BOARD AT TO BE ABLE TO CONSIDER
IS ALLOWABLE. UNDER THIS BILL.
AND THIS MEASURE WILL HELP US
MAKE NECESSARY IN TIMELY
REFORMS TO CHARTER SCHOOL
AUTHORIZATION APPEALS ARE
MINERALS AS WE MOVE FORWARD
AGAIN THANKS TO ALL. FOR THEIR
INPUT FOR THE DISCUSSION FOR
THE DIAL DIALOGUE AND FOR THIS
FINAL PRODUCT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER BONTA MISS WALDRON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL CHARTER
SCHOOLS ARE NOT THE ENEMY
UNLESS YOU ARE TRYING TO
PROTECT THE STATUS QUO. AND
WHAT IS THE STATUS QUO IN A
WORD AND THE WORD FAILURE
DESPITE LARGE FUNDING INCREASES
OUR SCHOOLS ARE OVERCROWDED
TEACHERS ARE UNDERPAID AND
STUDENTS AREN'T GETTING THE
QUALITY EDUCATION THEY'RE
ENTITLED TO. IN MANY LOW INCOME
AREAS AND RURAL PARTS OF THE
STATE AND COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
THE SITUATION IS EVEN WORSE
CHARTERS OFFER AN ALTERNATIVE
ESPECIALLY IN UNDERSERVED AREAS
MY SON WENT TO A CHARTER SCHOOL
AND WHEN THE PARENTS WHEN HE
WAS ON A LOTTERY FOR THREE
DIFFERENT TIMES BECAUSE THERE
WERE. A THOUSAND FAMILIES IN
LINE TO TRY TO GET INTO THAT
SCHOOL AND THAT MEANS IT'S
OFTEN ALTERNATIVE FOR PEOPLE
ARE DESPERATE TO GET THEIR KIDS
THE QUALITY EDUCATION WHICH IS
A STEP OUT AND CHANCE. AND THEY
ALL OF THESE CHARTER SCHOOLS
OFFER STUDENTS A CHANCE TO
ESCAPE FAILING SCHOOLS AND
LEARN IN AN ENVIRONMENT THAT
SUITS THEIR NEEDS THEY OFFER
ACCOUNTABILITY AND IF THE
SCHOOLS AND PERFORMING PARENTS
CAN MOVE THEIR CHILDREN TO ONE
THAT IS. WITH THIS BILL SPECIAL
INTERESTS ARE TRYING TO TAKE
THAT AWAY I URGE A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS WALDRON MISTER
MURATSUCHI YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN OH FIVE I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
WORKING WITH ALL THOSE WHO
RAISE THE CONCERNS OF. MAKING
SURE THAT HIGH PERFORMING
CHARTER SCHOOLS WERE NOT GOING
TO BE SET DOWN UNDER. A NEW
PROCESS AS A LONG TIME
SUPPORTER OF PUBLIC SCHOOLS I
WELCOME THIS BILL. AND I THINK
THE OFF ROLE AS HARD WORK ON
THIS. THANK YOU MISTER MAYOR SU
CHI'S SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
MISTER O'DONNELL YOU MAY CLOSE.
THAT'S WHEN I VOTE ON
CONCURRENCE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS
THERE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED ESERVER. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE EYES FIFTY SIX NO
SIXTEEN SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. MOVING TO FILE
ITEM ONE SIXTY TWO SB THREE
TWENTY NINE THE CLERK WILL READ
SENATE BILL THREE TWENTY NINE
BY SENATOR MITCHELL WHEN I
RELATING TO DISCRIMINATION. MR
GLORIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT
SENATE BILL THREE TWENTY NINE A
LONG OVERDUE ANTI
DISCRIMINATION MEASURE TO
PROTECT SOME OF CALIFORNIA'S
MOST VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
ACCORDING TO A NATIONAL REPORT
RELEASED BY THE US DEPARTMENT
OF HOUSING AND URBAN
DEVELOPMENT FOR EVERY THIRTY
NINE RENTAL ADVERTISEMENTS THAT
A FAMILY WITH A HOUSING
ASSISTED VOUCHER COULD AFFORD
THERE WAS ONLY ONE AD THEY DID
NOT EXPLICITLY PROHIBIT VOUCHER
HOLDERS FROM EVEN APPLYING FOR
THE UNIT. THAT SAME REPORT
FOUND THAT IN JURISDICTIONS
WHERE SOURCE OF INCOME
PROTECTIONS DID NOT EXIST
DENIAL RATES OF ASSISTED INCOME
FAMILIES WERE AS HIGH AS 75% OR
MORE IN PLACES WHERE THESE
INCOME PROTECTIONS EXISTED BUT
THE NOW RATE DECLINED
DRAMATICALLY THIS BILL IS ABOUT
GIVING THOSE INCOME ASSISTANT
FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA A
FIGHTING SO IT'S IN OUR
DIFFICULT HOUSING ECONOMY. I
HOPE THE EACH OF YOU WOULD
CONSIDER WHAT IT WOULD MEAN IF
YOU SAW TODAY IN CALIFORNIA IN
TWENTY NINETEEN AN
ADVERTISEMENT FOR RENTAL UNIT
THAT SAID NO PEOPLE OF COLOR
MAY APPLY. WHAT WOULD YOU SAY
IF YOU SAW AN AD THAT SAID NO
VETERAN MAY APPLY. BECAUSE IF
ANY OF YOU ANY OF YOU ARE ANY
SIDE OF THE AISLE SAW SUCH AN
AD YOU WOULD CONTEND THAT FOR
THE DISCRIMINATION THAT IT IS
AND IMMEDIATELY DO EVERYTHING
YOU CAN IN THIS BODY TO STOP
IT. WE SHOULD NOT ALLOW THAT
KIND OF DISCRIMINATION IN
CALIFORNIA AND WE SHOULD ALLOW
THIS KIND OF DISCRIMINATION IN
CALIFORNIA AND YET IT HAPPENS
IT HAPPENS REGULARLY WHAT ADDS
ACROSS THE STATE WE ARE BLAZING
WITH THE WORDS NO SECTION
EIGHT. MAY APPLY. MEMBERS MONEY
IS MONEY IT DOESN'T MATTER
WHERE IT COMES FROM YOU CAN
STILL CASH THE CHECK AT THE
FIRST OF THE MONTH. AND IT
SHOULD NOT MATTER IF THE RENT
CONTINUES TO BE SET BY A
PROPERTY OWNER NO ONE IN THIS
BILL IS BEING ASKED TO TAKE A
HAIR CUT OR TO GET A LITTLE BIT
LESS ALL WERE SIMPLY ASKING
THEM TO DO IS TO GIVE EVERY
CALIFONE BORN IN. A FAIR SHOT
AT A ROOF OVER THEIR HEAD AT A
PRICE THAT THEY CAN AFFORD.
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST SOMEONE
ON THE BASIS OF THEIR
PARTICIPATION IN A GOVERNMENT
PROGRAM IS THAT IS MEANT TO
KEEP PEOPLE SHELTERED IS NOT
ONLY UNCONSCIONABLE BUT IT'S
ILLOGICAL IN A STATE WITH THE
AMOUNT OF HOMELESS THAT WE
HAVE. YOU DO NOT GET TO TELL US
THAT WE ARE TOO POOR TO EVEN
APPLY FOR AN APARTMENT THAT WE
CAN'T AFFORD AND THEN TELL THE
AUTHORITIES AROUND US UP ON
PARK BENCHES TURNED INTO BED OR
IN PARKED CARS TURN INTO HOMES.
THAT ARE TOO MUCH OF AN EYESORE
YOU SEE THE LOGIC THAT IS NOT
PRESENT IN THE ARGUMENTS
AGAINST THIS BILL WHICH IS WHY
YOU MUST VOTE FOR IT. CITIES
AND COUNTIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA
HAVE ALREADY ENACTED THESE SAME
KINDS OF PROTECTIONS DO A
ORDINANCES IN THEIR OWN
COMMUNITY CITIES LIKE DARK
REALLY LOS ANGELES SAN
FRANCISCOSANTA MONICA AND YOU
CAN IN MY HOMETOWN OF SAN
DIEGO. SO LET'S GUARANTEED.
THAT'S GUARANTEED TO SAFEGUARD
FROM DISCRIMINATORY PRACTICES.
ALL CALIFORNIANS LET'S VOTE FOR
SENATE BILL THREE TWENTY NINE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER. THANK
YOU MISTER GLORIA MISTER BLOOM
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS I ALSO
RISE AS A PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB THREE
TWENTY NINE. HOUSING VOUCHERS
ARE FOR THOSE ON THE VERGE OF
HOMELESSNESS AND CAN BE THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN HAVING A
ROOF OVER THEIR HEADS. OR BEING
ON THE STREETS. CONTRARY TO
WHAT YOU MIGHT HEAR THE
MAJORITY OF VOUCHER HOLDERS ARE
SENIOR CITIZENS SINGLE PARENT
FAMILIES. AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES. NOT CRIMINALS. MY
CITIES AND MANY OTHER CITIES
USE HOUSING VOUCHERS TO HELP
FIGHT HOMELESSNESS. AND IT IS
IN STE INEXCUSABLE. THAT
LANDLORDS WOULD DISCRIMINATE.
AND WON'T EVEN CONSIDER A
PROSPECTIVE TENANT IF THEY WILL
BE PAYING RENT WITH THE VOUCHER.
IN MY DISTRICT THE PROB PROBLEM
HAS GOTTEN SO BAD THAT MANY
TENANTS WHO HAVE BEEN LUCKY
ENOUGH TO HAVE BEEN AWARDED A
VOUCHER. CAN'T FIND HOUSING
THAT WILL ACCEPT IT. I
LITERALLY HAVE HOMELESS PEOPLE
WITH VOUCHERSTELLING MY
DISTRICT OFFICE THAT THEY ARE
USELESS BECAUSE THE MINUTE THEY
TELL LANDLORD THEIR SECTION
EIGHT. THEIR TURN DOWN THAT'S
JUST WRONG. ACCORDING TO THE
LOS ANGELES TIMES 76% OF
LANDLORDS CONTACTED BY THEN
REFUSED TO ACCEPT VOUCHERS THEY
JUST FLAT OUT REFUSE. IN A
FLUID COMMUNITIES IN THE COUNTY
SUCH AS MY DISTRICT 82% OF THE
LANDLORDS WOULDN'T TAKE
VOUCHERS. DENIAL RATES WERE FAR
LOWER IN CITIES THAT PROHIBITED
A PROHIBITED DISCRIMINATION
AGAINST VOUCHER HOLDERS. THIS
BILL DOES NOT FORCE LANDLORDS
TO RENT TO ANY GIVEN TENANT BUT
SIMPLY REQUIRES THEM TO GIVE
EVERY TENANT THE SAME
OPPORTUNITY TO FILL OUT AN
APPLICATION REGARDLESS OF HOW
THEY'LL BE PAYING THE RENT.
IT'S STILL ALLOWS FOR CREDIT
CHECKS RENTAL HISTORY AND OTHER
REFERENCE CHECKS. MEMBERS LET
ME REMIND YOU EARLY THIS SPRING
CITIES ACROSS THE STATE DID
THEIR HOMELESS COUNTS AND WHAT
EVERY CITY FOUND WAS THAT THE
RISE IN HOMELESSNESS WAS
DIRECTLY ATTRIBUTABLE TO THE
RISE IN RENTS AND THE LACK OF
AFFORDABILITY. AROUND THE
STATE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU
TO VOTE I ON THIS MEASURE WHICH
WILL LET TENANTS KNOW THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IS SERIOUS ABOUT TO
HAVE IT PROTECTIONS. AND
KEEPING PEOPLE IN THEIR HOMES
AS WE WORK TO SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASE HOUSING PRODUCTION
ACROSS THE STATE. THANK YOU
ASKED. THANK YOU MISTER BLOOM
MISTER GALLAGHER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS WHAT'S LOST IN
THE SENSATIONALISM THAT WE'VE
HEARD FROM THE PREVIOUS TWO
SPEAKERS IS IT SECTION EIGHT IS
A VOLUNTARY PROGRAM. NO
LANDLORD HAS TO PARTICIPATE. IN
SECTION EIGHT. ONLY IF THEY
DECIDE THAT THEY WANT. TO
PARTICIPATE IN SECTION EIGHT DO
THEY HAVE TO THAT'S FEDERAL LAW.
AND SO WHAT THIS BILL DOES. IS
IT SAYS IF SOMEONE DECIDES NOT
TO PARTICIPATE IN THAT PROGRAM.
LET'S SAY THEY HAVE ALL RENTERS
BEING EQUAL SEVERAL RENTER
APPLICANTS. SEVERAL OF THEM WHO
ARE NOT SECTION EIGHT AND
SOMEONE WHO IS AND THEY DECIDE
NO I DON'T WANT TO PARTICIPATE
IN SECTION EIGHT I'M GOING TO
RENT. TO THE NON SECTION EIGHT
TENANTS. THEY ARE NOW OPEN UP
TO LAWSUITS AND THAT'S REALLY
WHAT THIS BILL IS ABOUT. IT'S
ANOTHER CONSUMER ATTORNEY
LAWSUIT MIL TO GO AFTER
LANDLORDS TO SAY YOU'RE ONLY
REJECTING THOSE PEOPLE BECAUSE
THEY'RE SECTION EIGHT NOW.
PEOPLE CAN REJECT SECTION EIGHT
BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROGRAM
THAT. IS FEDERAL LAW AND
THEY'RE ALLOWED TO DO SO. WE
DON'T NEED TO HAVE THIS
PROVISION IN THERE WE DON'T
NEED TO HAVE THIS PROVISION IN
LAW. IN ALL THE ONLY THING THE
ONLY THING THAT IS DOING WE HAD
THIS BILL AND JUDICIARY BECAME
VERY CLEAR THE ONLY THING THIS
DO IS SETTING UP. LANDLORDS FOR
FURTHER LAWSUITS AND WHAT WILL
THAT DO. IT WILL CAUSE
LANDLORDS TO RENT TO LESS
PEOPLE IT WILL CAUSE PEOPLE TO
LESS PEOPLE TO GET INVOLVED IN
IN THE RENTAL MARKET. FOR
HOUSING. AND THEREBY AGAIN
DECREASED SUPPLY. AND WHAT IS
DECREASING SUPPLY DO THAT'S
RIGHT IT RAISES RENTS. SO ALL
THIS LIKE FEEL GOOD THINGS THAT
WE'RE DOING WE'RE GONNA HAVE
ANOTHER MEASURE BEFORE US HERE
SOON. IS FEEL GOOD MEASURES
THAT ACTUALLY IT LEAD TO PEOPLE
GETTING HIGHER RENTS. TO
HOUSING BECOMING LESS
AFFORDABLE. AND SO I WOULD
ARGUE THAT. AGAIN WE DON'T NEED
THIS MEASURE INTO LAW IT WILL
IT WILL SUBJECT PEOPLE TO.
FURTHER LAWSUITS. AND AGAIN
SECTION EIGHT IS A VOLUNTARY
PROGRAM NO ONE HAS TO
PARTICIPATE. IN THE SECTION
EIGHT PROGRAM ASK FOR YOUR KNOW
THE- THANK YOU MR GALLAGHER AND
MR STONE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER LET ME
DISPEL THAT MYTH THAT IS NOT
TRUE THAT THIS REQUIRES ANYONE
TO ENTER INTO THE SECTION EIGHT
WE HAD THIS DEBATE PRETTY
VIGOROUSLY IN THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. AND WHEN ASKED ABOUT
THAT FAIRLY DIRECTLY VERY
DIRECTLY BY THE OPPOSITION WHO
KEPT RAISING THAT METHOD THIS
WOULD REQUIRE SECTION A
PARTICIPATION THEY REALLY
COULDN'T EVEN BEGIN TO ANSWER
THAT QUESTION IT DOES NOT
REQUIRE PARTICIPATION IN
SECTION EIGHT WHAT IT DOES SAY.
IS YOU MAY NOT DISCRIMINATE ON
THE SOURCE OF INCOME. BECAUSE
THAT. THE NILE OF SECTION EIGHT
SECTION EIGHT NEED NOT APPLY IS
IT A LOT OF OUR NEIGHBORHOODS
CODE FOR IF YOU'RE BLACK IN
YOUR BROWN DON'T APPLY YOU'RE
NOT GOING TO FIND HOUSING HERE.
THIS IS A DISCRIMINATION ISSUE
DISCRIMINATION ON THE SOURCE OF
INCOME IT SHOULD NOT BE
TOLERATED THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
STONE MISTER MURATSUCHI YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU VERY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I. ONE
RESPOND MIKE MY COLLEAGUES
COMMENT TO. YOU KNOW. WHEN I
FIRST HEARD ABOUT THE BILL AYE.
AYE MY INITIAL REACTION WAS. A
LITTLE RELUCTANT TO. YOU KNOW
IN TERMS OF AN EFFORT TO TELL
LANDLORDS. WHO TO RANT AND WHO
THEY SHOULD BE LEADING TO. BUT
THEN WHEN I. NO. REALIZED THAT
THIS PERHAPS IS NOT THAT MUCH
DIFFERENT FROM. CONVERSATIONS
IN THE PAST WHERE YOU KNOW IF
PEOPLE WOULD SAY IF YOU RENT TO
THOSE PEOPLE THEN YOU'RE GOING
TO LOWER YOUR PROPERTY VALUE OR
IF YOU READ TO THOSE PEOPLE
YOU'RE GOING TO AND FIGHT
CRIME. YOU KNOW I. THIS BILL AS
THE CHAIR OF THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE INDICATED AND I
WANTED TO CONFIRM. YOU KNOW WE
STILL DOESN'T PREVENT PEOPLE
FROM DISCRIMINATE ON THE BASIS
OF A BAD CREDIT HISTORY. IT
DOESN'T PREVENT PEOPLE TO
DISCRIMINATE ON THE ON THE
BASIS OF. A CRIMINAL BACKGROUND
AND WHAT WHAT WHAT THIS DOES
FOR OF A PREVENT AND WHAT IT'S
TRYING TO DO IS TO. IS TO AT
LEAST. YOU KNOW GET THAT FACE
TO FACE MEETING BETWEEN US AS A
SECTION EIGHT VOUCHER HOLDER
AND A AND A LANDLORD YOU KNOW
IF THEY CAN DEMONSTRATE THAT
THEY CAN THEY CAN PAY THEIR
BILLS AND THAT THEY WON'T CAUSE
PROBLEMS AND THEY THE THEY BE A
GOOD TENANT. THEN WE NEED TO WE
NEED TO HELP THESE THESE PEOPLE
OUT I THINK IT IS AN IMPORTANT
MEASURE YOU KNOW I STILL HAVE
SOME RELUCTANCE YOU KNOW I KNOW
THERE A LOT OF LANDLORDS MY
DISTRICT THAT ARE. GONNA BE
UNHAPPY WITH BY VOTERS
SUPPORTED THIS BUT- YOU KNOW
GIVEN THE CIRCUMSTANCES I THINK
THIS IS. AN IMPORTANT BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER MURATSUCHI
MISTER COOLEY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. COLLEAGUES I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND.
ONE OF THE GREAT PRIVILEGES OF
SERVICES THESE DEBATES CAUSE US
TO REFLECT UPON OURSELVES AND
WHO WE ARE AND WHO ARE VALUES
ARE. AND ON THIS PARTICULAR
BILL I FEEL IMPELLED TO RECITE
JOHN DONE. PERMISSION TO READ
WITHOUT OBJECTION. NO MAN IS AN
ISLAND ENTIRE OF ITSELF. EVERY
MAN IS A PIECE THE CONTINENT A
PART OF THE MAIN. IF A CLOUD BE
WASHED AWAY BY THE SEA EUROPE
IS THE LESS AS WELL AS OF A
PROMONTORY WERE. AS WELL AS ANY
MANAGED BY FRIENDS OF THINE OWN
WERE. ANY MAN'S DEATH
DIMINISHES ME BECAUSE I AM
INVOLVED IN MANKIND. AND
THEREFORE NEVER SEND TO KNOW
FOR WHOM THE BELL TOLLS IT
TOLLS FOR THEE. I SEE A BILL
LIKE THIS IS CONFRONTING US
WITH THE FACT THAT WE HAVE.
NEIGHBORS IN OUR COMMUNITY WHO
ARE AT RISK. THEY MAY BE AT
RISK IN WAYS IN WHICH WE ARE
NOT AT RISK. AND IT REALLY CAN
SUFFER THE NEED WHATEVER OUR
CIRCUMSTANCE WITH THE LAWMAKERS
RATHER'S. TO HAVE THE HUMILITY.
TO CONSERVE THE CIRCUMSTANCE OF
THOSE AROUND US. AND I WOULD
JUST POINT OUT THAT IN THIS
SECTION APPLIES OUR RATES ARE
RELATED TO OUR NATION'S CHIEF
EXECUTIVE. WHERE THERE IS NO
HUMILITY. THERE IS NO HUMANITY
I THINK THIS IS A FINAL VOTE I
THANK MY COLLEAGUE IN THE
SENATE FROM LOS ANGELES
ORIGINAL VOTE THANK YOU MISTER
COOLEY DOCTOR WEBER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. YEAH MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE TO IN SUPPORT OF
SB THREE TWO NINE. YOU KNOW WE
ARE GOING TO HAVE BEEN
CONFRONTED OBVIOUSLY ON THIS
FLOOR WITH AN AWFUL LOT OF
ISSUES CONCERNING HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS AND WE CONTINUE TO
KICK THE CAN DOWN THE ROAD
BECAUSE ANYTIME YOU DRESS SUCH
AN ISSUE LIKE THAT. THERE ARE
SO MANY WHO HAVE CONFLICTS
PERSONAL CONFLICTS WHETHER
THEY'RE HOMEOWNERS WITH A THERE
ARE WHERE THEY OWN HOMES THAT
THEY THE LANDLORDS IN THE
RENTERS AND THESE THINGS ARE
CRITICAL ISSUES AND YET WE KEEP
TALKING ABOUT THE HOMELESS
PROBLEM IS IF SOMEONE ELSE IS
GOING TO SOLVE IT FOR US.
SOMEHOW ANOTHER MAGICALLY THIS
IS GOING TO RESOLVE ITSELF AS
WE CONTINUE DOWN THE PATH OF
ALL THE PRACTICES THAT WE'VE
DONE THAT BASICALLY KEEP THIS
SITUATION GROWING AND GROWING
IN EVERY NEIGHBORHOOD. THERE'S
NO NEIGHBORHOOD I KNOW OF IN
SAN DIEGO COUNTY THAT IS NOT
AFFECTED BY HOMELESSNESS THE
MOST RESIDENTIAL AREAS YOU LOOK
AND SOMEONE IS UNDER A BRIDGE
UNDER SOME BUSHES OR TREE OR
SOMEWHERE. AND THIS IS REALLY
OUR PROBLEM AND THE WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO SOLVE IT AND THIS IS
A SMALL STEP IN DOING THAT. IT
REMINDS ME AS I. WHEN I WAS IN
AUSTRALIA BUT A YEAR AND A HALF
AGO. AND WE WERE CONFRONTED WE
WOULD TIME SYDNEY. AND SOMEONE
ASKED THEM ABOUT THEIR HOMELESS
PROBLEM. WE DIDN'T SEE A LOT OF
PEOPLE SLEEPING ON THE STREETS
AND IT WOULDN'T SEE THESE WE
DIDN'T SEE THESE THINGS
OCCURRING AND SO WE SAID WHAT
WHAT DID YOU DO WHAT ROB WHAT
WE LOOK FOR THE MAGIC THAT WE
THOUGHT WE WERE GOING TO FIND
SOME. MAJOR LEGISLATION THAT
WAS GOING TO BE SO UNIQUE. AND
THIS WOMAN SAID TO ME VERY
HONESTLY SHE SAID WE DECIDED.
THAT HOMELESSNESS WAS AN
AFFRONT TO OUR HUMANITY. HE
SAID EVERY TIME WE SAW SOMEONE
WHO DIDN'T HAVE THE BASICS LIKE
A PLACE TO SLEEP AT NIGHT THAT
WAS SECURE SHE SAID I FELT
LESS. THAN A HUMAN BEING. AND I
FEEL THE SAME WAY. AND MOST OF
YOU DO TOO WE DRIVE DOWN THE
STREET WAS SOMETIMES EVEN
AFRAID TO LET PEOPLE AYE AYE.
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT THEY THAT
THEY ARE HURTING AND THE AND
WITH THAT WE PROBABLY CAN DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT. BUT WE'RE
LOOKING FOR COMFORT ZONE THAT
ALLOWS US TO CONTINUE TO EXIST
WITHOUT DOING ANYTHING. THIS IS
NOT A MAJOR MAJOR ISSUE BUT IT
IS AN IMPORTANT ISSUE. THAT
THOSE WHO WANT TO RENT A PLACE.
HAVE AT LEAST THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PROVE TO THE LANDLORD THEN I
AM A PERSON WORTHY. WORTHY
BECAUSE I'M A HUMAN BEING. OF
HAVING A PLACE TO STAY. AND
I'LL BE A GOOD TENANT. AND SO I
OFTEN THINK ABOUT THAT EVERY
TIME SOMETHING COMES UP WHEN I
SEE SOMEONE I JUST FEEL LIKE.
THAT I AM LESS OF A HUMAN
BEING. THE MY HER MANATEES
BEING CHIPPED AWAY. MY HEART
HAS BEEN HARDENED. AND I DON'T
LIKE THAT. AND SO I ASK YOU
TODAY TO SUPPORT THIS BILL SB
THREE TWO NINE SMALL MINOR BILL
IN MANY WAYS BUT YET IS THE
EFFORT TO REALLY RESTORE OUR
HUMANITY. AND TO REALIZE THAT
THIS PROBLEM IS OUR PROBLEM IT
WOULD NOT SOLVE ITSELF. AND
SOME OF US WILL BE
UNCOMFORTABLE IN THE SOLVING OF
IT BUT I THINK IN THE PROCESS
OF THE US DEALING WITH THE
ISSUE OF HOMELESSNESS. WE
RESTORE OUR HUMANITY AS A STATE
AND WE WILL ALL FEEL BETTER AND
SLEEP SOUNDER AT NIGHT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOU I WILL
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER MISS
COME LONGER DRIVE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I. HADN'T PLANNED ON IT
BUT I TO WANT TO RISE AND SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE TWO NINE.
I TO WILL WILL PROBABLY SUFFER
SOME HEARTACHE IN MY DISTRICT
BECAUSE I KNOW THERE ARE NUMBER
OF CONSTITUENTS. WHO ARE NOT IN
FAVOR OF THIS BILL. BUT THIS
BILL REALLY JUST. ASKS
LANDLORDS AND PROPERTY OWNERS
TO INCREASE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
ACCESS IT DOES NOT SAY YOU MUST
RENT TO FOLKS WHO ARE ON
SECTION EIGHT VOUCHERS. BUT IT
DOES SAY YOU MUST GIVE THEM
EQUAL ACCESS TO HAVING THE
OPPORTUNITY TO APPLY IN TO BE
VETTED. IT IS AN ANTI
DISCRIMINATION BILL. AND WE
TALK IN SO MANY DIFFERENT WAYS
ON SO MANY DIFFERENT ISSUES
ABOUT HOW TO PROVIDE EQUITY
INTO THE POLICIES THAT WE ARE
CONSIDERING AND THIS BILL IS
ABOUT GREATER EQUITY. I DON'T
KNOW IF I HAVE SHARED THE STORY
BEFORE BUT I AM THE PRODUCT OF
A BIRACIAL MARRIAGE MY DAD IS
WHITE AND MY MOTHER IS BLACK.
AND IN CHICAGO IN THE VERY
EARLY SEVENTIES THEY WERE
LOOKING TO RENT AN APARTMENT
AND MY MOTHER HADTO WORK SO MY
DAD WENT OUT LOOK FOR AN
APARTMENT. AND HE FOUND A NICE
PLACE YOU APPLY. AND THE
LANDLORD SHOWED HIM AROUND AND
AT THE END HE SAID WHERE'S YOUR
WIFE. AND HE SAID WELL SHE'S
WORKING. AND EARLIER HE HAD
DISCUSSED WANTING TO RENT TO MY
DAD. AND AT THE VERY LAST
MINUTE BECAUSE MY MOTHER WAS
NOT THERE. THE LANDLORD TOOK A
PAUSE. IN SAID. I'M GOING TO
FILE THE APPLICATION AWAY. MY
DAD WENT HOME SHARED THIS WITH
MY MOTHER. THEY CALL TWO
FRIENDS OF THEIRS WHO WERE NOT
MARRIED BUT WERE BOTH WHITE AND
THEY SAID PRETEND TO GO AND
LOOK AT THIS APARTMENT. AND SO
THEY DID. AND THE LANDLORD SET
SO GREAT TO SEE YOU BOTH HERE I
HAVE AN APARTMENT READY FOR YOU.
NO ONE ELSE HAS LOOKED FOR IT
AND WENT TO THEM. AND MY FOLKS
ACTUALLY HAD TO FILE AN APPEAL.
WITH THE HOUSING AUTHORITY IN
CHICAGO. BECAUSE THEY HAD BEEN
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST BECAUSE
MY MOTHER WAS BLACK. JUST FORTY
PLUS YEARS AGO. THIS IS AN
EXTENSION OF THAT EXPERIENCE
NOW MY FOLKS GOT THAT APARTMENT.
BECAUSE. THEY WERE VIABLE
APPLICANTS. IT WASN'T SOME SORT
OF RETRIBUTION FOR RACISM AND
THEY TURNED OUT TO BE PRETTY
GOOD TENANTS. IN FACT THE
LANDLORD TOLD THEM THAT A YEAR
LATER HE SAID I DIDN'T EXPECT
THAT YOU ALL WOULD BE SO GOOD.
BUT IN FACT. YOU TURNED OUT TO
BE OKAY. THIS IS AN EXTENSION
OF THAT EXPERIENCE. AND SO
WHILE IT MAY BE TOUGH FOR SOME
OF YOU I AM URGING AN AYE VOTE
ON SB THREE TWO NINE BECAUSE
JUST BECAUSE YOU NEED A LITTLE
ECONOMIC SUPPORT DOESN'T MEAN
YOU'RE A BAD TENANT DOESN'T
MEAN YOU'RE GOING TO TRASH THE
PLACE DOESN'T MEAN YOU'RE GOING
TO BRING DOWN THE PROPERTY
VALUES. IT JUST MEANS YOU NEED
A LITTLE ASSISTANCE AND I BET
EVERYONE IN THESE CHAMBERS HAS
NEEDED A LITTLE ASSISTANCE I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON SB.
THANK YOU MUST COME LONGER DOES
MISS QUIRK SILVA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS I STAND HERE
ALSO TO URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
THIS IMPORTANT LEGISLATION.
AGAIN WE'VE NOTED ABOUT HOUSING
THROUGHOUT THIS YEAR OF NOT
ONLY THE RISE IN HOMELESSNESS
FROM ORANGE COUNTY TO SAN
FRANCISCO TO SAN DIEGO AND ALL
THE WAY UP NORTH BUT WE KNOW
THAT. NOT ONLY FIXING
HOMELESSNESS IS GOING TO
REQUIRE MULTIPLE SOLUTIONS AND
MANY MANY OPTIONS IN THIS IS
JUST ONE. BUT I WANT TO TELL
YOU THAT WHAT IS BEING
DESCRIBED IN THIS BILL IS
ACTUALLY FAKE NEWS AND THE FAKE
NEWS IS THAT THIS IS GOING TO A
DEMAND OR MANDATE THAT
LANDLORDS TAKE THESE APPLICANTS
WHAT IT ACTUALLY DOES IS IT
GIVES THEM A FAIR SHOT. AND AS
WAS NOTED BEFORE. WE DON'T HAVE
APPLICATIONS THAT SAY I WILL
NOT ACCEPT A CHRISTIAN FAMILY I
WILL NOT ACCEPT A JEWISH FAMILY
I WILL NOT ACCEPT A LATINO
FAMILY AND FOR US TO SAY WE
WILL NOT ACCEPT TO SECTION
EIGHT. AB CAN'T IS
DISCRIMINATION AND ONE OF THE
TOOLS THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS GIVEN US IS
THESE VOUCHERS AND WHEN
SOMEBODY FINALLY GETS A VOUCHER
AND FOR SOME IT'S MANY NOT ONLY
MONTHS BUT COULD BE YEARS. AND
THEN THEY CAN'T USE IT WERE
ACTUALLY SAYING TO THEM THAT
THAT TOOL YOU HAVE OR THAT
VOUCHER. IS NOT GOING TO BE
GRANTED AND WE HAVE NO PLACE
FOR IT HERE AND THAT IS THE
STORY THAT'S REPEATED OVER AND
OVER WHEN THEY CALL OR WHEN
THEYLOOK ON AN ONLINE
APPLICATION IT JUST SAYS DOES
DO NOT ACCEPT SECTION EIGHT.
AND WHAT WE ARE SAYING BY
SUPPORTING THIS BILL IS
EVERYONE HAS VALUE LOOK AT
THEIR APPLICATIONS AND MAKE THE
CHOICE SO I URGE YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS QUIRK SILVA
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER MISTER
COREY YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER I WANT TO THANK
MY CLLEAGUES FOR THEIR
COMMENTS THIS AFTERNOON ABOUT A
BILL THAT I THINK IS TRULY
IMPORTANT ON AND I WANT TO
THANK SENATOR MITCHELL FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO JOCKEY THIS
PARTICULAR BILL. MY FIRST
POSITION IN POLITICS WAS AS A
CITY HOUSING COMMISSIONER AND
SAN DIEGO. AND ANY DO NOT HAVE
THE EXPERIENCE OF OVERSEEING A
SECTION EIGHT PROGRAM YOU MAY
NOT KNOW THAT PEOPLE ARE ON THE
WAITING LIST FOR YEARS AND
YEARS AND YEARS AND SAN DIEGO
IT'S MORE THAN A DECADE.
IMAGINE WHAT IT IS TO BE A
SINGLE MOM TRYING TO MAKE ENDS
MEET FOR ALL THOSE YEARS
WAITING FOR THE CALL FROM THE
HOUSING COMMISSION SAY YOU GOT
A VOUCHER. YOU THINK ABOUT THE
HOMELESS PERSON LIVING IN A
SHELL A SHELTER SOMEWHERE
HOPING TO BE CALLED AND SAID
THAT YOU CAN GET A PERMANENT
HOME. AND YOU CAN THINK IN
EITHER THOSE INSTANCES WHEN
THEY FINALLY GET THAT CALL TO
GO OUT AND NOT FIND A SINGLE
PERSON WHO RENTED AND YOU CAN
IMAGINE WHAT THAT WILL DO. YOU
CAN UNDERSTAND WHY ARE
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS IS GETTING
WORSE WHY MORE FAMILIES ARE
GETTING PUSHED OUT OF THEIR
HOMES YOU UNDERSTAND THE
PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE DESIGNED
TO HELP THE VERY PEOPLE WERE
TALKING ABOUT. SO OFTEN IN THIS
CHAMBER ARE NOT WORKING BECAUSE
OF LANDLORDS ARE NOT WILLING TO
GIVE THEM A FAIR SHOT. AS MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE SAID OVER AND
OVER AGAIN I'M GONNA REPEAT AT
THIS VERY SAME MOMENT THIS DOES
NOT DEMAND A LANDLORD RENT TO
SOMEONE WITH SECTION EIGHT. IT
SIMPLY SAYS THEY CANNOT SAY
THAT THEY MAY NOT APPLY WITH
THEM BECAUSE THEY HAVE SECTION
EIGHT AND ANY OF YOU ARE
UNCOMFORTABLE WITH THIS CONCEPT
OR HAVING DIFFICULTY NAVIGATING
IT BECAUSE QUITE HONESTLY THIS
NOT UNANIMOUS I DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHO'S ON THIS FLOOR.
I'M A TELL YOU THIS WE HAVE
LONG IN THIS STATE HAD RULES
THAT SAY THAT YOU MAY NOT
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST SOMEONE
WITH A DISABILITY WHEN IT COMES
TO HOUSING. BUT EVERY SINGLE
PERSON ON THIS FLOOR UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE'S NO OBLIGATION TO
RENT TO SOMEONE WHO IS DISABLED
YOU SIMPLY MAY NOT DISCRIMINATE
AGAINST THEM. THIS IS THE SAME
FOR STORIES OF INCOME IN THIS
REGARD. MEMBERS I'M ASKING YOU
TO HELP. MANY CRITICIZED THIS
LEGISLATIVE SESSION FOR NOT
DOING ENOUGH ON HOUSING. IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DO SOMETHING.
HOUSING WITH THE- BILLION. TO
THIS DATE TO HELP. COME PEOPLE
GET BY. THE QUESTION FOR A LOT
OF US IS WHETHER OR NOT THERE'S
A FUTURE IN CALIFORNIA. FOR
POOR PEOPLE FOR WORKING PEOPLE
FROM MIDDLE CLASS PEOPLE. LET'S
ANSWER THAT QUESTION TODAY WITH
YOUR AFFIRMATIVE VOTE ON THE SB
THREE TWENTY NINE. LET'S MAKE
IT CLEAR THAT WE WILL NOT
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST PEOPLE
SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY'RE POOR.
THAT MONEY IS MONEY THE CHECK
WILL GET CASH YOU WILL GET
PAID. BUT WHAT YOU'RE GONNA
HAVE TO DO. IS MAKE SURE THAT
YOU LISTEN TO EVERYONE AND YOU
GIVE EVERYONE A FAIR SHOT. THAT
IS WHAT AMERICA IS ABOUT THAT'S
WHAT YOUR VOTE SHOULD BE ABOUT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON SB THREE TWENTY NINE.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTES AYE AYES
FORTY THREE NO SIXTEEN THIS
MEASURE PASSES
. MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO MOVED TO FILE ITEMONE
EIGHTEEN. SO THE ASSISTANT
SPEAKER PRO TEM MAY TAKE HER
ITEM UP. THIS IS FILE ITEM. ONE
NINETEEN SB SIX FORTY FOUR
CALGARY. SENATE BILL SIX FORTY
FOUR BY CENTER GLAZER ANOTHER
SNACK LEYVA TENNESSEE. MISS
PARQUET HAND. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND CHAIRS I RISE TO
PRESENT SB SIX FORTY FOUR ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR GLAZER SB SIX
FORTY FOUR WOULD PROVIDE RENTAL
RELIEF TO ACTIVE DUTY SERVICE
MEMBERS BASED IN CALIFORNIA BY
REDUCING THE AMOUNT OF SECURITY
DEPOSIT SERVICE MEMBERS ARE
REQUIRED TO PAY. TO MOVE INTO A
RENTAL UNIT. SB SIX FORTY FOUR
WOULD ALSO PROHIBIT LANDLORDS
FROM DISCRIMINATING AGAINST
SERVICE MEMBERS FOR HAVING TO
PAY LESS SECURITY DEPOSIT. SB
TWO TWO TWO BY SENATOR HILL IN
FORCES THIS PROVISION BY
PROHIBITING DISCRIMINATION AND
THE RENTAL MARKET BASED VETERAN
MILITARY STATUS. FOR HIS
HOUSING CRISIS MAKES IT
PARTICULARLY DIFFICULT FOR
SERVICE MEMBERS TO A FOR THE UP
FRONT COST OF MOVING INTO A
RENTAL UNIT IN CALIFORNIA WHICH
CAN INCLUDE MULTIPLE MONTHS OF
RENT ON TOP OF THE SECURITY
DEPOSIT. SB SIX FORTY FOUR WILL
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE AND MAKE
SURE THAT ARE ACTIVE DUTY
SERVICE MEMBERS ARE ABLE TO
AFFORD THE RENT. THESE BRAVE
YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN DESERVE OUR
SUPPORT AS THEY MAKE SACRIFICES
TO SERVE OUR COUNTRY. THIS BILL
IS SUPPORTED BY SEVERAL
VETERANS GROUPS INCLUDING THE
AMERICAN GI FORUM AM THAT'S AND
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
VETERAN. SERVICES AGENCIES THIS
BILL HADER SEE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND NOT A SINGLE NO
VOTE. AS WE CONTINUE TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW WE
PROVIDE HOUSING TO PEOPLE IN
OUR STATE WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE INCLUDING OUR
ACTIVE DUTY SERVICE MEMBERS NOT
CONVERSATION. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR PRIVATE. THERE WAS
BACKING HAND SEE NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE CLERK LIBERAL ALL
MEMBERS. THE DESIRE TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
GREAT. CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLL
TIDE OF A- HI SIXTY NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES. THIS IS
FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY BACK IN
FILE ORDER. SB FOUR SIXTEEN
COVERAGE. SENATE BILL FOUR
SIXTEEN BY CENTER HUESO AND
ACKLEY TO WORKERS COMPENSATION
MR GIPSON MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT SB
FOUR SIXTEEN BY SENATOR WESO
WHICH SEEKS TO EXTEND WORKMAN'S
COMP TO ALL CALIFORNIA PEACE
OFFICERS REGARDLESS OF THEIR
EMPLOYING AGENCY WORKMAN'S COMP
IS SOMETHING THAT EVERY WORKERS
SHOULD BE ENTITLED TO EXPRESSLY
OF THOSE WHO INHERENTLY PUT
THEMSELVES IN HARM'S WAY DAY IN
AND DAY OUT CURRENT LAWS CREATE
A PRESUMPTION PRESUMPTION WHERE
SPECIFIC INJURIES OR ILLNESS.
WORK RELATED PRESUMPTIONS
PLEASE FOR PEACE OFFICERS ARE
NOT PROHIBITED BECAUSE OF THE
AGENCY IN WHICH THEY WORK FOR
MEMBERS EVERY PIECE OFFICER
WHEN HE SAID HAVE WORKMAN'S
COMP I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
STRONG AYE VOTE ON SB. SIXTEEN.
THANK YOU MISS GIPSON SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLICK LIBERAL.
SORRY ABOUT ALL MEMBERS OF
DESIRE TO THE- ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE THOUGH. CLICK WELL
CLOSER ALL TIE VOTE EYES FIFTY
THREE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTY ONE. SB FOUR TWENTY
FIVE CLICK READ SENATE BILL
FOUR TWENTY FIVE BY SENATOR
HILL AN ACCOLADE HEALING ARTS.
MR GALLAGHER. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT SB FOUR TWENTY FIVE
WHICH REQUIRES HOSPITALS
CLINICS AND OTHER HEALTH
FACILITIES TO REPORT
ALLEGATIONS OF PATIENTS SEXUAL
ABUSE AND OTHER SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT BY MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS TO THE
APPROPRIATE STATE LICENSING
AUTHORITIES WITHIN FIFTEEN
DAYS. AS WE'VE SEEN HAS BECOME
ALL TOO CLEAR. MANY OF. THE
SEXUAL ABUSE AND SEXUAL
HARASSMENT THAT HAS COOLEY COME
TO LIGHT IN THE LAST FEW YEARS
WAS COVERED UP. THESE ISSUES
WERE NOT WRITTEN PROPERLY
REPORTED THEY WERE COVERED UP
BY THE BY THE VERY INSTITUTIONS
THAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN. HELPING
PROTECT PEOPLE. SB FOUR TWENTY
FIVE CLOSES LEGAL LOOPHOLES
THAT CAN ALLOW THE SUBJECT OF
REPEATED SEXUAL ABUSE AND
MISCONDUCT COMPLAINTS. AT TO
WORK AT A HEALTH CARE FACILITY
FOR YEARS BECAUSE THE RELEVANT
REGULATORY BOARD IS NOT
NOTIFIED BY THE FACILITY OF THE
ALLEGATIONS AGAINST A LICENSEE.
ALLEGATIONS OF SEXUAL ABUSE OR
MISCONDUCT BY DOCTORS AND OTHER
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS MUST BE
REPORTED SWIFTLY TO THE
APPROPRIATE LICENSING BOARD FOR
REVIEW SO THAT REGULATORS. CAN
DETERMINE WHETHER TO CONDUCT AN
INDEPENDENT CONFIDENTIAL
INVESTIGATION. BECAUSE AN
ALLEGATION IS REPORTED IN NO
WAY MEANS THAT THE MEDICAL
BOARD WATER MEDICALLY BEGIN AN
INVESTIGATION ALL ALL
COMPLAINTS SENT TO THE MEDICAL
BOARD ARE CONFIDENTIAL AND
FIRST REVIEWED BY A DOCTOR. ON
STAFF TO DETERMINE IF FURTHER
EDGE ACTION IS WARRANTED. THIS
IS A MUCH NEEDED STEP. AS
YOU'RE ALL FAMILIAR WITH THE U.
S. C. AND DOCTOR TYNDALL
SCANDAL. WHERE THERE WERE
MULTIPLE COMPLAINTS OF SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT FOR DECADES. NONE OF
THE PRIOR COMPLAINTS WERE EVER
REPORTED. TO THE MEDICAL BOARD.
THIS IS WHY THE MANDATORY
REPORTING WITHIN FIFTEEN DAYS
TO THE MEDICAL BOARD IS SO
ESSENTIAL. WE CAN NO LONGER
JUST SAY LEAVE THESE TO HEALTH
CLINICS AND HOSPITALS A DO IT
ON THEIR OWN. AND WE KNOW WE
NEED TO DO MORE. WE'RE CLOSING
ONE LOOPHOLE HERE TODAY BUT ONE
THAT REMAINS TO BE DONE IN
FUTURE WORK. IS THE GOVERNMENT
NEEDS TO BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE TO
THIS WE KNOW THAT. FOR EXIT FOR
EXAMPLE IN THE U. S. GYMNASTICS
SCANDAL IT WAS MICHIGAN STATE
UNIVERSITY A GOVERNMENT.
SPONSORED UNIVERSITY THAT
CONTINUE TO COVER UP YEARS OF
SEXUAL ABUSE AND MISCONDUCT.
NONE OF OUR BILLS SO FAR HAVE
APPLIED THESE RULES. TO STATE
GOVERNMENT AND THAT'S THE NEXT
STEP THAT SHOULD BE A BIG
PRIORITY FOR OUR NEXT SESSION
MEMBERS. SO IF TODAY I ASK THAT
YOU HELP CLOSE THIS LOOPHOLE
WHICH IS SO ESSENTIAL. BIAS BY
PASSING SB FOUR TWENTY FIVE
THANK YOU. SAYING NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ADAM CAR CLUB IN
MORE. NUMBER SEVEN ZERO ALL
MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE.
YEAH CLARK WELL CLOSER ROLL
TIDE ABOUT EYES FIFTY NINE
KNOWS ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY
TWO. SB FOUR FOUR FIVE SEPARATE
SENATE BILL FOR FORTY FIVE BY
CENTER PORTANTINO WOULD
ACTUALLY TO HEALTHCARE MS
GONZALEZ THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. I RISE TO PRESENT SB
FOUR FOUR FIVE WHICH WILL
AUTHORIZE THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES TO CONVENE
AN EXPERT PANEL TO ADVISE. ON
THE DEVELOPMENT OF YOUTH
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
TREATMENT STANDARDS MULTIPLE
STUDIES HAVE ESTABLISHED THAT
ADOLESCENTS ARE MORE VULNERABLE
THAN ADULTS TO ALCOHOL ALCOHOL
CANNABIS TOBACCO AND OTHER
DRUGS SERVICES FOR YOUTH NEED
TO BE INTEGRATED AND WRAPAROUND
SERVICES ARE NECESSARY TO SERVE
YOUTH THAT ARE MOST IN NEED
WHEREVER THEY ARE IN THE
COMMUNITY WHETHER IT'S ON THE
STREETS HOMELESS SHELTERS AND
FOSTER CARE OR IN SCHOOLS. THIS
BILL SEEKS DEVELOPING YOUTH
TREATMENT STANDARDS FOR
CHILDREN ADOLESCENTS AND YOUNG
ADULTS BY ADDRESSING THAT THEIR
NEEDS ARE DIFFERENT FROM ADULT
TREATMENT AND DEVELOPING A NEW
METHODOLOGY FOR CARING FOR
YOUNGER POPULATION.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THING WAS CONSEILS SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE OR CLUB IN
THE WRONG. IS OUT OF THAT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A- ALL
MEMBERS OF OUR DESIRE TO VOTE.
WELL CLOSER ALL HELLO BUT I
SIXTY NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES. THIS IS ABOUT A ONE
SEVENTY THREE. SB FOR FIFTY
FIVE QUICK READ. SENATE BILL
FOR FIFTY FIVE BY CENTER
BRADFORD OTHERS BACK LATE FOR
THE FINANCIAL EMPOWERMENT FUNNY
MAKING A PROBATIONER FOR THIS
MONTH. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS SP FOUR FIFTY FIVE
DIRECT THE DEPARTMENT OF
BUSINESS OVERSIGHT TO
ADMINISTER A GRANT PROGRAM FOR
THE BENEFIT OF NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT PROVIDE
FINANCIAL EDUCATION AND
FINANCIAL EMPOWERMENT PROGRAMS
AND SERVICES TO AN AND UNDER
BANK CALIFORNIANS THIS BILL IS
INTENDED TO HELP BRIDGE THE
INFORMATION GAP THAT MANY
UNDERSERVED CALIFORNIANS FACE
SB FOUR FIFTY FIVE FUNDS THE
GRANT PROGRAM WITH UP TO ONE
MILLION ANNUALLY FOR FOUR
YEARS. THE MONEY TO FIND IN THE
GRANT PROGRAM WILL COME FROM A
SPECIAL FUND ADMINISTERED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF BUSINESS
OVERSIGHT SB FOR FIFTY FIVE A
SPONSORED BY THE MISSION ASSET
FUND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. FAMOUS AMONG SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLICK LIBERAL.
RESERVE A ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF THE- THIS TAKES FIFTY
FOUR. ALL MY RESERVES ARE TO
VOTE. CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLE
TALBOT EYES FIFTY SEVEN KNOWS
ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY
ON FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY FOUR.
PAST RETAIN ON FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTY FIVE. THAT BRINGS US TO
FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY SIX SB
FIVE THIRTY TO COOPERATE SENATE
BILL FIVE THIRTY TWO BY CENTER
PORTANTINO WHEN ACT RELATING TO
REDEVELOPMENT. MR STONE THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
WE KNOW THAT WITH THE
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES HAVING
WOUND UP ACROSS THE STATE THERE
ARE A NUMBER WHO ARE STILL
HOLDING BOND PROCEEDS THOSE
BOND PROCEEDS COULD BE PUT TO
WORK AND COULD BE TO PUT TO
WORK IMMEDIATELY IF WE- APPROVE
THIS BILL THIS IS CENTER
PORTANTINO'S. BILL THAT WILL
ALL AUTHORIZES CITY OF GLENDALE
TO SPEND UP THE TWENTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLAR BONDS THAT ARE
SITTING THERE INSTEAD OF.
HAVING TO TURN THEM BACK IN AND
BE ABLE TO PUT THEM TO WORK AND
BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
THEIR CITY. AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE THAT. THANK YOU
MISTER STONE SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE QUIRK LIBERAL.
SARAH VOTE ALL MEMBERS OF. WE
DESERVE A. ALL MEMBERS VOTE. IT
IS OUT OF THE CLERK WELL. CLOSE
ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FIFTY FIVE
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY SEVEN. IS
SB FIVE THIRTY EIGHT CORKERY
SENATE BILL FIVE THIRTY EIGHT
BY CENTER RUBIO ANOTHER SNACK
LEAD TO ELECTRONIC CIGARETTES
IN THE CLEARLY YOU SEE THERE OF
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. MR
GARCIA THANK THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES TODAY
PRESENT SB FIVE THIRTY EIGHT A
BILL THAT WILL HELP PARENTS AND
EDUCATORS IDENTIFY ELECTRONIC
CIGARETTES TO REDUCE THEIR USE
BY STUDENTS. THIS BILL WILL
REQUIRE ELECTRONIC CIGARETTE
MANUFACTURERS TO SO MANY
PHYSICAL DESCRIPTION ANY
PHOTOGRAPH OF EACH TYPE OF
DEVICE THEY SELL HERE IN
CALIFORNIA TO THIS DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH. AND HAVE THE
DEPARTMENT POST THIS
INFORMATION ONLINE SB FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT IS SUPPORTED BY
HEALTHCARE SCHOOL AND PARENT
ORGANIZATIONS AND HAS PASSED
OUT OF THE ASSEMBLY G.
ORGANIZATION HOUSE AND
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEES WOULD
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR OF THE
BILL. MISS RUBIO CENTER RUBIO
AND RESPECT LAST FREE I WILL.
THANK MISTER MISTER GARCIA. SEE
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE CARPAL OF
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBER SERVICE
OUT OF THAT ALL MEMBERS VOTE
DESIRE TO VOTE. THIS TAKES
FIFTY FOR ALL MEMBERS OF. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I FIFTY SIX
NO ZERO ON THE URGENCY EYES
FIFTY SIX NOW ZERO ON THE
MEASURE. THAT BILL PASSES. THIS
IS FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY EIGHT
SB FIVE FORTY TWO CORKERY.
SENATE BILL FIVE FORTY TWO BY
SENATOR STERN AND OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE WORKERS COMPENSATION
MR WENT. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
SB FIVE FOUR TWO FIRE FIGHTING
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT OR TO THE
MOST STRESSFUL OCCUPATIONS
IMAGINABLE THE WALLS THE FIRE
AND BORDERLINE SHOOTING. PUT
THIS FRONT AND CENTER THIS PAST
YEAR IN MY DISTRICT
OCCUPATIONAL DUTIES CAN AND DO
HAVE A DRAMATIC IMPACT ON MANY
FIREFIGHTERS AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS PUTTING
THEIR MENTAL HEALTH AT RISK. SB
FIVE FOUR TWO IS A BIPARTISAN
EFFORT TO ADDRESS THIS CRISIS
THE BILL WILL CREATE A
REBUTTABLE. WORK FOR WORKMAN'S
COMPENSATION PRESUMPTION FOR
OCCUPATIONAL P. T. S. I. WHICH
WILL FACILITATE TIMELY ACCESS
TO NEEDED TREATMENT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I HAVE
A. THINGS ARE ON SCENE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE QUIRK LIBERAL.
ALL MEMBERS OF. DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE OF A.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL. ZERO TELL YOU WHAT
I FIFTY NINE NO ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTY NINE IS SB FIVE FIVE
EIGHT QUICK READ SENATE BILL
FIVE FIFTY EIGHT BY CENTER
HUESO AND OTHERS NOT RELATE TO
CALIFORNIA MEXICO FAIRS MR
GARCIA. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I PRESENT ANOTHER BILL
FROM THE SINGING SENATOR FROM
SAN DIEGO THIS BILL ESTABLISHES
AN ELEVEN MEMBER COMMISSION ON
CALIFORNIA MEXICO AFFAIRS TO
SERVE AS A PUBLIC STAKEHOLDER
BODY ON CULTURAL ECONOMIC AND
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES RELATING
TO CALIFORNIA MEXICO
RELATIONSHIP NOW. JUST A LITTLE
BIT OF SOME STATISTICS HERE TO
GIVE YOU A SENSE OF HOW
IMPORTANT THIS RELATIONSHIP IS
CALIFORNIAN MEXICO BORDER
REGION IS HOME TO SIX POINT
FOUR MILLION PEOPLE AND
GENERATES CLOSE TO TWENTY FOUR
POINT THREE BILLION IN ECONOMIC
ACTIVITY. EVERY MONTH FIVE
POINT NINE MILLION PEOPLE CROSS
THE BORDER TO SPEND MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN OUR STORES AND TO
VISIT MANY OF CALIFORNIA'S
LANDMARKS WHETHER IT BE IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA THE GOLDEN
GATE BRIDGE OR DODGER STADIUM
IN LOS ANGELES. YES MEXICANS
ARE USUALLY DODGER FANS THANK
YOU TO FERNANDO VALENZUELA THAT
THAT'S THAT'S A PROVEN FACT IN
FACT IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
THE LOS ANGELES TOURISM AND
CONVENTION BOARD ONCE AGAIN
IDENTIFIED MEXICO AS A TOP OR
REGION NATION SOURCE OF
INTERNATIONAL TOURISTS. RIGHT
THAT'S THAT LOS ANGELES TOURISM
AND CONVENTION BOARD. OUR STATE
TECH SPORTS LET'S GET BACK TO
THE IMPORTANT BUSINESS. OUR
STATE EXPORTS TO MEXICO TOTALED
THIRTY POINT SEVEN BILLION IN
TODAY MEXICO IN CALIFORNIA'S
RELATIONSHIP HAS ESTABLISHED.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS THAT
THERE ARE TREMENDOUS AMONG THE
CHALLENGES THAT COME WITH THIS
RELATIONSHIP PARTICULARLY ON
THE BORDER AS IT RELATES TO AIR
QUALITY WATER QUALITY.
TRANSPORTATION ACCESS TO HEALTH
CARE AND SO FOR THOSE REASONS
THE RELATIONSHIP AND THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF THIS
COMMISSION IS OF EXTREME VALUE
THAT'S WHY THIS BILL IS BEFORE
YOU AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YA
VOTE. THANK YOU MR GARCIA. MS
GONZALEZ YOUR RECOGNIZED I JUST
HAVE A QUESTION THE AUTHOR I
GUESS THE PRESENTER DID YOU SAY
MAX WITHOUT OBJECTION. PADRE
FANS. BECAUSE I'M PRETTY SURE
THAT'S WHAT YOU MEANT TO SAY
FROM THE SENATOR FROM SAN DIEGO.
MR GARCIA YOU MAY CAN ADDRESS
SAID IN MY CLOTHES. THANK YOU
MR GARCIA. SEEM NO ADDITIONAL
DISCLOSURES OF EIGHT YOU MAY
NOW ADDRESS THAT MISTER. JUST
MY COMMENTS ARE REFERENCE FROM
THE TALKING POINTS I RECEIVED
FROM THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL BUT.
IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN WHEN
THE LOS ANGELES TOURISM AND
CONVENTION BOARD IDENTIFIED HOW
MANY MEXICANS TRAVEL TO THAT
CITY. CHAVEZ RAVINE DODGER
STADIUM WAS ONE OF THE
LOCATIONS. AND SO I THINK IT'S
FAIR TO CONCLUDE. THAT A
MAJORITY OF MEXICANS TRAVELING
TO CALIFORNIA'S LANDMARK
DESTINATIONS. OUR DODGERS FANS
ARE RESPECT LESS RIVAL. THAT
WILL BE STRICKEN FROM THE
RECORD. SEE NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROOM. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
DESIRED ABOUT. ALL MEMBERS OF
THE DESIRED ABOUT. ALL MEMBERS
ARE DESIRABLE. CLARK WELL
CLOSER ROLE. TELL YOU WHAT I
FIFTY NINE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES. THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE
EIGHTY. SB FIVE SEVENTY SIX
QUICK READ. SENATE BILL FIVE
SEVENTY SIX BY CENTER OF BERGEN
ACCOLADE ACOSTA RESOURCES. THIS
PETRIE-NORRIS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER NUMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT SB FIVE SEVENTY SIX
WHICH WILL REQUIRE THE OCEAN
PROTECTION COUNCIL TO DEVELOP
AND IMPLEMENT A COASTAL CLIMATE
CHANGE ADAPTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE AND READING THIS
PROGRAM THE PROGRAM WILL
RECOMMEND BEST PRACTICES AND
STRATEGIES TO IMPROVE THE
RESILIENCY EVER COASTAL
COMMUNITIES ADDITIONALLY THIS
BILL WOULD REQUIRE THE COUNCIL
TO PARTICIPATE WITH
UNIVERSITIES SCIENTISTS AND
OTHER NGOS TO FACILITATE
INFORMATION SHARING FOR BEST
STRATEGIES TO ADDRESS
CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE CRISIS.
IMPLEMENTING BEST PRACTICES TO
PREPARE OUR COASTAL COMMUNITIES
FOR RISING SEA LEVELS IS
CRUCIAL TO SAFEGUARD THE LIVES
OF THE NEARLY 70% OF THE
STATE'S POPULATION AND THE
OVERALL HEALTH OF OUR ECONOMY
WE MUST ACT NOW TO ADDRESS THE
CLIMATE CRISIS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS THE CLUB
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
THAT. THERE WAS PETRIE-NORRIS
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
SO DESIRABLE. CLARK WELL CLOSER
ALL TELL ABOUT EYES FORTY NINE.
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
THERE'S MORE TO PASS RETAIN. A
FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY ONE THIS
IS FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY TWO. SB
SIX AWAIT CORPORATION SENATE
BILL SIX AWAIT BY CENTER GLAZER
ANOTHER'S AN ACCOLADE TO
PROFESSIONS VOCATIONS HELLO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS THIS IS A NUMBER OF
BILLS WITH RESPECT TO SUNSET
EXTENSIONS AND THIS ONE IS WITH
RESPECT TO THE ARCHITECTS BOARD
IN LANDSCAPE ARCHITECTS
TECHNICAL COMMITTEE
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE. THERE
WAS LOS SENIOR DISCUSSION
DEBATE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
WRONG. CEREMONY ALL MEMBERS OF.
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS ARE
RESERVE CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLE
HELLO. I SIXTY ONE. KNOWS ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES. THIS IS
FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY THREE SB
SIX OH NINE. SENATE BILL SIX OH
NINE BY CENTER GLAZER AND
ACCORDING TO PROFESSIONS OF
LOCATIONS MR LOW YOU MAY GET
OPEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS THIS IS THE
CENTS A BILL FOR THE BUREAU OF
SECURITY AND INVESTIGATIVE
SERVICES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE. THANKS LOW SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE CORD BLOOD IN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS OTHERS
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE THOUGH. CLARK WELL
CLOSER ROLE TELEVOTE EYES FIFTY
THREE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES. YES ME FILE ITEM ONE
EIGHTY FOUR SB SIX TEN CLICK
READ. SENATE BILL SIX TEN BY
CENTER GLAZER AN ACCOLADE TO
CONTRACTORS SURE LOW YOU MAY
GET OPEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR SPEAKER THIS IS THE SUNSET
BILL FOR THE CONTRACTOR STATE
LICENSING BORDERS BY FAST FOR A
VOTE. THEY MISS LOW SENIOR
DISCUSSION OF A CLERK WILL OPEN
THE. ALL MEMBERS OF. DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS A DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLE
TELL YOU BUT I SIXTY ONE NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES THIS
IS FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY FIVE SB
SIX TWENTY QUICKLY SENATE BILL
SIX TWENTY BY CENTER PORTANTINO
WHEN I RELATED TO CRIMINAL
OFFENDER RECORD INFORMATION
MISTER GIBSON. MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT SB
SIX TWENTY ON BY SENATOR
PORTANTINO WHICH AUTHORIZED
SPECIFIED LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES TO PROVIDE LIMITED
INFORMATION ABOUT PERSONS ON
SUPERVISION SUPERVISED RELEASE
WITHIN THEIR JURISDICTION THIS
WILL ALLOW THOSE LEAVING
PRISON. TO HAVE A GREATER
ACCESS TO CASE MANAGEMENT
FINANCIAL LITERACY MENTAL
HEALTH SUBSTANCE ABUSE
TREATMENT PROGRAMS AND
WORKFORCE AND BET WORKFORCE.
DEVELOPMENT SERVICES LOS
ANGELES COUNTY. 87% OF
COMMUNITY MEMBERS WHO RETURN
FROM INCARCERATION RE RE OFFEND
AT OUR RE INCARCERATED WITHIN
THREE YEARS LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICIALS HAVE RELEASED DATA.
THAT OF PERSONAL INFORMATION
FOR EVERY ROUTE PAROLE LEE AND
POST RELEASE COMMUNITIES
SUPERVISED PROBATION HOWEVER
THEY DO NOT CONNECT THESE
PREVIOUS IMMEDIATELY
INCARCERATED I'M COMMUNITY
MEMBERS TO SERVICES PROVIDERS
OR RELEASE THIS INFORMATION AS
A RESULT IT IS HARD TO BREAK
THE CYCLE OF RECIDIVISM BY
HAVING CONTACT INFORMATION OF
THESE RETURNING TO SOCIETY
SERVICES PROVIDING CAN POCUS.
THEIR EFFORTS AND GRANT FUNDING
ON PREVIOUS INCARCERATED
COMMUNITY MEMBERS OF THAT WOULD
HELP THEM SUCCEED I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHAT I VOTE ON
SB SIX TWENTY. THANKS GIPSON
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE CARPAL
OF THE ROLE. IS THERE THEN ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A- ALL
MEMBERS OF THE- IT IS OUT OF
OUT. WELL. CLOSER ROLE. SORRY
IN SIR. TACKLE CLOSER ROLE
TALLY OF A AYE SIXTY ONE NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO PASS
TEMPORARILY. PASS TEMPORARILY
ON FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY SIX.
PASS AND RETAIN A FILE ITEM
NINETY SEVEN. YEAH WE WILL TAKE
UP FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY EIGHT.
THIS IS SB SIX NINETY EIGHT
CORPORATION SENATE BILL SIX
NINETY EIGHT BY CENTER LEYVA
ANOTHER'S AN ACCOLADE TO
EMPLOYMENT. MISS WICKS THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
STARTING IN SEPTEMBER TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THOUSANDS OF LOW WAGE
WORKERS AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA WENT WEEKS AND EVEN
MONTHS WITHOUT RECEIVING THEIR
PAYCHECKS. THIS DELAYED WAGES
WAS THE RESULT A VERY POOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE UC PATH
PAYROLL SYSTEM. CLEARLY THE
CONSEQUENCES OF MISSED LATE OR
INCORRECT PAYCHECKS HAVE BEEN
DEVASTATING FOR WORKERS AT THE
UC UNFORTUNATELY THIS PROBLEM
CONTINUES TODAY. RIGHT NOW
STUDENTS AND CLERICAL WORKERS
ACROSS THE UC SYSTEM ARE
WAITING TO RECEIVE MISSING
PAYCHECKS AND SEVERAL WORKERS
IN MY DISTRICT RECENTLY WERE
THREATENED WITH EVICTION
NOTICES BECAUSE THEY COULD NOT
PAY THEIR RENT. SB SIX NINE
EIGHT SIMPLY DRESSES UNTIMELY
WAGES AT UC BY AMENDING SECTION
TWO OH FOUR OF THE LABOR CODE
TO REQUIRE THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA TO FOLLOW THE SAME
RULES AS PRIVATE EMPLOYERS AND
ENCOURAGES UNIVERSITY
ADMINISTRATORS TO PRIORITIZE
THE ACCURATE TIMELY AND FAIR
PAYMENT OF THEIR EMPLOYEES.
THIS MEASURE HAS EARNED STRONG
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT EVERY STEP
OF THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS WICKS SEEN
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE CLUB
LIBERAL. ALL MEMBERS OF.
DESERVE A ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS ARE TO VOTE. CLARK WELL
CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF WHAT I SIXTY
FOUR KNOWS ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES. PASS AND RETAIN ON FILE
ITEMS. ONE EIGHTY NINE THREE
ONE NINETY TWO. WE WILL TAKE UP
FILE ITEM ONE NINETY THREE SB
THIRTY FOUR. OPERATE. SENATE
BILL THIRTY FOUR BY CENTER
WIENER ANOTHER'S AN ACCOLADE
CAMPUS DOCTOR WOULD. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER COLLEAGUES I
RISE TODAY IS A PRIVATE CO
AUTHOR SENATE BILL THIRTY FOUR
BY SENATOR WIENER SENATE SB
THIRTY FOUR PERMITS DONATION
BASE COMPASSIONATE CARE
PROGRAMS TO CONTRACT WITH
LICENSE RETAILERS TO FACILITATE
THE DONATIONS OF MEDS MEDICINAL
CANNABIS TO VALID MEDICINAL
PATIENTS SO WE CAN HELP GET LOW
AND TO INCOME PEOPLE AND
VETERANS OFF THE ILLICIT
MARKET. THIS BILL ALSO BECAUSE
OF CODIFIES EXISTING REAL
REGULATIONS THAT PERMIT
DONATIONS BY RETAILERS TO
MEDICINAL PATIENTS EXEMPT THESE
ADDITIONAL EXEMPTS HE'S
MEDICINAL CUT DONATIONS FROM
THE USE AND CULTIVATION TAXES.
A LOT OF WORDS THERE HE'S YEAH
I KNOW YOU'RE LISTENING OF LAST
YEAR THE LEGISLATURE PASSED A
SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR BILL SB
EIGHT TWENTY NINE WITH
OVERWHELMING BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
THIS SESSION SB THIRTY FOUR IS
ADOPTED AMENDMENTS PROPOSED BY
AGENCIES A SAFEGUARD AGAINST
ILLEGAL DIVERSION AND DELAY THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE ACT.
ENACTMENT OF PROP SIXTY FOUR IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN CREATED NEW
TAXES FOR ALL CANNABIS PRODUCTS
AND DONATED MEDICAL. CANNABIS
BECAME THE SUBJECT TO THESE
COMMERCIAL TAXES. NOW THESE
COMPASSIONATE USE PROGRAMS HAVE
BEEN FORCED TO CLOSE THE FACE
OF THESE TAXES A NEW LICENSING
FEES AND SUBSEQUENTLY THE
VETERANS LOW INCOME PATIENTS
THAT HAVE LONG SIR. ARE CHOOSE
TO THE HEAD THEY THAT THEY LONG
CERTIFIED OR CHOOSING BETWEEN
THE LISTEN MARKET ARE GOING
WITHOUT THE MEDICINE THEY NEED.
SB THIRTY FOUR FOR CARE FOR
THIS CALIFORNIA GOAL OF
MINIMIZING THE SIZE OF THE
ILLICIT MARKET PUTS PATIENT
ACCESS BEFORE PROFITS THE BILL
HAS BEEN AS ENJOYED STRONG
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. THROUGHOUT
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD. WHICH
MATHIS YOUR RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AS A
CO AUTHOR ON THIS BILL AND A
VETERAN I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
THIS BILL IS A GREAT BILL THAT
HELPS OUR VETERANS GET AWAY
FROM THE OPIOID EPIDEMIC ALLOWS
THE NONPROFITS THAT ARE OUT
THERE TO BE ABLE TO GET THIS
MEDICINE FOR OUR VETERANS THAT
ARE IN NEED. AND FOR THAT
REASON I ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
MATHIS SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO
VOTE. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE TELL YOU ABOUT AYE AYES
FIFTY SIX NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTION THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY ROLES SIXTY
THREE AND SEVENTY SEVEN TO
ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK
SILVA TO TAKE UP AB THREE SIXTY
EIGHT TODAY WITHOUT REFERENCE
THE FILE. FOR CONCURRENCE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION. MEMBERS THIS
IS. WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE
AB THREE SIXTY EIGHT. BY MISS
QUIRK SILVA. THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL THREE SIXTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK
SILVA ANOTHER'S AN ACCOLADE TO
VETERANS CEMETERIES. MS QUIRK
SILVA YOU MAY OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS A VERY
PROUD TODAY TO STAND AND
PRESENT AB THREE SIXTY EIGHT
THE STATE LEGISLATURE HAS
SUPPORTER AND A SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA VETERANS MEMORIAL
PARK IN CEMETERY PREVIOUS
LEGISLATION SELECTED ONE
LOCATION IN IRVINE AND
ALLOCATED FOUR POINT FIVE
MILLION TO A MASTER VAIL MASTER
DEVELOPMENT FUND THIS MEASURE
RECEIVE UNANIMOUS AND
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. SENATE
AMENDMENTS AUTHORIZE KILL THAT
TO TOOK TO CONDUCT STUDIES ON
TWO POSSIBLE SITES IN IRVINE
THE MEASURE ALSO AUTHORIZES CAL
THAT TO TAKE ACTION TO CHOOSE
THE APPROPRIATE SITE ON THREE
DIFFERENT CRITERIA ECONOMIC
FEASIBILITY BENEFITS TO
VETERANS AND CITY OF IRVINE
RESIDENTS AND AVAILABILITY OF
EACH LOCATION. NOW MEMBERS WE
HAVE TWENTY FOUR POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS THAT HAS BEEN
SET ASIDE TO BUILD THE CEMETERY
AND ANOTHER TWENTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS HAS BEEN
PLEDGED LOCALLY IRVINE HAS
STEPPED UP AND OFFERED THE LAND
TO BUILD THE CEMETERY FOR OUR
VETERANS THE LAND IS THERE THE
FUNDS ARE THERE THE VETERANS
GROUPS ARE RALLYING BEHIND THE
SEVEN TERRY AND I ASK YOU TO
HELP US BUILD THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA VETERANS. CEMETERY
AND I ASK FOR YOUR CONCURRENCE.
THANK YOU MISS FOR SELMA MISTER
BRO YOUR RECORD THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IS PROUD
CO AUTHOR OF AB THREE SIXTY
EIGHT THERE WAS A DEAL LAST
YEAR THAT WAS ON WOUND BY A
RED. REFERENDUM BACK IN IRVINE
BUT  JUST WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM FULLERTON FOR
STAYING ON THIS BY THE VETERANS
OF ORANGE COUNTY WE'VE GOT A
LARGE POPULATION THREE POINT
THREE MILLION PEOPLE. WE NEED A
CEMETERY ON THAT OLD EL TORO
MARINE BASE. AND ASK FOR YOUR
AYE THE. THINGS WROTE DR CHOI.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. I ALSO RISE
IN SUPPORT OF THAT THIS SO
WHICH IN A MATTER OF. AB THREE
SIXTY EIGHT. AS A FORMER
MEMBER. OF A CITY COUNCIL AND
THE MANY OF US CITY OF IRVINE.
THE FORMER. ASIDE ON A SITE
THAT HAS BEEN VERY OF POLITICAL
AND THE- CONTENTIOUS BUT NOW
WITH THIS AS A COMPROMISE THE
VERSION. THAT THE A LATER DATE
NOW FOR THE AWAY FROM THE
pFELLOW LAW AREAS. SO IT IS A
MUCH BETTER LOCATION DOWN THE
PREVIOUS ONES SO OFF WITH THAT
THE- IT HAS BEEN A LONG TIME
THAT HAS BEEN. A DEBATE. AND
THAT THIS ONE HAS A GREAT
CHANCE I EVEN POSTED WE DO WE
HAVE A LOCAL CHILD. PUT
POLITICAL LOCAL. CHALLENGE I
WOULD YOU YES FAULT. THANK YOU
THIS QUIRK SILVA WITHOUT THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
DESIRABLE. ALL MEMBERS THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE. CLARK WELL
CLOSER ALL TELL YOU WHAT I
SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
NUMBERS ONE AND UP GO BACK TO
FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY SIX THIS
FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY SIX SB SIX
TWENTY TWO COVERING. SENATE
BILL SIX TWENTY TWO BY CENTER
DRAWS A ONE ACT PLAY THE CIVIL
DETENTION FACILITIES MR BONTA
YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES OVER THE LAST YEAR.
THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY GENERAL
THE CALIFORNIA STAE AUDITOR
AND DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA HAVE FLAG SEVERAL
INCIDENTS OF HUMAN RIGHTS
ABUSES AT IMMIGRATION DETENTION
FACILITIES IN CALIFORNIA
INCLUDING PHYSICAL AND SEXUAL
ABUSE POR ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE
LITTLE ACCESS TO LEGAL COUNSEL
OVER USE OF SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT. AND EVEN DEATH SB
SIX TWENTY TWO BY SENATOR
DORADO REQUIRE CIVIL DETENTION
FACILITIES TO IMMEDIATELY
NOTIFY THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY
GENERAL OF ANY DEATH IN CIVIL
CUSTODY AND OPEN AN
INVESTIGATION INTO THE CAUSE
AND CIRCUMSTANCES OF THE DEATH.
SB SIX TWENTY TWO ALSO
CLARIFIES THAT ANY FACILITY
RECORDS RELATED TO SUCH DEATHS
ARE PUBLIC RECORDS FOR PURPOSES
OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
RECORDS ACT SINCE MARCH TWENTY
TEN ICE HAS REPORTED A TOTAL OF
EIGHTY THREE DEATHS NATIONALLY
IN ADULT IMMIGRATION DETENTION
IN CALIFORNIA ALONE THERE HAVE
BEEN AT LEAST THIRTEEN. THIS
BILL WILL CREATE GREATER AND
MUCH NEEDED TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AND CIVIL
DETENTION FACILITIES CURRENTLY
OPERATING IN CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE ON THIS MEASURE.
THANK WHICH BONTA SEEING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE QUIRK LIBERAL.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE CEREMONY ALL
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBER SERVICE OUT OF VOTE.
KIRK WELL CLOSER ALL TALLY THE
VOTE AS FORTY SIX KNOWS TEN THE
MEASURE PASSES. BACK IN THE
PREVIOUS FILE ORDER THIS IS
FILE ITEM ONE NINETY FOUR. SB
FORTY TO OPERATE. SENATE BILL
FORTY TWO BY SENATOR SKINNER
AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE THE
JAILS DOCTOR EGGMAN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER SB
FORTY TWO WILL ALLOW THOSE
RELEASE FROM COUNTY JAIL
BETWEEN SUNDOWN AND EIGHT AM
THE OPTION TO STAY IN THEIR
CELL WITH THEIR CONSENT OR
PERMISSION IN AND SAFE AT
WAITING AREA. OFTENTIMES
RELEASING PEOPLE FROM JAIL IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT IS
DANGEROUS ESPECIALLY FOR WOMEN
AND PEOPLE LIVING OUT IN THE
RULE COMMUNITIES SOMETIMES JAIL
CAN BE FIFTEEN MILES AWAY FROM
THE NEAREST SAFE PLACE FOR
SOMEBODY TO GO THE SAFE WAITING
AREA OFFERED BY THIS BILL WILL
PROVIDE FREE PHONE CALLS ACCESS
TO SELL CHARGERS AND REQUIRE
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE RELATED
RELEASED LATE AT NIGHT TO BE
TRACKED. THIS BILL WILL PREVENT
THE AVOIDABLE DEATH IN DANGER
TO THOSE WHO HAVE SERVED THEIR
TIME AND ARE TRYING TO GET ON
WITH THEIR LIVES WE HAVE
PROGRAMS IN NOT SAM JUST GOING
LA HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFUL IT BE
GREAT TO PROVIDE THIS OPTION
EVERYWHERE I KNOW MY OWN COUNTY
WE'VE HAD AN ISSUE WITH PEOPLE
BEING ASSAULTED. INJURED WHEN
THEY ARE RELEASED LATE IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT AND THE OUT
OF FRENCH CAMP IT'S AT LEAST A
SIX MILE WALK INTO ANYWHERE
ELSE AND IF YOU DON'T HAVE A
CELL PHONE. YOU ARE LEFT AT THE-
SEE OF ANYONE OUT THERE. SO
LET'S KEEP PEOPLE SAFE PLEASE
VOTE YES ON SB FORTY TWO. DAY
DOCTOR RECOMMEND SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
BETTER CEREMONY ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBER
SERVICE ARE TO VOTE. CLICK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE WHAT ICE FIFTY
TWO NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
PASSING RETAIN A FILE ITEMS ONE
NINETY FIVE THROUGH TWO HUNDRED.
THIS IS FILE ITEM. TWO OH ONE.
SB ONE FORTY TWO COVERAGE
SENATE BILL ONE FORTY TWO BY
CENTER WE ANOTHER'S NATURALLY
INTO ONE POINT THIS WICKS THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
I RISE TODAY 2% SB ONE FORTY
TWO ON BEHALF OF SENATOR WIENER
THIS BILL ENSURES THAT
EMPLOYEES WHO ARE PREGNANT OR
CONSIDERING PREGNANCY KNOW THAT
BREAST FEEDING WILL BE
ACCOMMODATED BY THEIR EMPLOYER
IT BASICALLY DOES TWO THINGS IT
EDUCATES EMPLOYERS I SORRY
EMPLOYEES ON THE RIGHT TO LIKE
TATIAN SPACE AND ALSO PROTECTS
EMPLOYEES. FROM POTENTIAL
RETALIATION FROM THE EMPLOYER
AND AS SOMEONE WHO HAS A PUMPED
IN GAS STATION BATHROOMS AND IN
MY CAR AND IN A HOTEL CLOSETS
THIS IS A REALLY IMPORTANT
MEASURE FOR WOMEN WHO ARE
BREASTFEEDING WE SHOULD BE
DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
ENCOURAGE BREASTFEEDING AT IN
OUR WORKPLACE AND BEYOND THIS
BILL HAS THE SUPPORT OF THE
CALIFORNIA BREASTFEEDING
COALITION LEGAL AID AT WORK
ACLU WOMEN'S FOUNDATION AND
OTHERS AND I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK ON BEHALF OF ALL MOTHERS.
IN THIS STATE FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS WICKS. SEEING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLICK LIBERAL. SARAH BUT ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ALL TALBOT
EYES FORTY SIX KNOWS ELEVEN.
THAT MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WE
ARE GOING TO GO BACK AND TAKE
UP. FILE ITEM ONE NINETY EIGHT.
THIS FILE ITEM ONE NINETY EIGHT
SB ONE TWENTY SEVEN CORKERY.
SENATE BILL ONE TWENTY SEVEN BY
CENTER WIENER ANOTHER'S
INOCULATED TRANSPORTATION AS
PER THE HORA YES THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS SB ONE
TWENTY SEVEN IS A COMMON SENSE
BILL THAT REQUIRES CALTRANS TO
CONSIDER AND WHERE APPROPRIATE
INTEGRATE COMPLETE ST FEATURES
LIKE VISIBLE CROSS WALKS. AND
BIKE LANES INTO ROUTINE
MAINTENANCE PROJECTS ON STATE
HIGHWAY SEGMENTS OF FUNCTION AS
SERVICE STREETS BECAUSE THIS
STATE HIGHWAY SEGMENTS ARE
MEANT TO CARRY TRAFFIC QUICKLY
THEY DO NOT ALWAYS INCLUDE
SIDEWALKS A BICYCLE FACILITIES
THAT MAKE IT SAFE TO WALK A
BIKE ALONG THEM AND MANY OF
THESE ROADS ARE SAFE ROUTES TO
SCHOOLS FOR CHILDREN. THIS IS A
PROBLEM FOR CALIFORNIANS ACROSS
THE STREET THE STATE WHO USE
THE STATE HIGHWAY SEGMENTS TO
CUT THROUGH THEIR COMMUNITIES
TO GET HOME TO GO TO SCHOOL OR
VISIT THE DOCTOR ACCORDING TO
SMART GROWTH AMERICA THIS
PROBLEM IS SO LARGE THAT
CALIFORNIA RANKS NUMBER SIXTEEN
IN THE NATION FOR PEDESTRIAN
RISK WITH SEVEN THOUSAND ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY SEVEN PEDESTRIAN
DEATHS. BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND
TWENTY SIXTEEN ALONE EIGHT
HUNDRED SIXTY SEVEN PEDESTRIANS
WERE KILLED AND MORE THAN
FOURTEEN THOUSAND WERE INJURED.
IN SEPTEMBER IN SEPTEMBER WE
HAVE WHAT'S KNOWN AS PEDESTRIAN
SAFETY MONTH AND WE CAN DO
BETTER BY ENCOURAGING THE
INCLUSION OF COMPLETE ST
FEATURES THAT CALM TRAFFIC
REDUCE COLLISION AND SAVE LIVES
SB ONE TWENTY SEVEN ASSURE THAT
CALTRANS CONSIDER COMPLETE ST
ELEMENTS FIFTY DESIGN ASPECTS
FOR ALL ROAD USERS ON THE STATE
HIGHWAY SEGMENTS THAT ARE ALSO
CITY SERVICE STREETS. IT
REQUIRES CALTRANS TO MAKE STATE
OWNED ROADS IN CITIES AND TOWNS
SAY FOR PEOPLE. IN OUR
COMMUNITY I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MS
BOERNER HORVATH. SEEN NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE CAR CLUB
THE ROLE. THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ALL. HI BUT
ICE FORTY KNOWS FIFTEEN. THAT
MEASURE PASSES BACK IN FILE
ORDER THIS IS FILE ITEM TWO OH
TWO. SB ONE FIFTY NINE. THE
CLERK WILL READ SENATE BILL ONE
FIFTY NINE BY SOONER WIENER
ANOTHER RECYCLING HIV
PREVENTION. MISTER GIBSON THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AS THE CHAIR OF THE
SELECT COMMITTEE ON INFECTIOUS
DISEASE I RISE UP TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL SENATE BILL ONE
FIFTY NINE BY SENATOR WINNER.
OF WHICH SEEKS TO EXPAND ACCESS
TO CRITICAL AND POWERFUL HIV
PREVENTATIVE MEDICATIONS TO
BRIEFLY SUMMARIZE PREP IS A PO
ONE TIME A DAY FOR THOSE WHO
ARE NEGATIVE TO HIV ALMOST
NEARLY ENTIRELY SKEWS ME
CHARLIE ELIMINATES THE RISK OF
BECOMING INFECTED BY HIV. HELP
IS A ONE TIME TWENTY EIGHT DAY
OF COURSE UP FOR PEOPLE WHO MAY
HAVE BEEN EXPOSED BY HIV IT CAN
STOP HIV FROM TAKE YOU HOLD IN
YOUR BODY. FOR EXPOSURES OF
SEVENTY TWO HOURS PREPPING PAP
ARE BOTH CRITICAL TOWARDS THE
CAMPAIGN IN THE STRATEGY TO IN
HIV INFECTION NEW HIV
INFECTIONS RATES I'M HERE IN
CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY PREPPING
PAP BOTH REQUIRES A PHYSICIAN'S
PRESCRIPTION WHICH DELAYS OR
PREVENT SOME. SOME PEOPLE FROM
ACCESSING THE CARE THAT THEY
NEED REDUCING NEW HIV
INFECTIONS WHILE MAINTAINING
POSITIVE HEALTH OUTCOMES IS THE
GOAL OF THIS LEGISLATION AND WE
BELIEVE THAT REMOVING THESE
UNNECESSARY BARRIERS TO KEY TO
KEEP INDIVIDUALS HEALTHY. AND
IN GOOD SPIRITS COLLEAGUES THIS
BILL HAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
HAS A STRONG COALITION OF HIV
ADVOCATES PHARMACISTS AND
PHYSICIANS BEHIND IT I WOULD
LIKE TO ALSO. NOTE THAT
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
HAS REMOVED THEIR OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL I RESPECTFULLY ASK
BUT I VOTE ON SENATE BILL ONE
FIFTY NINE. THANK YOU MS GIBSON
THIS WALDRON YOUR RECORD THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
YEARS AFTER THE US FOOD AND
DRUG ADMINISTRATION APPROVED
PRE EXPOSURE PROPHYLAXIS KNOWN
AS PREP. AND POST EXPOSURE
PROPHYLAXIS PEP. TREATMENTS
MANY PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIANS
HAVE NOT PRESCRIBED IT OR EVER
HEARD OF IT. IN FACT MANY FEEL
UNCOMFORTABLE DISCUSSING PRE
EXPOSURE AND THE STIGMA THAT IS
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT WHICH IS
ONE OF THE THINGS WE'RE
CONTINUE TO WORK TO OVERCOME.
REDUCES THE RISK OF HIV
TRANSMISSIONS BY 99% IN HIGH
RISK UNPROTECTED SEX AND BY 74%
284% IN PEOPLE WHO IN JACK
DRUGS. IN A SEPARATE TWENTY
SIXTEEN CDC REPORT ON
HETEROSEXUALS AT INCREASED RISK
FOR HIV ONLY SIX POINT 7% HAD
EVER HEARD OF PRESS. INCREASING
ACCESS TO LIFESAVING TREATMENTS
WHICH IS WHAT THIS BILL DOES
DESERVE YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS WALDRON. SEEING
NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION. OR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM THE CAR CLUB
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS OF. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS OUT OF BOTH. CLARK WELL
CLOSER ALL. TELL VOTE. I SIXTY
FIVE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS WERE GOING TO
MOVE BACK IN THE FILE TO TAKE
UP. FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY FOUR.
THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY
FOUR. SB FOUR FIFTY NINE
CORPORATE. SENATE BILL FOR THE
ARE BY CENTER GALGIANI
INOCULATED CRIMES IS PARA QUE
HAN. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
TODAY I RISE RIPPED PRESENT SB
FOUR FIFTY NINE AND A HALF THE
SENATOR GALGIANI SP FOUR FIFTY
NINE ADDS CONSISTENCY THE PENAL
CODE BY APPLYING THE EXISTING
FIVE YEAR SENTENCE ENHANCEMENT
FOR THE INFLICTION OF GREAT
BODILY INJURY DURING A RAPE TO
INCLUDE A SPOUSAL RAPE. UNDER
CURRENT LAW A PERSON CONVICTED
OF RAPE IS GIVEN A FIVE YEAR
SENSE ENHANCEMENT WHEN THE
SURVIVOR HAS SUFFERED GREAT
SUFFERED GREAT BODILY INJURY
UNDER THE FOLLOWING
CIRCUMSTANCES FORCE VIOLENCE TO
RASTER MENACE INTOXICATION OR
UNDER ANESTHETIC OR CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCES AND UNDER THREAT
RETALIATION. BUT THERE IS NO
ENHANCEMENT OF THE SURVIVOR
SUFFERED GREAT BODILY INJURY AT
THE HANDS OF A SPOUSE UNDER
INTOXICATION UNDER ANESTHETIC
OR CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES SB
FOUR FIFTY NINE WOULD FIX THIS
INCONSISTENCY AND GIVES
SURVIVORS OF MARITAL RAPE EQUAL
JUSTICE. THE BILL HAS RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK INSPIRED HANDS SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLUB THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE CEREMONY ALL
MEMBERS THE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE VOTE
EYES FIFTY NINE NO ZERO.
MEASURE PASSES BACK IN REGULAR
FILE ORDER. THIS IS FILE ITEM
TWO OH THREE. SB ONE SIXTY.
PERCENT OF I MISS THEM ON
QUICKLY. SENATE BILL ONE SIXTY
BY CENTER JACKSON AND OTHERS
NOT RELATE TO EMERGENCIES MISS
THE MARK THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS SB ONE
SIXTY REQUIRES COUNTY EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT OFFICES TO IMPLEMENT
CULTURAL COMPETENCE INTO THE
NEXT. UPDATE OF THEIR EMERGENCY
PLANS SPECIFICALLY SB ONE SIXTY
REQUIRES LOCAL EMERGENCY PLANS
TO ADDRESS AT A MINIMUM HELLO
ALL CULTURAL POPULATIONS WITHIN
THE JURISDICTIONS ARE SERVED BY
EMERGENCY COMMUNICATIONS YOU
MAD EMERGENCY EVACUATION
SHELTERING EMERGENCY MITIGATION
PREVENTION EMERGENCY PLANNING
AND EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS AMAL SEE
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE. CLERK
WILL THE ROLE. PARAMOUNT. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
CLERK WELL. CLOSER ALL TIED TO
VOTE EYES FIFTY SEVEN NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES OVER TO
PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE AND TO
FOR FILE ITEM TWO OH FIVE. SB
ONE SEVENTY SIX. QUICK READ.
SENATE BILL ONE SEVENTY SIX BY
SENATE JACKSON AN ACCOLADE TO
ATTORNEYS MR STONE. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS ON
BEHALF OF THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE I RISE TO PRESENT THE
ANNUAL BAR DUES BILL. FOR THOSE
OF YOU WHO'VE BEEN HERE FOR A
FEW YEARS YOU REALIZE THAT IT
IS THIS HOUSE WHO HAS DRIVEN
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES AT THE
STATE BAR. MAKING SURE THAT
THEY ARE ACCOUNTABLE TO US AND
ENSURING THAT THEY ARE BEING
THEIR OBLIGATION OF PULP THE
PUBLIC PROTECTION THAT THE
LEGISLATURE SET FOR THEM A
NUMBER OF YEARS AGO. THIS
YEAR'S UNIQUE HOWEVER BECAUSE
THE STATE BAR CAME TO US ASKING
FOR AN INCREASE IN THE DUES.
DEUCE WIRES PAY HAS NOT BEEN
RAISED IN TWENTY YEARS. A
POTENTIALLY MORE. AND MASSES
FOR A LARGE CHUNK OF MONEY
JUSTIFIED BY SOME. STATEMENTS
AND SOME DOCUMENTATION THAT
SEEMED INADEQUATE FORTUNATELY
THIS HOUSE REQUIRED AN AUDIT BY
THE LA L. AN AUDIT BY THE STATE
AUDITOR. THE INFORMATION THAT
WE OBTAINED THROUGH THOSE AUDIT
SHOWED THAT WHAT THE STATE BAR
WAS ASKING FOR WAS
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE THAN THEY
COULD JUSTIFY. SO WHILE THIS
BILL DOES INCLUDE. AN INCREASE
IN THE IN THE ANNUAL DUES. IT
IS SOMETHING THAT WE FEEL IS
NOW MUCH MORE REASONABLE AND-
THIS BILL CONTAINS PROVISIONS
TO ENSURE THAT THE THAT THE
STATE BAR IS SPENDING THE MONEY
IN WAYS THAT THE STATE AUDITOR
AND THE LA. SUGGESTED AND AGAIN
DAD IS THE OVERSIGHT THAT WE'RE
PROVIDING OVERDID MINISTRY TO
FUNCTION OF THE JUDICIAL
BRANCH. I FEEL THAT THIS THIS
BILL IS REASONABLE I KNOW THAT
WOULD THAT WE'VE BEEN HEARING
QUITE A BIT FROM ATTORNEYS WHO
ARE OBJECTING TO PAYING TO
HIGHER FEES. BUT THE FACT THAT
THEY HAVEN'T BEEN RAISED IN A
NUMBER OF YEARS AND THE FACT
THAT THAT THIS NUMBER THAT IS
NOW IN THIS BILL IS SUPPORTED
BY BOTH THE LA AND THE STATE
AUDITOR. I THINK IT IS A
REASONABLE STEP BUT THAT SHOULD
NOT AT ALL TAKE AWAY FROM THE
OVERSIGHT THAT WE WILL CONTINUE
TO DO OVER THE STATE BAR. SO ON
BEHALF OF SENATE JUDICIARY AND
SENATOR JACKSON I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTES ON SB ONE SEVENTY SIX.
A MISTER STONE. SAY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK
LIBERAL. MEMBERS VOTE. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE ABOUT. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
. THIS TAKES
FORTY ONE
. MR STONE MOVES A
CALL. AVERAGE THIS IS FILE ITEM
TWO OH SIX SB ONE EIGHTY TWO
CORPORATION SENATE BILL ONE
EIGHTY TWO BY SENATOR JACKSON
AND ACTUALLY LOCAL GOVERNMENT
MS AGUIAR-CURRY THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE
TO PRESENT SENATOR JACKSON'S
BILL SB ONE EIGHTY TWO WHICH
ESTABLISHES COMMUNITY RISK
REDUCTION STANDARDS FOR NEW
DEVELOPMENTS PLANNED IN THE
VERY HIGH FIRE RISK AREAS. AS
OF LATE WE HAVE BEEN REGULARLY
REMINDED ABOUT THE RISKS OF OUR
RURAL SUBURBAN AND EVEN URBAN
COMMUNITIES FACE DURING
CATASTROPHIC FIRES REVIEW OF
THESE INCIDENTS SHOWS THAT WE
CAN DO BETTER IN PLANNING
COMMUNITIES FOR EVACUATION
DESIGN COMMUNITY HARDENING AND
DEFENSIBLE SPACE FIRE FLOW AND
EMERGENCY RESPONSE THIS BILL
DOES JUST THAT BY DIRECTING CAL
FIRE IN THE OFFICE OF STATE
FIRE MARSHAL TO ISSUE STATE WHY
COMMUNITY RISK REDUCTION
STANDARDS FOR NEW DEVELOPMENT
APPROVALS IN VERY HIGH. FIRE
RISK AREAS AS WELL AS RETROFIT
PLANS FOR EXISTING DEVELOPMENTS
SB ONE EIGHTY TWO STRIKES A
BALANCE BETWEEN PRESERVING
LOCAL AUTHORITY AND
ESTABLISHING A STATEWIDE
PLANNING STANDARDS TO REDUCE
LOSS OF LIFE AND PROPERTY FROM
WILD FLOW FIRES. I ASKED FOR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MS
AGUIAR-CURRY SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. CAR CLUB
THE ROLE. SORRY ABOUT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A- ALL
MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL. CLOSER ALL TIME
ABOUT EYES FIFTY EIGHT KNOWS
FOR THAT MEASURE PASSES THIS IS
FILE ITEM TWO OH SEVEN SP ONE
NINETY. SENATE BILL ONE NINETY
BY SENATOR DODD AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE FIRE SAFETY.
DOCTOR WOULD. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS SB ONE
NINETY DIRECTS THE OFFICE OF
THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL TO
ENHANCE AWARENESS OF AND
COMPLIANCE WITH EXISTING
DEFENSIBLE SPACE REQUIREMENTS
TO BETTER PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITIES FROM FUTURE
WILDFIRES. EARLIER THIS YEAR
CAL FIRE RELEASED A REPORT THAT
STRESS THE NEED FOR THE STATE
TO TAKE A COMPREHENSIVE ACTIONS
IN ADDRESSING VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT DEFENSIBLE SPACE AND
HARDENING HOMES. SB ONE NINETY
DOES THREE THINGS FIRST IT
DIRECTS THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL
TO DEVELOP A MODEL DEFENSIBLE
SPACE ORDINANCE FOR
CONSIDERATION BY JURISDICTIONS
THAT MAY NOT HAVE ONE IN PLACE.
SECOND IT REQUIRES THE STATE
FIRE MARSHAL TO PRODUCE AND
MAKE AVAILABLE ON THE INTERNET
OF A LOUIS STANDARDS COMPLIANCE
MANUAL TO HELP TRAIN
CONTRACTORS BUILDING OFFICIALS
FIRE SERVICE AND THE PUBLIC.
LASTLY THE BILL REQUIRES THE
STATE FIRE MARSHAL THE UPDATE
AND MAINTAIN A WILL BE
COMPLIANT PRODUCT MANUAL FOR
REFERENCE BY CONTRACTORS
BUILDING OFFICIALS FIRE SERVICE
IN THE GENERAL PUBLIC TOGETHER
THESE RESOURCES WILL HELP OUR
COMMUNITIES TO BE MORE FIRE
RESILIENT IN FUTURE WILDFIRES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD.
SAY NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
OUR GLOBAL ROLE. MEMBERS OF THE
SITE ABOUT. ALL MEMBERS OTHERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS A
DESIRE TO VOTE. QUIRK WELL
CLOSER ALL TALBOT EYES FIFTY
NINE. KNOWS ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES THIS IS FILE ITEM TO
AWAIT. SB ONE NINETY SIX. QUICK
RATE SENATE BILL ONE EIGHTY SIX
BY SENATOR BELL AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TAXATION. THIS
PETRIE-NORRIS. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TO ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR SB ONE
NINETY SIX WHICH WILL CREATE
MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR LOW
AND MODERATE INCOME FAMILIES BY
PROVIDING PROPERTY TAX RELIEF
FOR COMMUNITY LAND TRUST THIS
BILL WILL CREATE PARITY IN LAW
ALLOWING COMMUNITY LAND TRUSTS
TO ENJOY THE SAME TAX
EXEMPTIONS THAT OTHER COMMUNITY
BASED NONPROFITS CURRENTLY
UTILIZE NONPROFIT HOUSING
ORGANIZATIONS WORK TIRELESSLY
TO PROVIDE HOUSING ACROSS THE
STATE AND MUST BE AFFORDED AS
MANY TOOLS AS POSSIBLE AS WE
CONFRONT CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING
CRISIS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR IPAD. SEEING NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM QUIRK
LIBERAL. THE DESIRE TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THAT RESERVE A. QUIRK
WELL CLOSER ROLLTIDE ABOUT ICE
FIFTY THREE. KNOWS ONE. THE
MEASURE PASSES. THIS IS FILE
ITEM TWO OH NINE. SB TWO TEN
COOKERY SENATE BILL TWO TEN BY
SENATOR LEYVA AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO BE AWARE POLLUTION
MR GARCIA. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES SB TWO
TEN ESTABLISHES SMOG CHECK
REQUIREMENTS FOR HEAVY DUTY NON
GASOLINE TRUCKS BY MODERNIZING
EMISSIONS CONTROL ENFORCEMENT
THREE COMPREHENSIVE INSPECTION
AND MAINTENANCE PROGRAM OVER
THE NEXT DECADE SB TWO TEN WILL
ASSIST IN THE REMOVAL OF
SIXTEEN HUNDRED TONS OF HARMFUL
PARTICULAR MATTER COOLANT TO
TAKING THREE HUNDRED SEVEN FIVE
THOUSAND TRUCKS. OFF THE ROADS
IN CALIFORNIA I'D LIKE TO
PERSONALLY KNOWLEDGE AND THANK
THE AUTHOR THE BILL FOR WORKING
WITH THE VARIOUS INDUSTRIES
THERE ARE SOME PENDING ISSUES
THAT THE REGULATORY PROCESS AT
A R. B. WILL TAKE CARE OF BUT
CERTAINLY RECOGNIZING THE WORK
THAT WENT INTO THE BILL AS IT
RELATES TO THE AG INDUSTRIES
AND OTHER INDUSTRIES AND RURAL
COMMUNITIES. RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOU I WILL. AMOS GARCIA
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
CARPOOL OF THE ROLE. THESE ARE
NOT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
ABOUT. ALL MEMBERS OF. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE
. ALL MEMBERS ARE
RESERVE A
. CLICK WELL. CLOSER
ALL. TELL YOU ABOUT AYE AYES
FORTY FOUR. NO SIXTEEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES. I WANT TO PASS
RETAIN A FILE ITEMS TO TEN
THROUGH TWO TWELVE. THIS IS.
FILE ITEM TO THIRTEEN
. MEMBERS
WANT TO PASS TEMPORARILY ON
FILE ITEM TO THIRTEEN.
CORRECTION WE'RE GONNA TAKE UP
FALLEN TO THIRTEEN SB TWO
SEVENTY THREE CORKERY SENATE
BILL TWO SEVENTY THREE BY
SENATOR RUBIO AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
IS RUBIO THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS TODAY I AM
PRESENTING SB TWO SEVENTY THREE
THE PHOENIX ACT ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR SUSAN RUBIO. SB TWO
SEVENTY THREE WHAT EXTEND THE
STAT THE STATUE OF LIMITATIONS
FROM THREE YEARS TO FIVE YEARS
FOR SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE ABUSE TO REPORT. THIS
BILL ALSO PROVIDES CRITICAL
TRAINING FOR PEACE OFFICERS TO
BE ABLE TO HELP SUPPORT
SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
WHO COME FORWARD. MEMBERS IT IS
TIME TO EMPOWER SURVIVORS. OF
THIS ABUSE. DATA SHOWS MULTIPLE
REASONS WHY SURVIVORS MAY NOT
COME FORWARD WITHIN THE STATUE
OF LIMITATIONS INCLUDING THEIR
AGE AT THE TIME OF ABUSE.
ONGOING TRAUMA THREATS FROM THE
PERPETRATOR OR LACK OF
EVIDENCE. IN AMERICA AN AVERAGE
OF FIFTY WOMEN ARE SHOT TO
DEATH BY THEIR INTIMATE
PARTNERS EVERY MONTH. AND MANY
MORE INJURED. LET'S NOT MAKE
THE STATUE OF LIMITATIONS ONE
MORE HURDLE THAT AN ALREADY
BROKEN TRAUMATIZED VICTIM HAS
TO JUMP. BUT WHEN THEY DO FIND
THE COURAGE TO SEEK JUSTICE WE
MUST ALLOW THEM TO DO SO. THE
BILL WHICH PASSED OUT OF THE
SENATE HAD A MUCH LONGER
EXTENSION ON THE STATUE OF
LIMITATIONS HOWEVER ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEES UNFORTUNATELY
NARROWED THE BILL MUCH TO THE
DISAPPOINTMENT OF THE SURVIVORS
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
SPONSORING THE MEASURE. THIS
INCLUDES THE SENATOR OFFERING
SB TWO SEVENTY THREE WHO IS A
SURVIVOR DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
COMMITTED BY A FORMER MEMBER OF
THIS BODY. MY SISTER AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THE FIGHT
NEXT SESSION AND HOPEFULLY
CONVINCING SOME OF OUR
COLLEAGUES ON THE MERITS OF THE
IMPROV EMPOWERING SURVIVORS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. AS CHAIR OF
THE ASSEMBLY SELECT COMMITTEE
ON DOMESTIC VIOLENCE I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO THANK THOSE OF MY
COLLEAGUES WHO HAVE SUPPORTED
US IN THIS ISSUE. AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO OUR CONTINUED
ADVOCACY FOR SURVIVORS DROP
CALIFORNIA. THIS VOTE THIS BILL
HAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN MY
WRISTS RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MS
RUBIO SEEING. NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE MATTER. CAR CLUB
RURAL ALL MEMBERS. DESIRE TO
VOTE ON MEMBERS OF DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED HER
DESIRE TO VOTE. QUIRK WELL
CLOSE ROLE TELEVOTE EYES SIXTY
ONE KNOWS ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES THIS IS FILE ITEM TO
FOURTEEN. SB TWO SEVENTY SEVEN
CORKERY SENATE BILL TWO SEVENTY
SEVEN BY SENATOR PELL AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO
TRANSPORTATION MR FRAZIER THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. TODAY I AM
PRESENTING SB TWO SEVENTY SEVEN
THIS BILL PROVIDES PROGRAM
DETAILS FOR THE LOCAL
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM OTHERWISE
KNOWN AS THE L. P. P. L. P. P.
IS A FUNDING PROGRAM THAT
PROVIDES A DOLLAR FOR DOLLAR
MATCH TO LOCAL ENTITIES THAT
HAVE PASSED LOCAL MEASURES TO
FUND TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS.
WITHIN THEIR REGION.
HISTORICALLY THE L. P. P. HAS
PROVIDED FUNDING TO THESE
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES ON A
FORMULA BASIS. SB TWO SEVENTY
SEVEN PROVIDES THE PROGRAM
DETAILS AND LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTIVE TO BRING THE CURRENT
LPP INTO ALIGNMENT WITH HOW THE
PROGRAM WAS PREVIOUS PREVIOUSLY
IMPLEMENTED IN THE NINETEEN
NINETIES AND UNDER PROPOSITION
ONE BE. MEMBERS THIS BILL
PROVIDES THE NECESSARY
CLARIFICATION TRAIL PP. THIS
BILL BOOK PROVIDES FUNDING TO
OUR LOCAL TRANSPORTATION
AGENCIES WHICH IN TURN ALLOWS
HIM TO FUND TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS TO ME LOCAL REGIONAL
PRIORITIES. AND THESE LOCAL
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITIES
INFLECT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
INTO THEIR REGIONS AND WE NEED
TO BE ABLE TO PARTNER WITH
THEM. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE.
THANK WAS FRAZIER SAYING NO
DISCUSSION OF A CLERK WILL CALL
THE ROLL. SARAH ALL MEMBERS OF.
DESIRABLE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. CLARK WELL CLOSER
ALL. TELL ABOUT AS FIFTY THREE
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES S.
FILE ITEM TO FIFTEEN IS SB
THREE THREE SEVEN. QUICK READ
SENATE BILL THREE THREE SEVEN
BY SENATOR SKINNER AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY A CHILD SUPPORT.
MS RUBIO. YOU MAY OPEN. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TO
PRESENT SB THREE THIRTY SEVEN
ON BEHALF OF SENATOR SKINNER.
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN LOW
INCOME PARENTS PAID NEARLY
THREE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
MILLION IN CHILD SUPPORT TO THE
GOVERNMENT RESULTING IN OVER
ONE POINT TWO MILLION
CALIFORNIA. CHILDREN LIVING IN
OR NEAR POVERTY ONLY RECEIVING
FIFTY DOLLARS OF THEIR CHILD
SUPPORT PAYMENT. THIS BILL WILL
INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF CHILD
SUPPORT PAYMENTS PASSED ON CAL
WORKS RECIPIENTS TO ONE HUNDRED
DOLLARS FOR A PARENT OF ONE
CHILD. AND TO TWO HUNDRED
DOLLARS FOR A PARENT WITH TWO
OR MORE CHILDREN. THIS BILL
ALSO ALIGNS WITH FEDERAL LAW IN
REGARDS TO INCOME DISREGARD AND
DOES NOT AFFECT ELIGIBILITY FOR
ASSISTANCE. GOVERNMENT SERVICES
SUCH AS CAL WORKS AND CAL
FRESH. SB THREE THIRTY SEVEN
TAKES STEPS TOWARDS
REHABILITATING A BROKEN SYSTEM
AND DIRECTS CHILD SUPPORT MONEY
GO WHERE IT SHOULD TO THE
CHILDREN. THIS BILL HAS ENJOYED
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I BOUGHT. NAME IS RUBIO SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE OUR PROBLEM
ROLE. IS THAT OF A. ALL MEMBERS
THAT RESERVE A- ALL MEMBERS
SENATORS ARE TO VOTE. WORK WELL
CLOSER ALL HI BUT I FIFTY SIX
KNOWS ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASSES
THIS IS FILE ITEM TO SIXTEEN SB
THREE FORTY FOUR CORPORATE
SENATE BILL THREE FORTY FOUR BY
SENATOR MCGUIRE AND ACTUALLY TO
PREPAID MOBILE TELEPHONE
SERVICES. THIS BURKE. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS SB THREE
FORTY FOUR PROVIDE A ONE YEAR
SUNSET EXTENSION TO ALLOW LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO COLLECT ON LOCAL
UTILITY USER TAXES ARE YOU YOU
T. FROM RETAIL RETAIL SALES A
PREPAID WIRELESS
TELECOMMUNICATION PROJECTS
PRODUCTS AND SERVICES PRIOR TO
THE PASSAGE OF AB SEVENTEEN
SEVENTEEN AND TWENTY FOURTEEN.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAD NO WAY
FOR COLLECTING LOCAL YOU YOU
TEASE ON PREPAID WIRELESS AB
SEVENTEEN SEVENTEEN ESTABLISHED
A COLLECTION MECHANISM SIMILAR
TO SALES TAX WHERE CD TFA
COLLECTS LOCALLY IMPOSED YOU
TEASE FROM RETAIL SALES AND
DISTRIBUTE THOSE REVENUES TO
THE CITY OR COUNTY WHERE THE
PURCHASE TOOK PLACE. THERE ARE
CURRENTLY A HUNDRED AND ONE
CITIES AND THREE COUNTY TO
COLLECT YOU YOU TEASE ON
PREPAID WIRELESS WHICH HAVE
RECEIVED APPROXIMATELY TWENTY
FOUR MILLION IN NEW REVENUE
SINCE THE PROGRAM WAS ENACTED.
IF SB THREE FORTY FOUR IS NOT
IN THE THESE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS WILL LOSE THEIR
ABILITY TO COLLECT THIS REVENUE
SOAPS BEGINNING JANUARY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY SB THREE FORTY
FOUR WILL ONLY APPLY TO LOCAL
IMPOSED VOTER APPROVED UTILITY
USER TAX IS. NOT THE PROVISIONS
AB SEVEN SOME SEVENTEEN
SEVENTEEN THAT WERE OVERTURNED
BY THE COURTS THAT DECISION
WILL REQUIRE ADDITIONAL CLEAN
UP AND TIME TO BE WORKED OUT SB
THREE FORTY FOUR WILL ENSURE
THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE KEPT
WHOLE WHILE THESE LARGER ISSUES
ARE SORTED OUT THIS MEASURE
ENJOYS BROAD ISN'T SUPPORT. THE
LEGAL CITIES C. C. S. C. STOCK
HELP ME RETIRED SO. SHE'S CHEN
AND SEAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AND I. THANK YOU MS BURKE.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE
QUIRK LIBERAL. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE ABOUT. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. CLICK WELL.
CLOSER ALSO HIGHLIGHTS FORTY NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES HOUSE
RETAIN A FILE ITEM TO EIGHTEEN.
FILE ITEM TO NINETEEN. IS SB
FOUR FIFTY ONE CORKERY SENATE
BILL FOR FIFTY ONE BY SENATOR
ATKINS AND ACTUALLY TAXATION TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY TAX
LEVY. MS BURKE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AT THIS MEASURE WOULD
CREATE AN INCENTIVE FOR
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT THROUGH
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF A TAX
CREDIT FOR THE PRESERVATION AND
REHABILITATION OF HISTORIC
BUILDINGS IN CALIFORNIA IF
ENACTED CALIFORNIA WOULD JOIN
THIRTY FIVE OTHER STATES WAS
STATE HISTORIC TAX CREDIT
PROGRAMS. BY ENABLING
CALIFORNIANS TO LEVERAGE
FEDERAL REHABILITATION TAX
CREDIT IT IS OUR HOPE THAT THIS
MATTER WILL PROVIDE THE EXTRA
INCENTIVE NECESSARY TO
STIMULATE PUBLIC AND EVEN
INVESTMENTS WHILE ALSO BUILDING
CIVIC PRIDE AND WE SAW AS WE
CELEBRATE OUR HERITAGE AND
PRESERVE. CALIFORNIANS PASSED I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST IT. THINGS
BURKE SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE WRONG. ALL
MEMBERS. THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE. ALL
MEMBERS HAVE THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT
I FIFTY NINE NO ZERO. THE
MEASURE PASSES WE DISPENSE WITH
FILE ITEM. TWO TWENTY THIS IS
FILE ITEM TO TWENTY ONE SP FOUR
SEVENTYONE FOR FREE. SENATE
BILL FOR SEVENTY ONE BY SENATOR
STERN AND ACTUALLY TO
SUBPOENAS. MS ARE ONE. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TODAY
TO PRESENT SP FOUR SEVEN ONE BY
SENATOR STERN. PERSONAL
SERVICES OF A SUBPOENA CAN BE A
LABORIOUS AND OFTEN DANGEROUS
TASK REQUIRING COUNTLESS HOURS
SPENT GATHERING INFORMATION IN
ORDER TO LOCATE THE WITNESS AND
SUBSEQUENTLY SERVED A SUBPOENA.
SB FOUR SEVEN ONE WILL ENABLE
PROCESS SERVERS TO DELIVER
SUBPOENAS TO A PARTY IN
LITIGATION ELECTRONICALLY THUS
REMOVING THEMSELVES FROM
POSSIBLE HARM. AND REMOVING THE
RECIPIENT FROM EMBARRASSMENT OR
SOCIAL HARM INVOLVED IN BEING
SERVED THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT THROUGHOUT
BOTH HOUSES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR NIGHT OF. SEEING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CORPORAL.
SEVEN HOMERS VOTERS ARE. ALL
MEMBERS THE DESIRABLE. WELL.
CLOSE ROLES HOWEVER I SIXTY ONE
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
THIS IS FILE ITEM TO SB FOUR
NINETY COVERAGE SENATE BILL FOR
NINETY FIVE SENATOR D'AMATO AND
OTHERS IN EXCELLENT HEALTH
FRESH. THIS RACE. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS. I RISE
TO PRESENT SENATE BILL FOR
NINETY AUTHORED BY SENATOR OR
TOGGLE WHICH WILL PREVENT
HUNGER AMONG LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE ELDERLY OR
DISABLED AND WHO RECEIVE
SUPPLEMENTAL SECURITY INCOME.
IT WILL DO THIS BY REQUIRING
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES TO DEVELOP A POLICY
FOR COMPROMISING.
ADMINISTRATIVE ERROR CLAIMS IN
WHOLE OR IN PART FOR HOUSEHOLDS
INCLUDE AT LEAST ONE ELDERLY OR
DISABLED MEMBER. THIS POLICY
WOULD INCLUDE BUT NOT BE
LIMITED TO RECIPIENTS OF
SUPPLEMENTAL SECURITY INCOME
AND OR CALIFORNIA STATE
SUPPLEMENTARY PAYMENT BENEFITS.
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE
ASSEMBLY LOWER THE COST OF THE
BILL AND NARROW THE SCOPE OF
THE BILL TO REQUIRE DSS TO COME
UP WITH A POLICY ADMINISTRATIVE
ERROR CLAIMS SB FOUR NINETY HAS
HAD NO OPPOSITION AND HAS
ENJOYED UNANIMOUS SUPPORT IN
BOTH POLICY AND APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEES. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. AVIS RESTS
MISTER MATHIS YOU'RE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS ON TO PUT THIS VERY
SIMPLY AS A CO AUTHOR THIS BILL
FIXES THE ERRORS THAT THE
AGENCY HAS BEEN DOING SO WHEN
OUR FAMILIES THAT ARE ON THESE
PROGRAMS GET OVER PAID. INSTEAD
OF THEM GETTING CUT OFF OF
THEIR BENEFIT WHICH IS BEEN
WHAT'S HAPPENING. IT KEEPS THEM
GOING MAKES THE ADMINISTRATION
RESPONSIBLE INSTEAD OF MAKING
THE FAMILY RESPONSIBLE FOR
GOVERNMENT THERE I ASK YOU FOR
AN AYE VOTE. HE WAS MATHIS.
WITH THAT CLICK LIBERAL.
MEMBERS OF THE CEREMONY. ALL
MEMBERS OF DESIRE TO VOTE. KIRK
WELL CLOSER ROLE TELL OF A- I
SIXTY ONE OH ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE AND TWO TWENTY
THREE. SB FIVE TWENTY PRESENTED
BY DR QUIRK. CORPORATION SENATE
BILL FIVE TWENTY BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG AND ACTUALLY TOOK
TRICITY. DR QUIRKY MAIL. THANK
YOU SPEAKER MEMBERS SB FIVE
TWENTY ESTABLISHES A SAFETY NET
FOR ELECTRICITY CUSTOMERS KNOWN
AS THE PROVIDER OF LAST RESORT.
RETAIL ELECTRICITY CHOICE IN
CALIFORNIA HAS EXPANDED RAPIDLY
GIVING CONSUMERS A WIDE RANGE
OF OPTIONS FOR MEETING
RESIDENTIAL AND COMMERCIAL
ENERGY NEEDS APART FROM A
REGULATED UTILITY COMPANY. IN
TWO THOUSAND ONE THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY CRISIS DISPLAYED FIRST
HAND WHAT CAN HAPPEN WHEN
CALIFORNIA'S HE'LL PREPARED.
THE SUDDEN FAILURE OF A LOAD
SERVING ENTITY BECAUSE
BLACKOUTS ACROSS THE STATE AND
EXPOSE CUSTOMERS TO DRAMATIC
PRICE INCREASES AT THAT TIME
ONLY 50% OF OUR ENERGY MARKET
WAS OCCUPIED BY ENTITIES THAT
WERE NOT INVESTING INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITIES AND YET THE
IMPACT WAS STILL PROFOUND.
TODAY THE NUMBER OF NON I USES
INCREASED 2404% NOT ALL LOAD
SERVING ENERGIES ARE REGULATED
LEAVING THOSE CUSTOMERS
POTENTIALLY WITHOUT KEY
CONSUMER AND PRICE PROTECTION.
LAST YEAR FOLLOWING A SERIES OF
P. UC WORKSHOPS WHICH
DETERMINED THAT DEFINING A
PROVIDER OF LAST RESORT WAS
CRITICAL. SENATE BILL FIVE
TWENTY ESTABLISHES THIS BASIC
SAFETY NET FOR ELECTRICITY
CUSTOMERS. THIS WILL ENSURE
CONTINUOUS ELECTRIC SERVICE IN
THE EVENT A RETAIL ELECTRICITY
PROVIDER LEAVES THE MARKET FOR
ANY REASON I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
EXPERTS SAY NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE CORPS CORPORAL. OBSERVER
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE OF A.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
WELL. CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE
ABOUT ICE FIFTY FOUR NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES THIS IS
FILE ITEM TO TWENTY FOUR SP
FIVE THIRTY READ. SENATE BILL
FIVE THIRTY BY SENATOR GALGIANI
AND OTHERS AND EXPLAIN TO
EMPLOYMENT. MISS KOREA. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
SB FIVE THIRTY WILL REQUIRE THE
DIVISION OF LABOR STANDARDS
ENFORCEMENT TO DEVELOP AN
INTEREST IF SPECIFIC HARASSMENT
DISCRIMINATION PREVENTION
POLICY FOR USE BY EMPLOYERS IN
THE CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY.
ONGOING REVELATIONS UNDERSCORED
THE EXTENT TO WHICH WIDESPREAD
SEXUAL HARASSMENT EXISTS WITH
IN VIRTUALLY EVERY INDUSTRY
THESE INCIDENTS UNDERMINE THE
ACHIEVEMENTS OUR STATE HAVE
MADE TOWARDS GENDER EQUITY IN
THE WORKPLACE SB FIVE THIRTY
ADDRESSES THIS PROBLEM BY
ESTABLISHING AN ADVISORY
COMMITTEE TO DEVELOP INDUSTRY
SPECIFIC. ANTI HARASSMENT AND
DISCRIMINATION POLICY TRAINING
STANDARDS FOR USE BY
CONSTRUCTION EMPLOYERS
INCLUDING THE TIME FRAME FOR
RECEIVING THE TRAINING TRAINER
QUALIFICATIONS AND THE METHODS
BY WHICH AN EMPLOYER CAN
PROVIDE TRAINING. THIS BILL
ENJOYS A BROAD BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. THANK WAS
CARRILLO. SENIOR DISCUSSION
DEBATE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
RIGHT. SIDE OF ON ALL MEMBERS
OF THE CEREMONY. ALL MEMBERS
ARE DESIRABLE. CLICK WELL CLOSE
ROLE TELEVOTE EYES FIFTY ONE
KNOWS FIVE. THAT MEASURE PASSES
WELL IN TWO TWENTY FIVE IS SB
FIVE THIRTY SEVEN CORKERY
SENATE BILL FIVE THIRTY SEVEN
BY SENATOR HILL AND ACTUALLY TO
WORKERS COMPENSATION MISTER
DAVID CHIU YOU MAY OPEN THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER COLLEAGUES
SB FIVE THIRTY SEVEN WOULD
REDUCE MEDICAL DISPUTES AN
INCREASE TRANSPARENCY IN THE
OPERATION OF MEDICAL PROVIDER
NETWORKS WITHIN THE WORKERS
COMP SYSTEM. THESE NETWORKS ARE
KEY TOOL IN A WORKERS COMP
SYSTEM TO ENSURE THAT INJURED
WORKERS GET THE TREATMENT THEY
NEED IN A COST EFFECTIVE AWAY
AND THAT WORKERS HAVE CHOICES
TO ACCESS THE MEDICAL CARE WITH
PROVIDERS THAT THEY LIKE. THIS
BILL WOULD REQUIRE THAT THESE
NETWORKS ARE TRANSPARENT ON
CHANGES TO MEDICAL BILLS AND
TREATMENT PLANS AS WELL AS
REIMBURSEMENT RATES TO
PROVIDERS THE BILL'S HAD NO
VOTES IN OPPOSITION AND BROAD
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. FAMOUS SHOES SAYING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE CLERK WILL
PAROLE. SORRY ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
KIRK WELL CLOSER ALL TELL YOU
WHAT I FIFTY EIGHT NO ZERO. THE
TWO SIX IS SB FIVE FORTY ONE
CLERK WILL READ SENATE BILL
FIVE FORTY ONE BY SENATOR BATES
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY SCHOOL
SAFETY. MS GONZALEZ. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TO
PRESENT FIVE SB FIVE FORTY ONE
ON BEHALF CENTER BEACH BATES
WHICH REQUIRES CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT EDUCATION COLLECT
DATA AND PRODUCE A REPORT. ON
THE USE OF LOCKED DOWN AND
OTHER EMERGENCY RESPONSE DRILLS
IN ALL CASE TO TWELVE PUBLIC
AND CHARTER SCHOOLS
SPECIFICALLY CD WILL HAVE TO
LOOK INTO THE BEST PRACTICES
FOR AGE APPROPRIATE DRILLS
THEIR EFFECTIVENESS IN THE
AFFECTS OF DRILLS HAVE ON EMOTE
STUDENTS EMOTIONAL WELL BEING
AND EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS. I
AM I AM GRATEFUL THAT THE
AUTHOR TOOK SUBSTANTIAL
AMENDMENTS IN APPROPRIATIONS
RATHER THAN SAYING WE ARE GOING
TO DO LOCKDOWN DRILLS AS A MOM
OF A- A YOUNG CHILD I KNOW THAT
THAT'S NOT NECESSARILY
APPROPRIATE IN SCHOOLS HAVE
CHOSEN DIFFERENT WAYS TO DO IT
WHICH HAVE NOT ALWAYS BEEN
GREAT. THIS WILL STUDY AND GET
AS BEST PRACTICES SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK. NAME IS
GONZALEZ MR BRO YOUR RECORD
HENCE. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
FORTY ONE. SB FIVE FORTY ONE
EDUCATE CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
TEACHERS AND PARENTS ON KNOWING
WHAT TO DO DURING AN ACTIVE
THREAT STARTING SCHOOL LOCK
DOWN A MULTI OPTION DRILLS
REPAIR SCHOOLS FOR THE WORST
POSSIBLE SITUATIONS THANK YOU
AND ASK FOR YOUR I'VE. THERE
WAS WITHOUT CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROOM. IS OUR VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A- ALL MEMBERS OF
THE DESIRE TO VOTE. WELL CLOSE
ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY TWO NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES THIS IS
FILE ITEM. TWO TWO SEVEN. SB
FIVE FIFTY ONE SEPARATE SENATE
BILL FIVE FIFTY ONE BY SENATOR
JACKSON AND ACTUALLY THE OIL
AND GAS MR MURATSUCHI. THANK
YOU I AM PRESENTING GUYS SENATE
BILL FIVE FIVE ONE AND SIT ON
WE HAVE A CENTER JACKSON THIS
IS A IMPORTANT TRANSPARENCY
MEASURE WITH NO UP REGISTERED
OPPOSITION. TO REQUIRE ALL OIL
AND GAS OPERATORS TO REPORT TO
THE DIVISION OF OIL GAS AND
GEOTHERMAL RESOURCES OR DOCTOR
AT LEAST ONCE EVERY FIVE YEARS
pWITH ACCURATE AND THOROUGH
ASSESSMENT OF THE COST TO
DECOMMISSION AND RE MEDIATE.
THEIR PRODUCTION FACILITIES I
HAVE IN MY HAND HERE A LETTER
FROM WEST BUT DATE IS SEPTEMBER
SIXTH REMOVING THEIR
OPPOSITION. I REPEAT THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER MURATSUCHI.
THE BLESSEDNESS GONZALEZ.
SENIOR DISCLOSURE BAKER GLOBAL.
DESIRABLE ALL MEMBERS OF DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF THE
DESIRE TO VOTE
. ROM
. ANYBODY
ANYBODY. MR MURATSUCHI. ALMOST
MOVED TO CALL. ERICA. CLARK
WELL CLOSER ALL. TELL YOU ABOUT
AS FORTY ONE KNOWS FOURTEEN.
THAT MEASURE PASSES. PASSWORD
CAM FILE ITEM TO TWENTY EIGHT
FILE ITEM TO. TWENTY NINE IS SB
FIVE EIGHTY NINE. SENATE BILL
FIVE EIGHTY NINE BY SENATOR
BATES AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
SUBSTANCE ABUSE PROGRAMS MISTER
ROWE THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
RISE PERCENT SB FIVE EIGHTY
NINE IN BEHALF OF CENTER BATES
SB FIVE EIGHTY NINE PROHIBITS
AN OPERATOR OF A SPECIFIED
RECOVERY AND TREATMENTFACILITY
FROM PROVIDING ANY PERFORM OF
FALSE ADVERTISING OR MARKETING
SERVICES THE BILL OF SB FIVE
EIGHTY NINE IS PROTECT
INDIVIDUALS WITH ADDICTION FROM
BEING TREATED ADVERSELY. AND
ENSURE THAT THEY ARE RECEIVING
THE TREATMENT THAT THEY ARE
PROMISE MARKETERS MARKETERS WHO
KNOWINGLY WILLFULLY MAKE FALSE
STATEMENTS WHETHER AN
ADVERTISING OR BY DIRECT
COMMUNICATION WITH CURRENT OR
POTENTIAL PATIENTS SHOULD BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE THANK YOU AND
I. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR EITHER.
HE WAS WRONG SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE. COUPLE OF
THE ROLE. DESIRE TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE ABOUT. ALL
MEMBERS OF. RESERVE OF. THE.
CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT
I SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES. PAST RETAIN
ABOUT TWO THIRTY. WELL IN TWO
THIRTY ONE. IS SB SIX FORTY
SEVEN CORPORATE RATE SENATE
BILL SIX FORTY SEVEN BY SENATOR
MITCHELL AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO HAZARDOUS
SUBSTANCES. MR MURATSUCHI.
THANK YOU I RISE TO PRESENT
SENATE BILL SIX FOUR SEVEN ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR MITCHELL FOR
ANY PARENTS GRANDPARENTS
AUNTIES AND UNCLES WHO EVER
BEEN CONCERNED ABOUT TO LEAD
AND CADMIUM IN CHILDREN'S
JEWELRY THIS BILL IS
STRENGTHENING IS CALIFORNIA'S
REGULATIONS ESTABLISHING A
SCIENCE BASED STANDARDS THAT
HAVE BEEN ADOPTED IN THE
EUROPEAN UNION THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION AS WELL AS IN
CANADA. THIS BILL IS ENJOYED NO
NO VOTES AND STRONG BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AYE VOTE. THANK REST MURATSUCHI
SEEN NO DISCUSSION DEBATE
CORPORAL OF THE ROLE. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS
FOR THE SERVER. WELL CULTURAL
TIES BUT I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES HIGHLIGHTED
TO THIRTY TWO IS SB SIX SEVENTY.
SENATE BILL SIX SEVENTY BY
SENATOR MCGUIRE AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TELECOMMUNICATIONS
DECLARING THEIR IT'S EITHER UP
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. BUT
WHAT. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
SB SIX SEVENTY BY SENATOR
MCGUIRE IS A SIMPLE MEASURE TO
MITIGATE THE RISKS DURING TIMES
OF TOTAL CRISIS AND PHONE
OUTAGES. BY REQUIRING
TELECOMMUNICATIONS PROVIDERS
REPORT NINE ONE ONE SERVICE
OUTAGES OUTAGES AFFECTING
EMERGENCY ALERT WARNING
TECHNOLOGIES. TO THE CALIFORNIA
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES IN
REAL TIME. CURRENTLY WHEN
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SERVICES GO
DOWN AFFECTING NINE ONE ONE
SERVICE OR THE ABILITY FOR
EMERGENCY OFFICIALS TO SEND
ALERTS. TELECOMMUNICATIONS ARE
NOT THE COMPANIES ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO REPORT REAL TIME
INFORMATION ABOUT THE LOCATION
OF THE OUTAGE HOW MANY
INDIVIDUALS ARE AFFECTED AND
WHAT THE ESTIMATED TIME OF
REPAIR IS. SB SIX SEVENTY WOULD
REQUIRE CALLOW YES TO SET
THRESHOLD THROUGH REGULATIONS
WHEN PROVIDERS OF
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SERVICES
WOULD NEED TO REPORT AN OUTAGE
OF NINE ONE ONE SERVICE OR
AFFECTING ALERTING AND WARNING
CAPABILITIES. HE'S REGULATIONS
NEED TO BE COMPLETE BY JULY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY SB SIX SEVENTY
WOULD ALSO REQUIRE PROVIDERS OF
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SERVICES TO
NOTIFY CALLAWAY YES WHENEVER
THERE WAS A NINE ONE ONE
SERVICE OUTAGE. OR ANY OUTAGE
AFFECTING EMERGENCY WARNING
CAPABILITIES HITTING THE YES
CREATED THRESHOLDS WITHIN SIXTY
MINUTES OF THE OUTAGE. CALLOW
THE YES WOULD THEN BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR NOTIFYING THE
AFFECTED LOCAL COUNTY. YES THIS
WOULD ENSURE THAT ALL EMERGENCY
FIRST OFFICIALS ARE GETTING THE
INFORMATION THEY NEED TO KEEP
RESIDENTS SAFE. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. THEY THAT
WOULD SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE
OR WILL OPEN THE ROLE. THE
CEREMONY ALL MEMBERS VOTERS AT
ABOUT. ALL MEMBERS OF THE
DESIRE TO VOTE WELL. CLOSE ROLE
TIVER I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES PHONE TWO THIRTY
THREE IS. SORRY AYE AYES SIXTY
SIX DOES YOUR ON THE URGENCY I
SIXTY SIX NO ZERO ON THE BILL
THE MEASURE PASSES. KATIE. FIVE
TO THIRTY THREE IS SB SIX
NINETY SIX CORPORATION. SENATE
BILL SIX NINETY SIX BY SENATOR
UMBERG ACTUALLY TO LECTIONIS
OCCURRING THERE IT'S EITHER UP
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
MITCHELL OF. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS. BECAUSE THIS IS THE
IMPETUS FOR THIS BILL IS TO
REDUCE VOTER CONFUSION AND
EFFECTUATE VOTER INTENT IN
ORDER TO REDUCE VOTER CONFUSION
ESPECIALLY AMONGST VOTERS WHO
WISH NOT TO REGISTER WITH ANY
PARTY AND STAY INDEPENDENT OF
POLITICAL PARTIES. THIS BILL
WERE PAID IT THE NAME OF A
POLITICAL PARTY FROM INCLUDING
THE WORD INDEPENDENT TO DECLINE
TO STATE OR NO PARTY PREFERENCE
OR ANY VARIATION OF THOSE
WORDS. ON BEHALF OF ELECTIONS
SENATE CHAIR CENTER I'M BURKE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE. THANK
YOU MISTER LOWE. SEEN NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM. CLARK LIBERAL. THE
CEREMONY ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE. CLICK WELL. CLOSER ALL
TIED ABOUT ICE FIFTY FIVE DOES
TWELVE ON THE URGENCY AYE AYES
SIXTY FIVE KNOWS TWELVE ON THE
MEASURE. THE BILL PASSES. THIS
IS FILE ON TWO THIRTY FOUR SB
SEVEN OH FOR COVERAGE. SENATE
BILL SEVEN OH FOUR BY SENATOR
BRADFORD IN OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
OF TELECOMMUNICATIONS. MR
GARCIA HAD MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES SB SEVEN OH FOUR BY
THE MEMBER FROM GARDEN GROVE
WERE GUARDINO CORRECTION.
UPDATES AND IMPROVE THE
LIFELINE UNIVERSAL TELEPHONE
SERVICE PROGRAM TO INCREASE
PARTICIPATION AMONG ELIGIBLE
LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS AND
BETTER ACCOMMODATE WONDERFUL
POPULATIONS RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YA VOTE. THANK YOU SIR
SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE. CLUB
THE ROLE. CEREMONIAL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE ABOUT. ALL MEMBERS
OF. THE DESERVE A. AND ONE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSER ALL. HIGHS
FIFTY TWO. KNOWS MELENDEZ.
MEASURE BASS. THIS IS. FILE
ITEM TO THIRTY FIVE. SB SEVEN
SIXTEEN CORPORATION SENATE BILL
SEVEN SIXTEEN BY SENATOR
MITCHELL AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY JUVENILES. MR BELOW
KAMALA THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS SB SEVEN SIXTEEN WILL
ENSURE THAT INCARCERATED YOUTH
WITH HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMAS HAVE
ACCESS TO A COLLEGE EDUCATION
AND CAREER VOCATIONAL TRAINING.
PROBATION DEPARTMENTS WILL BE
REQUIRED TO COLLABORATE WITH
PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS AND CAREER
TRAINING TECHNICAL TRAINING
ENTITIES IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
THESE SERVICES EDUCATION AND
VOCATIONAL TRAINING DEVELOPS
OCCUPATIONAL SKILLS AND LEAST
PRODUCTIVE CAREER PATHS WHICH
IN TURN REDUCES RECIDIVISM AND
FUTURE INVOLVEMENT WITH THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM. RECENT
AMENDMENTS REDUCE THE COST OF
THE BILL AND CLARIFY THE ARRAY
OF SERVICES THAT WOULD BE
PROVIDED FOR THESE YOUTH. THIS
BILL HAS ENJOYED NO OPPOSITION
BI PARTISAN SUPPORT AND NO NO
VOTE SO I REQUEST YOUR I'VE A-
NAMES BLOOM SEE NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE. CLARK WELL OVER THE
ROLE. ZERO ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE ABOUT. ALL MEMBERS SO
DESIRABLE. MARK WELL CLOSE ROLL
TIDE BUT I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES. PASS
RETAIN A FELON TWO THIRTY SIX.
IS FILE ITEM. TWO THIRTY SEVEN
WE WILL PASS TEMPORARILY. WE
WILL TAKE UP FILE ITEM TO
THIRTY SEVEN SB SEVEN EIGHTY
FIVE CORPORATION SENATE BILL
SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE BY THE
COMMITTEE ON NATURAL RESOURCES
AND WATER AND ACTUALLY A PUBLIC
RESOURCES. MS FREEMAN THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I'M
PRESENTING SB SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE
THE SENATE NATURAL RESOURCES
AND WATER COMMITTEE BILL WHICH
MAKES SEVERAL NON CONTROVERSIAL
MINOR TECHNICAL CHANGES THE
STATUTE. THESE INCLUDE AMONG
OTHER THINGS EXTENDING THE
SUNSET ON APARTMENT EFFICIENT
WILDLIFE INVASIVE SPECIES
PROGRAM. AND MINOR CLARIFYING
UPDATES AFFECTING THE STATE
COASTAL CONSERVANCY STATE PARKS
THE STATE LANDS COMMISSION THE
HOT HOPE TOGGLE REGIONAL
PLANNING COMPACT AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION.
THERE IS NO OPPOSITION TO THIS
MEASURE AND IS REASON RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. A MISS FRIEDMAN.
SAYING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
WELL OPEN THE ROLE MEMBERS. IS
THERE A VOTE ALL MEMBERS OF THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WE DESIRE TO VOTE. CLICK
WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE
SIXTY NO ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES FILE AND TWO THIRTY
EIGHT IS SB FIVE EIGHTY SIX.
SENATE BILL FIVE EIGHTY SIX BY
SENATOR ROTH AND ACTOR MEANING
TO COMMUNITY COLLEGES. MR
HOLDEN. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS ON BEHALF
OF SENATOR ROTH I'D LIKE TO A
PERCENT I SB FIVE EIGHTY SIX
IT'S BACK FOR YOUR APPROVAL
AFTER HAVING BEEN. A RETURN TO
THE SIMPLY TO INCLUDE CHAPTER
NOW LANGUAGE SP FIVE EIGHTY SIX
PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
LOCAL WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD'S TO WORK CLOSELY WITH
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND HIGH
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AS THEY
DEVELOP THEIR COLLEGE AND
CAREER ACCESS PATHWAY PROGRAMS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
ABOUT. THANK IN THIS HOLDEN.
SAYING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE. VOTE ON
MEMBERS OF DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
CLARK WELL. THOSE ARE ALL TIED
VOTE. AYE AYES SIXTY NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES THIS IS
FILE ITEM TWO THREE NINE SB
THREE NINETY NINE CORPORATION
SENATE BILL THREE NINETY NINE
BY SENATOR ATKINS ACTUALLY
PEACE OFFICERS. KAMLAGER-DOVE
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I AM
PRESENTING SB THREE NINE NINE
ON BEHALF OF PRESIDENT PRO TEM
TONI ATKINS SB THREE NINETY
NINE ADDS TO ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
MEMBERS TO THE COMMISSION ON
PEACE OFFICER STANDARDS AND
TRAINING ALSO KNOWN AS POST TO
BE APPOINTED BY THE SENATE
PRESIDENT PRO TEM AND THE
SPEAKER OF THE ASSEMBLY WHO ARE
NOT PEACE OFFICERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MS
KAMLAGER-DOVE C. NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE CARPAL OF THE ROLE.
CEREMONY. ALL MEMBERS OF THE
CEREMONY. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. CLICK WELL CLOSER
ALL TYLER I SIXTY SEVEN. NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO TAKE UP
SOME ADDITIONAL ITEMS ON THE
SENATE. THIRD READING FILE.
THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY
TWO. FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY TWO
SB FIVE NINETY ONE THE CLERK
WILL READ SENATE BILL FIVE
NINETY ONE BY SENATOR GALGIANI
AND ACTUALLY TO INCARCERATED
PERSONS THE SHOW LACKEY. THANK
YOU SPEAKER MEMBERS SENATE BILL
FIVE NINETY ONE AUTHORIZES
PRACTICING PSYCHIATRISTS OR
PSYCHOLOGISTS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
REHABILITATION OR THE BOARD OF
PAROLE HEARINGS. TAP PROMPT IN
AND- I'M PETER ACCESS TO AN
INMATE TO IS TEMPORARILY HOUSE
OF THE COUNTY CORRECTIONAL
FACILITY. FOR A COUNTY MEDICAL
FACILITY OR STATE TO SIGN
MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDER. TO
ENSURE THAT MENTALLY DISORDERED
OFFENDERS ARE PROPERLY
EVALUATED AND TREATED PURSUANT
TO PENAL CODE SECTION TWENTY
NINE SIXTY TWO. IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT PSYCHOLOGISTS
AND PSYCHIATRISTS EMPLOYED BY
THE S. H. R. CDC ARE AND THE
BOARD OF PAROLE HEARINGS. TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE INMATES
HEALTH RECORDS AND TO THE
INMATE I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
SUPPORT ON THIS MEASURE. THANK
MISS LOCKING. SENIOR DISCUSSION
DEBATE CORP LIBERAL. NUMBER
SEVEN. WE DESIRE TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSER ALL TELL YOU
BUT I SIXTY NO ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES. THIS IS FILE
ITEM ONE THIRTY THREE. SB FIVE
NINETY EIGHT GREGORY SENATE
BILL FIVE NINETY EIGHT BY
SENATOR MORE LOCK AND OTHERS
AND AFTER THE PUBLIC AGENCY
FINANCIAL REPORTING THE
STRUGGLE TO THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE ON BEHALF OF
CENTER MORE LOCKED TO PRESENT
SB FIVE NINETY EIGHT THE OPEN
OF FINANCIAL STATEMENTS ACT.
THIS BILL WOULD ESTABLISH A
COMMISSION TO CREATE A COMMON
MACHINE READABLE FORMAT FOR THE
REPORTING OF MUNICIPAL FINANCE
DATA THIS WILL NOT ONLY MAKE
THE PROCESS OF REPORTING THIS
DATA MORE EFFICIENT AND
TRANSPARENT WILL ALSO IMPROVE
LIQUIDITY IN MUNICIPAL BOND
MARKETS IN CALIFORNIA. THIS
EFFORT HAS BEEN ENDORSED BY A
WIDE VARIETY OF STAKEHOLDERS
BOTH STATEWIDE AND AT THE
NATIONAL LEVEL AS WELL AS
ENJOYED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
BOTH CHAMBERS. I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MISTER OBERNOLTE SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CARP WILL
OPEN THEIR OWN. DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS OF. DESIRABLE. WELL
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY
FOUR NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY
NINE. SB SIX THIRTY NINE. THE
CLERK WILL READ SENATE BILL SIX
THIRTY NINE BY SENATOR MITCHELL
AND ACTUALLY THE HEALING ARTS
MR STONE. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AND WITH ALL
DUE RESPECT TO OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM HEALDSBURG. THE ALL THE
TIME THAT I WOULD NOT WANT TO
BE MAKING A DECISION ABOUT
FINANCING A MEDICAL PROCEDURES
WITH SOMEONE IS STANDING OVER
ME WITH. SHARP INSTRUMENTS
ABOUT TO PUT INTO MY MOUTH. BUT
IN FACT THAT'S ONE OF THINGS
THAT OFTEN HAPPENS THAT JUST
BEFORE A MEDICAL PROCEDURE.
THERE IS. A PATIENT IS THEN
OFFERED THE ABILITY TO FINANCE
IT THROUGH A MEDICAL CREDIT
CARD OR OTHER. MECHANISM AND
WHAT THIS BILL DOES WIDE
SENATOR MITCHELL'S SB SIX
THIRTY NINE BILL DOES. IS MAKE
SURE THAT THOSE TRANSACTIONS
ARE HAPPENING AT A TIME WHEN
THE PATIENT HAS THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BETTER UNDERSTAND WHAT IS
HAPPENING. TO MAKE APPROPRIATE
CHOICES ABOUT THE KIND OF
MECHANISM THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
USE TO FINANCE THEIR- THERE
MEDICAL PROCEDURE. THIS BILL IS
THE CONSUMER PROTECTION BILL
AND SENATOR MITCHELL HAS BEEN
WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH ALL
OF THE STAKEHOLDERS TO MAKE.
SURE THAT ENSURE THAT THIS WILL
BE IMPLEMENTABLE AT THE SAME
TIME PROTECTING CONSUMERS. WHO
NEED TO BE ABLE TO MAKE COGENT
DECISIONS ABOUT HOW THEY'RE
GOING TO FINANCE MEDICAL
PROCEDURES AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTES.
THANK YOU MISTER STONE SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE. QUIRK
LIBERAL. SORRY ABOUT. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS OF OUR DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ALL TIED
THAT MEASURE PASSES THIS IS
FILE ITEM ONE FORTY ONE. SB
SEVEN FORTY TWO. GREGORY SENATE
BILL SEVEN FORTY TWO BY SENATOR
ALLEN AND OTHERS NATALIE TO
TRANSPORTATION. MR GRAY. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS SB
SEVEN FORTY TWO REMOVES
PROHIBITIONS IN CALIFORNIA LAW
WHICH PRESENT PREVENT A
PASSENGER FOR WRITING ON AN
INTERCITY RAIL THRUWAY BUS
UNLESS HE OR SHE IS THE ROAD ON
THE TRAIN BEFORE CATCHING THAT
BUS OR IS RIDING ON THE BUS TO
CATCH A TRAIN THIS IS A
COMPROMISE BETWEEN PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE OPERATORS THAT WILL
FILL FACILITATE BETTER
INTERCONNECTED BODY. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK DR. THANK YOU
MISTER GRAY. SEE NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE CARPAL OF THE ROLE. IS
OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS OF THE
DECIDE ABOUT. ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS OUT OF THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE TELL YOU WHAT I
SIXTY TWO NO ZERO. THAT MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
JUMP TO FILE ITEM ONE FORTY
FOUR. SB SIX SEVENTY SIX.
SENATE BILL SIX SEVENTY SIX BY
SENATOR BRADFORD AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO TRANSPORTATION
ELECTRIFICATION THIS
BOERNER HORVATH YES MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS SB SIX SEVENTY
SIX BY SENATOR BRADFORD
INSURANCE THAT WE ARE WITH THAT
WE START ADDRESSING THE GREAT
IMPACTS OF ELECTRIC VEHICLE
CHARGING BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
EASY'S AT PEAK CHARGING WILL
DEMAND EQUIVALENT POWER OF AN
ENTIRE NUCLEAR JET REACTOR LEFT
AND MANAGE THIS WILL CREATE
MANY NEW COSTS. THIS BILL
ACCELERATES THE WORK TO
OPTIMIZE THAT NEW LOAD TO THE
BENEFIT OF ALL RATE PAYERS THE
STATE'S BEEN DISCUSSING VEHICLE
GREAT IMMIGRATION FOR YEARS
IT'S TIME TO GET SERIOUS ABOUT
THIS PROBLEM I PLEASE ASK YOU
FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU MS
BOERNER HORVATH C. NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE. OUR CLUB THE
ROLE. THE CEREMONY ALL MEMBERS
VOTE. IT IS OUT OF OUT. ALL
MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF A. CLERK
WILL CLOSE ROLE. TALLY THE VOTE
I SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES
. MEMBERS WE ARE
IN A HOLDING PATTERN AT THIS
TIME WE CAN TAKE VOTE CHANGES
MR MAIENSCHEIN. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. SB TWO SEVENTY
SEVEN I TO NOT VOTING VOTE
CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN SENATE BILL TWO
SEVENTY SEVEN I TO NOT VOTING.
MEMBERS I GOTTA GO LEFT TO
RIGHT MY LEFT TO MY RIGHT MR
GLORIA. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I VOTE CHANGE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TODD GLORIA FILE ITEM
SIXTEEN AB ELEVEN NINETY FIVE I
TO KNOW. THE CHANGE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GLORIA AS AN ABLE LEVIN
NINETY FIVE I TO KNOW. MR WHEN.
IRWIN SB ONE TWO SEVEN NO TO
I'D- THE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OR WHEN SENATE BILL ONE TWO
SEVEN NO TO I. AND MS LIMóN.
THANK YOU VOTE CHANGE IT SB ONE
FIVE THREE I'D TO NOT VOTING.
THE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LIMON SENATE BILL ONE FIVE
THREE I TO NOT VOTING. M. IS
PETRIE-NORRIS. THANK YOU I
DON'T CHANGE PETRIE-NORRIS SB
ONE FIFTY THREE I TO NOW. THE
CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS SENATE BILL ONE
FIVE THREE I TO KNOW. AND MR
TING. VOTE CHANGE AB ELEVEN
NINETY FIVE I TO NOT. THE
CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER TEAM AS
A LABEL ELEVEN NINETY FIVE I
IT'S NOT VOTING. AND MISS WICKS
I HAVE A CHANGE SB FOUR FIVE
SEVEN I'D TO KNOW. THE CHANGE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS SENATE
BILL FOUR FIFTY SEVEN I TO KNOW.
M. IS FRIEDMAN. THANK YOU SP
FOUR FIVE SEVEN I TO NOT VOTING
FRIEDMAN VOTE CHANGE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN SENATE
BILL FOUR FIFTY SEVEN I TO NOT
VOTING. MISTER COOPER VOTE
CHANGE FILE ITEM TO TWENTY SB
FOUR SIXTY EIGHT. I DO NOT
VOTING. THE CHANGE IS ONLY
MEMBER COOPER SENATE BILL FOUR
SIXTY EIGHT I TO NOT VOTING.
AND DOCTOR CHEN. MODE CHANGE SB
ONE NINE SIX NOTES I'D. THE
CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER TEN
SENATE BILL ONE NINETY SIX NO
TO I. PHOTO CHANGE MULLIN. SB
FIVE TWENTY I TEND NOT VOTING.
THE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MULLIN SENATE BILL FIVE TWENTY
I TO NOT VOTING
. WE'RE STILL
ONE VOTE CHANGES AT THE MOMENT
DOCTOR CHEN VOTE CHANGE SB FIVE
FIFTY NOTES I'D. THE CHANGE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TRêN SENATE
BILL FIVE FIFTY NOTES HI.
MISTER CALDERON FOR YOUR
PROCEDURAL MOTION PURSUANT TO
ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY SIX I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RE
REFER ITEM ONE EIGHTY NINE SB
ONE ATKINS TO THE NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION THE REQUEST IS
GRANTED. AND MEMBERS I AM
PREPARED TO LIFT THE CALL.
PREPARE TO LIVE THE CALL ON
FILE ITEM TWO OH FIVE THIS IS
SENATE BILL ONE SEVENTY SIX THE
CLERK WILL POST. ALL MEMBERS OF
THE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE CLARK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE TALLY THE VOTE
AYE AYES FORTY FOUR KNOWS FIVE.
THAT MEASURE PASSES
.
ENTERTAINING ADDITIONAL VOTE
CHANGES AT THIS TIME MR KANSEN
CHU. VOTE CHANGE CHOOSE TO SB.
SORRY SB FOUR FIVE SEVEN FROM I
TO ABSENT. THE CHANGE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KANSEN CHU SENATE BILL
FOUR FIFTY SEVEN I TO NOT
VOTING
. ADDITIONALCHANGES
MISTER RODRIGUEZ NOW FILE ITEM
ONE SIXTY TWO SENATE BILL THREE
TWENTY NINE FROM I DO NOT
VOTING. VOTE CHANGE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RODRIGUEZ SENATE BILL
THREE TWENTY NINE I IT'S NOT
VOTING. ANNOUNCEMENTS. SESSION
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS.
WEDNESDAY SEPTEMBER ELEVENTH.
FLOOR SESSION TEN AM TO SIX PM
THURSDAY SEPTEMBER TWELFTH
FLOOR SESSION TEN AM TO SIX PM.
FRIDAY SEPTEMBER THIRTEENTH.
FOR SESSION FROM TEN AM TO WHO
KNOWS WHEN. ALL OTHER ITEMS
REMAINING WE PASS RETAIN ALL
MOTION SHALL BE CONTINUED
SECONDARY NO FURTHER BUSINESS
I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION
TO ADJOURN. MISS WALDRON MOVES
MISTER GRAY SECONDS THAT THIS
HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL
WEDNESDAY SEPTEMBER ELEVENTH.
AT TEN AM IN A QUORUM CALLS
LIFTED
. GONZALEZ AB ELEVEN
NINETY FIVE BY O'DONNELL I TO
KNOW. THE CHANGE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GONZALEZ ASSEMBLY WILL
LIVE IN NINETY FIVE I TO KNOW
.
BUT WE DON'T DO ANYTHING YET.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CARTY AB ELEVEN
NINETY FIVE I DID NOT VOTING.
THE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY SENATE ASSEMBLY BILL
ELEVEN NINETY FIVE I IT'S NOT
VOTING